welcome everyone to the final day of the
week on our digital marketing journey by
simply learn on day 5 we looked at the
various digital marketing tools today we
are going to learn about paid marketing
paid marketing is one of the easiest and
quickest ways to help customers discover
your brand and offerings with paid
marketing you can purchase advertising
that allows you to Target an audience
instead of waiting for them to find you
organically paid advertising is
measurable and is easier than SEO in
this video we will learn how someone can
make use of platforms such as Google
Facebook YouTube and Instagram for
advertising and growing their business
so let's begin with understanding how
marketing Works through Google ads
YouTube ads Facebook ads and Instagram
ads when you're setting up your brand
and you need to make sure reaches the
Right audience and provide the best
results there's really only one place to
turn to it's one of the largest online
advertising platforms really in the
world and that's on Google and so today
we're going to talk about how to
advertise on Google so thank you for
joining my name is Rob Sanders I'm with
simply learn and we're going to talk
about all things Google when it comes to
advertising so thanks for joining and
let's get right to it and talk about
Google ads and its effect with
advertising so we're going to start out
with what are Google ads well Google ads
used to be called Google AdWords and
it's been around a good while almost 20
years now so really Google has grown at
a really rapid Pace it's become one of
Google's main sources of revenue uh you
could say probably in the 90 percent
tile of its Revenue comes from Google
ads and when we say Google ads we mean
people who pay for advertising on
google.com so Google that's really what
it does is it provides services that
fall under the category of PPC which
stands for pay-per-click UA Also may
hear Google ads or PPC referred to as
cost per click or CPC or sponsored
search really what it comes down to it's
a model so when you advertise on
google.com and somebody clicks on your
ad basically you're paying Google for
the click okay so it's just really a
business model where an Advertiser pays
Google to have their advertisement on
google.com but they only pay Google when
they get the click so that's really in a
nutshell how it works for advertisers if
I want to advertise my business I can go
to Google ads and say Google place my ad
on google.com and then if my ad does get
shown on google.com somebody clicks on
it it's just as simple as I pay Google a
fee so Google ads is just an online
advertising platform platform developed
by Google with which advertisers can pay
to display ads they can offer up their
services there's video involved there's
obviously mobiles involved so you got
all the necessary devices and platforms
available in Google's ecosystem so for
example if I go to Google Search even if
I type in you know what is Google ads
here I could see a total of 1.8 billion
results for what our Google ads as my
search query so in search you got a lot
of different things going on here you
have organic results you have videos
that are being pulled from YouTube you
got a Knowledge Graph here you got
featured Snippets you got an organic
listing but really at the top this is
what we're going to focus on today we're
going to talk about sponsored search so
you can see here for this particular
keyword query that I typed in what are
Google ads really two sponsored search
or pay-per-click ads appeared now now if
I happen to click on any one of these
two and go to that particular
advertisements website they're going to
pay Google a specific cost per click so
that's how it looks on google.com it
really depends on your query and what
ads show up but the great thing about
you know Google ads is they make it
known for the user who's doing the
search query what the ad is so here I
can easily pick out what's an ad a
sponsored search or pay-per-click at and
what's not because if it's a
pay-per-click ad or an Advertiser
advertising on google.com I'm going to
be able to see this little box here this
is AD next to the listing and so by
displaying that little logo their ad
it's letting the end user know the
person who's searching know that hey
this is an Advertiser who is advertising
their product or service on google.com
Okay so that's how you can differentiate
between paid search and organic search
organ search here or even down here
doesn't have that little add box next to
the listing so you know if it doesn't
have a little ad box you know it's a
paid search hat now why do we want to
advertise on Google ads because it
increases visibility to high quality
audience so what I mean by that is you
know search is really a great place to
advertise because you're meeting the
consumer halfway meaning somebody's
typing something in and your ad is there
to help them find what they're looking
for so Google ads advertises your
product or service to the relevant
audience to ensure the users perform the
action required of them so it's really a
great way to get quality audience to
your website because if somebody types
in something and you happen to offer
what they're looking for basically your
ads going to show up somebody clicks on
it you pay Google for the click and you
get quality traffic and return so the
other great benefit to being on Google
ads is increases brand awareness so it's
a great way to get your product and
brand out there Google has a vast
network uh uh also known as the display
network but even on google.com the
search Network itself the search engine
itself means of people use it every day
in fact here in the United States it's
been said or studied that you know
people over the age of 18 use search at
least once a day at least once a day
here in the United States so you can
figure that's millions and millions of
people so it's a great way to get your
brand in front of a large captive
audience okay so top of Mind awareness
refers to a brand of product being the
first one that comes to a customer's
mind when thinking about a particular
industry or category so it really does
provide top of Mind awareness another
benefit to being on Google ads is
retargeting so when we say the word
retargeting in marketing that means you
know showing our ad to somebody who's
already been to our website so we can
use Google's Display Network or we can
run remarketing lists for search ads
right on google.com to ensure that we're
targeting those folks who have already
been to our website and have not
performed a function that we want them
to perform such as converting or buying
something or downloading something or
subscribing to a newsletter or visiting
a certain page okay so if somebody
doesn't do what we want them to do it's
okay maybe they're ready to commit to
our product or service and that's why
Google offers up retargeting so it
allows us to reach that audience a
second time so they're going to be
familiar with their product they're
going to be familiar their website
because they've been there and so we can
offer up a very unique specific ad to
that audience so that's a really good
benefit to being on Google ads so some
other benefits here increased
intelligence so you know we can
certainly get data about who is coming
to our audience so we can look at what
device what you know browser Etc so we
can really gain some information about
who's coming to the website but we could
certainly measure our performance so
with Google we're paying cost per click
and So based on that model you know we
can certainly measure what keywords what
ads are generating traffic to the
website and how much we're paying for
that okay and if that traffic turns out
to be a lead we can measure that against
that specific keyword or ad or campaign
so we can certainly measure our
performance all the way down the keyword
level and can we can measure up against
how many conversions or what we're
paying for those conversions so Google
ads is a very highly quantitative
approach to advertising because there's
lots of numbers involved and you're
constantly collecting information about
your advertising on google.com and its
Network and another benefit really it's
high flexibility so Google ads has a
number of different options so we can
customize our ads based on an audience
based on a keyword based on a specific
website based on retargeting so we
really have a lot of options not to
mention the number of options in terms
of the ad format text ads Dynamic
responsive ads video ads display ads so
Google ads has very flexible options in
terms of advertising and we're going to
talk about some of those as we move
along here today so another big benefit
here and this is what I always suggest
is if you're not ranking organically
then you might want to consider Google
ads because as we've shown here in our
example if I go back to our example a
couple minutes ago you know if you want
to bid on the keyword what are Google
ads why would you bid on that well it's
relevant to your business maybe you're
in the digital marketing industry and
you want to help folks who need help and
advertising on Google ads but what if
you want to be found for that
organically well if you're not found for
it organically then you can bid on it so
it definitely is a good option if you're
not ranking for a particular keyword
organically so it serves as almost an
option I always say that you know search
is like a fruit bowl okay you have
apples and oranges in that fruit bowl
well the Orange is organic search and
the apple is paid search they're
different approaches but they share the
same fruit bowl the same real estate so
you can really really help yourself by
using Google ads to complement what
you're doing organically so if you're
not ranked organically for keyword you
can certainly use Google ads if you are
ranked for specific keywords and it's a
highly competitive industry then you can
use Google ads to help you leverage the
amount of clicks you get from that ad so
it's okay to be organically listed and
have a paid search listing at the same
time so if we go back to our example
here we could see wordstream.com has a
paid ad and here we can see just two
spots below organically they're showing
up with organic listing so you could
certainly be in both positions to try
and maximize your clicks so it's
definitely a good strategy to run with
Google ads on top of everything we
mentioned in terms of measurement
flexibility Google ads does offer a
really good incentive to advertise and
let's not lose focus that again search
is really the only medium in which
you're meeting somebody halfway based on
what they're looking for and when I say
halfway meaning your ad is going to
appear for somebody who's looking for
something whether that be food a cafe a
plumber a doctor or directions search is
there to serve that that person needs
there's no other advertisement platform
or another Channel out there in terms of
advertising that reacts the same way
whether that be TV or radio or email
marketing or affiliate marketing search
is unique in that regard so search
engine results pages are the pages that
are displayed by search engines in
response to an ad so that's serp and so
you could certainly you know be listed
in the serps OR also known as organic
search but the great thing is Google ads
is there to help you get your brand or
product in front of that user looking
for a specific need or service so let's
shift Focus now and talk about the
various formats in Google ads on Google
search we have text ads so text ads are
the only ad format on Google Search and
so here you can see in this example you
have a headline so not only do you have
one headline you have three headlines in
one ad so JBL headphones one headline
wide range of headphones second headline
amazon.in third headline so you have
three headlines and the great thing
about Google ads with with this text
format is that you can have up to two
descriptions of 90 characters so the
headlines are up to 30 characters the
descriptions are up to 90 characters and
so you can really write some specific
information about your ad about your
product about your service okay and the
ad is also going to contain what we call
AD extensions so here you can see shop
by category in-ear headphones on-ear
headphones those are all site link
extensions meaning they're going to link
to something on your website and so the
purpose of the extension is to help get
the click so the reason why you're
running Google ads is to get the click
you want to generate the click you want
to get that traffic to your website so
by writing three headlines and writing
to description lines and adding
extensions to your ad all help you get
that click yes you're going to pay
Google for the click but that's the
whole purpose is to generate the click
from search because remember search is
there to respond to somebody's need or
query and so if you get the click on
your ad chances are it's going to be a
highly relevant visitor to your website
so Google offers up a lot of opportunity
for you to write a lot of information in
your text ad on Google for google.com so
Google also has other formats and so
they also have responsive display ads so
when we say responsive we mean Google
can serve up a specific image from your
website based on what somebody's looking
for based on the page that they went to
so these ads are all responsive they
adjust their size appearance and format
depending on the space available so
responsive can also be text text and or
image and so the whole point of response
is if you have a large website let's
just say with a lot of different
products and categories like Amazon well
it's hard to write static ads for
thousands of particular categories and
products so why not let Google do the
heavy left it why not let Google serve
up the images and ads based on what
somebody looked at on your website and
so that's the whole idea behind
responsive ads is it allows Google to
you know show the particular ad that's
most relevant to that user so it's a
really a great option when you're
advertising on Google you have image ads
as well so image ads are as we mentioned
part of responsive or they can just be
static and so here you can see an
example from slack okay you can see just
an image app but the great thing about
image ads is you have a lot of different
size options so 468 by 60 250 by 250 160
by 600 all these are pixel sizes so you
have a lot of different size variations
when you run image ads okay so you don't
have to run a small image ad let's just
say in comparison to Facebook where you
have a thumbnail okay and one size for a
particular image ad on Facebook versus
Google you have multiple both sizes that
you can choose from in terms of running
image ads so image ads are really a
great option if you're going to
advertise on Google okay you also have
app promotional ads these ads are used
to drive app downloads and engagement so
here you can see an example for Uber so
that's another option too if you have an
app and you really want to drive
engagement for that app and then you
also have video so Google owns YouTube
so you can run advertisements video
advertisements on YouTube so they could
be Standalone or they can be inserted
into other streaming video content as
say pre-roll meaning people are going to
look at your ad before actually watching
the actual video they went to YouTube
for so you have a lot of different
options with video advertisements on
YouTube so the other AD format you have
on Google are shopping ads and shopping
ads are really a great way to get your
product in front of the right user so
some somebody's looking for shoes or
running shoes it's an opportunity for
you to run shopping ads so you could put
that particular shoe with a description
with the price with your brand name in
front of that user and so with a cost
per click model if a user clicks on your
shopping ad then chances are they're
probably going to convert because they
could see the product they could see the
price they could see the product name
they could see the brand and so it's an
opportunity for you to really drive high
quality traffic to your site with the
opportunity to convert somebody at a
very high rate so shopping ads are
really good because it prevents unwanted
clicks if somebody clicks on that ad
they're definitely interested so let's
take a look on search to see how that
looks so if I go to Google Search and I
just type in running shoes so my search
results are going to list not only some
paid ads but a lot of different options
on shopping ads so here I can certainly
scroll around and see all the different
brand names I could see the price point
if I hover over it I can actually see
you know some other information about it
like reviews return policy so if I
actually click on this ad chances are
I'm going to buy it otherwise why would
I click on the ad as an end user and so
that's the great thing about shopping
ads it gives you the advertiser an
opportunity to really get your products
in front of people who are looking for
your product or service and given that
you're listing the price if they like
the price and they click on your ad
they're probably going to go ahead and
follow through with the conversion so it
doesn't necessarily have to be running
shoes it could be anything that you have
to offer a user so running shopping ads
on Google is a good strategy if you have
products okay so you can showcase these
these shopping ads on Google search by
certainly really giving Google access to
your product inventory connecting in
some reviews connecting in some
information connecting in the pricing
points and voila it's really very fairly
easily to set up Google shopping ads
within Google search and the great thing
about shopping ads is it also pairs
under images and also pairs under
shopping so if I'm on Google search you
know I can go to shopping or I can go to
images and I'll see those same image ads
show up here at the top and I will
certainly see those under shopping as
well so shopping ads allow you to really
showcase your products on Google search
to those looking for that particular
product so it's really a great option
with Google you also have call ADS so
when we say call ADS really call only
ads are great for mobile so when you run
advertisements on Google if you have a
phone number associated with your
business you can certainly add that
phone number to the ad so if somebody's
searching on their mobile device and
your ad is displayed along with your
number if they click on your number
they're actually going to call your
business and Google can track that they
can track how many people click on your
number and even turn that into a
conversion for you so if you have a
phone number associated with your
business it's wise to go ahead and set
up you know what we call a call
extension as part of the app because if
somebody sees that ad with that phone
number on mobile it allows them to
easily just click on the number and call
your business and so Google can track
calls as well so keep that in mind if
you have a phone number and you want to
associate that phone number with an ad
okay so let's move over to where is
Google showing your ads I showed you an
example of Google search so we looked at
text ads we looked at shopping ads on
Google search networks so Google search
Network really allows you to advertise
on Google search so with Google search
if I go back to Google search and and I
go to all I typed in running shoes okay
here I can see shopping ads here I can
see a couple of text ads so you have the
opportunity if you're running only text
ads to show up the top and if you're not
at the top then Google will place you at
the bottom so it really depends on the
keyword that somebody's querying in
Google search so it really depends on
how many people are advertising and so
what Google does if I didn't have any
shopping ads here Google will list a
maximum of four Tech stats at the top
and at the bottom any other ads that
weren't shown at the top will get placed
at the bottom so ideally if you're
running text ads on Google you want to
make sure you're always at the top and I
would say between positions one and
three you always want to make sure
you're at the top okay so you can
certainly measure that remember Google
had has measured performance so you can
measure everything about your ad so if
you're gonna have advertise on Google
with the text ads you want to make sure
you're always at the top so let's have a
look at the different types of search
networks that Google ads is affiliated
with so the first is Google search Okay
so let's focus on Google Search and so
basically when we say Google search or
search sites we really mean google.com
or all Google search engines for that
matter so if you want to advertise to a
mass audience you want to probably start
with google.com because again millions
of people use it on a daily basis and so
if you're advertising on google.com your
ads will appear basically below or above
the search results on a Google search so
if somebody searches for something
depending on the search query they're
going to see results now depending on
the device Oswald so they could be on
mobile or on desktop they could see
sponsored ads or paid ads they could see
local listings and they could see
organic search results so for example
this is what an ad would look like so
let me show you what that looks like on
Google search so if we go for example to
google.com and type in the keyword
classes on digital marketing we could
see some search ads here these ads
appear above some featured Snippets and
the organic search results okay so
depending on a lot of different factors
again I've mentioned this throughout the
webinar there are a lot of factors in
showing up in the top position second
position third position and so forth
okay if I scroll all the way to the
bottom you may even see ads down here
depending on how many people are
actually bidding on the keyword phrase
classes on digital marketing so we could
see simply learn here in the second
position why because again I can see the
logo add here okay so I can see simply
learn using three headlines I can see
simply learn using their two description
lines here and I can see simply learn
using some other extensions with the ad
now all of this is geared towards
getting the click so when you're on
Google search the whole idea is
somebody's looking for something you're
offering that up and so it doesn't even
matter if you're in the top position
ideally you want to be in these top
three positions in order to get the
click okay so that's the whole idea
behind being on Google search if you're
on Google search you have the
opportunity to be at the very top of the
search result or in the top three above
local listings and above organic results
now if I change my search query and
typed in coffee in San Francisco my
search results are going to be
completely different I'm going to see
local listings here okay so this is tied
to Google my business not Google ads
okay so this is completely different so
don't don't mix this up with running ads
on Google search so Google my business
is tied to local listings or Google Maps
and again with desktop which is what I'm
showing you the search result on you're
going to see likely Google local
listings above organic results okay and
if I go back to my previous query of
classes on digital marketing I'm going
to be able to see paid search results
above local and organic listings so in
other words if you're running ads ads
are going to Trump any other type of
results on Google search if you can be
in positions one through three now in
addition to google.com google also has
something called Google search Partners
so if you set up an account and you set
up a campaign in Google ads you have the
option to choose Google search as your
network and then as an alternative or an
additional option you can advertise on
Google search partner sites and so some
of their search Partners can range so
basically these are sites that have
partnered up with Google that's allowing
Google to show ads on their site so the
sites can range anywhere between YouTube
to Amazon to New York Times let's take a
look at an example it could even be
another search engine so if I go to say
ask.com and type in classes on digital
marketing it's a completely different
search engine but I can see the same ad
for simply learn so I can see same I
could see a different headline here
actually but I can see the description
and I can see some site link extensions
and so notice the ad is still at the top
in this case it's in position one and I
can see multiple companies run
advertisements why because I could see
ad next to it and I could see those over
over organic listings so these are
Google search partner listings so you
can opt in to be on other partner sites
that Google or other sites that Google
has partnered up with so you have
options outside of Google search and
that option is Display Network so
Display Network allows you to advertise
elsewhere which is outside of Google
search and if you're going to advertise
on Google's Display Network you have
more ad formats Available to You
including image and including video for
example your ad can be found on a
specific website if you choose to
advertise on the newyorktimes.com or
WebMD or marriott.com you could
certainly do that okay you just need to
tell Google hey this is the site I want
to advertise on so some of the
advantages of being on the Display
Network so if you don't want to
advertise on Google search Okay
google.com you can certainly go to
display and on the display if you're
running display ads or or even video ads
you're going to grab the attention of
potential customers because of the
format of the ad okay so put in your ads
in front of people early on in the
buying cycle can have a very positive
effect so you're basically reaching out
to a large number of people on Google's
Display Network and giving them an
opportunity to see who you are as a
brand and giving them an opportunity to
see what your product is all about so
for me the display network is a good
opportunity get your product and service
in front of a lot of people because this
way the display network works is it's a
millions of websites who want to have
advertising on their site and so you can
really pick and choose a specific site
where your audience is going to be and
get your ad in front of that audience so
you can read really retarget to
potential customers so retargeting as we
said earlier is really reaching out to
people who have already been to your
website and didn't perform a particular
function that you wanted them to perform
meaning somebody came to your website
from Paid search on google.com and they
went to page a and then they left so you
really wanted them to go to page B add a
product to a shopping cart and check out
and purchase that product however if
they didn't do that you could certainly
run ads knowing that they've been to
page a and Page B and you can offer up
that specific ad to that person who's
been to your website and so that's what
retargeting really is all about and you
can retarget on Google's Display Network
so remarketing your product to people
who previously visited your your website
or even your app allows you to really
get your ad in front of a qualified
audience and so you could take advantage
of anal Medics so Google's ads has all
the information you need so let's
actually take a look at some of these
options in Google ads for the Display
Network so if I actually go to Google
ads and I actually go to display
campaigns I can see I have a lot of
different options available to me so if
I click on keywords for example okay I
can choose keywords for my display
campaign so what Google does if you
choose keywords basically what they're
doing is they're going to contextually
place your ad based on the keyword okay
so that's an option for you if you're
not sure what websites to be on with the
Display Network you can certainly just
add keywords and based on those keywords
Google will place your ad on websites
that they deem relevant to the keywords
you choose so you can also choose
demographics so on the Display Network
you can say hey Google I only want to
advertise to say 18 to 24 year olds or
25 to 34 year olds and So based on that
Google is going to place your ads on
websites related to that age demographic
you're interested in on the Display
Network you can also choose topics so if
there's a specific topic that you want
your ad to be associated with you can
certainly do that so Google has a number
of different topics at their disposal so
here if I just choose a particular ad
group now I have specific topics that I
can choose from arts and entertainment
food and drink to news to pets and
animals and so under each one of these
topics I can get really specific so if I
go under science I can see subcategories
under the topic science I can see
chemistry and physics and scientific
institutions and equipment so I can
really pick and choose specific topics
where I want my ads to be shown as I
mentioned already you can pick and
choose specific placements okay so if
you have a specific website that you
want your ad to be shown on you can
certainly let Google know okay you can
also advertise on Gmail you can also
advertise on YouTube so you can really
pick and choose where you want your ads
to be shown so you have all these
different options available to you to me
one of the best options for advertising
on the Display Network because when you
tell Google you have a specific audience
you want to Target and that audience
could be somebody who went to a specific
page or somebody who went to your
website and didn't convert you can
associate that audience with the
campaign and when you associate that
audience with a campaign you can
re-target them with an ad so the display
campaign is very powerful with Google
because you have all these different
options available to you so with Google
ads you can also determine how well
you're reaching your goals which
websites you're running your ads on
which ads are bringing in clicks and
which site gives you maximum value for
the minimum cost so you can see all that
on Google ads so when I actually pick
and choose how I want to Target I can
certainly measure that so for example
audiences or or demographics for example
if I go back to demographics I have all
this data that Google's collected on my
advertising so I can see for example by
age range based on my campaign how many
clicks how many Impressions impressions
are how many times my ads been seen
click-through rate meaning the rate at
which people see my ad and are clicking
on my ad how much I'm paying per click
CPC is cost per click total cost and
conversions how many conversions am I
getting so I could see all this data
available to me in Google ads so it's a
very powerful platform for measuring
performance okay let's talk about how
you can create a Google ad okay so first
thing you want to do is you want to set
up your campaign and you want to align
and goal with that campaign just like we
talked with ads related to Facebook you
always want to align a goal with your
campaign just like we talked about there
we want to do the same thing here on
Google so we have a number of different
options at our disposal so when you run
a campaign why are you running the
campaign so if you're in just to drive
traffic or you're trying to generate
brand awareness okay great you can still
set up that campaign you're just going
to choose the Display Network okay the
Display Network allows you to get your
ad out there on millions of websites so
that people can actually see what your
brand product or service is all about
now if you're into direct response
meaning you're in it for sales and leads
then you probably want to choose
potentially Google search Partners as a
network okay not display but Google
search and the partner sites okay on
Google search so by choosing Google
search as your network it's directory
response so somebody's typing in a
keyword query and you're responding so
that's the whole idea behind Google
search is we want to meet somebody
halfway we want to be able to offer up
the product or service they're looking
for so if sales and leads are what your
campaign goal is all about then you want
to go search network with the option to
choose Google search Partners okay again
if you're into you know driving brand
awareness our product and brand
consideration then maybe you should
choose the Display Network the bottom
line is you need to figure out what the
goal is of the campaign that's the very
most important very first step and most
important step is to figure out what the
goal is of the campaign and once you've
decided that then it's on to setting up
the campaign and in Google you're always
going to have at least one ad group and
what makes up an ad group keywords and
ads so ideally when you set up a
campaign on Google search Network you're
going to choose keywords and those
keywords should be tightly knitted or
tightly themed or in other words be all
relevant to one another in an ad group
so that's what an ad group is keywords
that are relevant to one another okay in
that ad group you're also going to have
an ad so when you choose your keywords
you're going to write an ad for those
keywords so step three is after you set
up the ad group and choose your keywords
you're going to create an ad so let's
take a look at how that looks in Google
ads so if I go to Google ads I can see I
already have an account set up I have a
couple campaigns so let's just say I
have this campaign set up here I'm just
going to call it industrial campaign
okay and if I choose industrial campaign
okay I'm going to then be asked to set
up an ad group now if I set up an ad
group already in that ad group should be
keywords and ads okay so remember when
you set up an ad group you want to
choose your keywords first paying this
keywords should be all related to one
another so for example I could see an ad
group here called fig concentrate well
if I click on this ad group and I look
at the keywords they should all be
related to Fig concentrate so here we go
we can see a few keywords in this ad
group in fact I have 10 of them all
related to Fig concentrate so it's very
very important from a quality score
perspective if you remember when we're
talking about quality score quality
score is based on landing page
experience expected click through and
the ad relevancy to the keyword so if
you can choose a ad group and have all
your keywords related to one another
like I do here with fig concentrate
Google ads platform we can see here I
already have a couple of ads going okay
so ideally if I wanted to I can run more
than just two ads as a best practice as
a best practice you want to have at
least two ads why AI because these two
ads are going to be served up against
each other and ideally the whole idea of
running more than one ad is what Google
can do is start serving up the ad that
is performing better in terms of
click-through rate or in terms of
conversions okay so it doesn't hurt to
even add one or two more ads so here I'm
going to go ahead and add one more ad
here okay so if I click on that plus
button I have a bunch of options here
I'm going to go ahead and choose text ad
because I'm running this campaign on the
search Network and my goal is to get
sales not leads sales so I want sales I
want somebody to click on my ad go to my
website and purchase some fake
concentrate so that's my goal and so if
I'm on the search Network I can only
have text ads so I'm going to choose
text at and once I choose text ad then I
have the option now to go through and
create a new ad okay so what Google
actually does is they pop populate the
ad from previous ads and so this gives
me an opportunity to tweak one of the
ads I already have in place so here you
can see I have a final URL and that's
the URL that the traffic is going to go
to when they click on your ad okay so if
somebody clicks on the ad that's the
page they're going to go to call that
the final URL now I have an option to
create up to three headlines so here I
could see headline one up to 30
characters I have my brand name headline
two I have something related to the
keyword I'm bidding on so what am I
talking about fake concentrate okay
again up to 30 characters now that
includes spaces so if you happen to go
over 30 characters your ads not going to
get approved so here you can see 32 over
30 I'm two characters over if I just get
rid of that the ad is okay so you got to
be careful to stay within the boundaries
of the character limits including spaces
so here I got headline two is fig
concentrate now I'm going to write
headline three this is new so this is
recently implemented by Google and I
highly recommend that all the fields
available to you you use because the
more information you can put in an ad
the better it is for not only your ad
but for the end user because if
somebody's searching and looking for
fake concentrate and you provide them as
with as much information as possible
then the chances of them clicking on
your ad are going to be greater and
that's what we want if we're going to
advertise we want to advertise so that
people can see our ad and click on our
ad that's the whole point isn't it to
get people to click on our ad because
they're looking for something that we're
offering in this example fit concentrate
so here I have headline three I'm gonna
go ahead and put something in the
headline three maybe a promotion let's
just say I'm offering up 20 so I can say
up to 20 off through April and May now
you see I'm running into the character
count so I'm just gonna go ahead and
keep it at April so up to twenty percent
off through April now I can create
another ad and maybe change the headline
and say up to twenty percent off through
May so you want to take advantage of all
three headlines now notice when I added
the headline here I can see a preview of
it on mobile and I can see a preview of
it on desktop now underneath that I have
what they call the display path so what
Google does is they take your domain in
this case valleyfig.com and you can
basically customize that domain with
what they call a path so you have path
One path two and the whole point of this
is for you to customize it based on the
keywords you were bidding on so if I'm
bidding on fake concentrate I'm gonna
put fake concentrate in here now
remember when somebody actually clicks
on my ad they're not going to go to
valleyfig.com
concentrate they're going to go to the
URL up here under final URL so you want
to make sure you put a path in there
ideally what I would do is put in
something related to the keyword I'm
bidding on in this case if it
concentrate now I have an opportunity to
add a new description a second
description this is new and I have up to
90 characters so I can go ahead and add
some content so remember what
description two I have up to 90
characters so I'm just going to go ahead
and borrow some copy from the website if
I'm not actually sure what to write and
so here you can see thick concentrate is
a natural product containing no
preservatives or additives so that's my
second description so now I can go ahead
and save and create extensions so I'm
just going to go ahead and push the
button save and create extensions and
when I do that I'm going to be prompted
to go ahead and create some ad
extensions and so ad extensions allow me
to add in links site links underneath
the ad just like you see here so when
you've added your site link extensions
and other extensions you save it you'll
be able to see your new ad here here we
can see the ad we created okay notice
it's got the three headlines now this
has got the two descriptions and if I
want to edit I can just click edit add
and go ahead and edit it I don't want to
edit it then I don't have to I can
always go back so you can always edit it
out after it's been created okay if not
no big deal notice when you actually
create your ad in some cases Google's
going to review it to make sure it fits
within Google's guidelines and policies
but once it's approved you'll see it
under you'll see approved under the
status column and that's pretty much how
you would go ahead and create a text app
okay so when it does get approved it's
going to be in the rotation with the
other two ads and so what Google is
going to do is serve up each ad equally
and then eventually the ad that is
performing best will get served up more
and that way your putting your best ad
always in front of the user who's
looking for the product and service
you're offering so now let's talk about
the metrics so associated with these
keywords these ads these ad groups and
campaigns so there are a lot of metrics
in Google ads a lot of metrics and we're
not even going to cover most of these
metrics we're just going to cover what I
deem the most common the most important
metrics to get you going so if you find
yourself advertising whether that be on
Google search Network or Google's
Display Network you're going to have
some common metrics and here are the
metrics that we're going to focus on
today so you have Impressions cost
clicks average CPC conversions cost per
conversion CTR or click the array and
quality score so let's go through these
metrics here and talk about what they
are so Impressions really it's the
number of times your ads been shown on
that particular Network whether it's
Google search or display and so an
impression is just how many times
somebody actually seen your ad okay
whether they actually physically seen it
or not if your ad is showing up on that
Network then an impression is going to
get counted so here for looking at ads
we can see we have over a period of time
certain amount of Impressions okay so
that's how many times this particular ad
has been shown so this particular ad
here the first one at the top has been
shown 557 times over this period of time
which is year to date okay so that's an
impression how many times your ads been
shown so if we talk about cost cost
refers to the amount of money we've
spent so anytime your ad gets clicked
you're going to pay Google X amount so
if I go back to Google ads I can see
what my total cost is and not only can I
see what my total cost is I can see what
my average cost per click is and so
there's a lot of factors that go into
what you actually pay and some of these
factors are who else is advertising
where you're advertising what network
you're advertising on what time of day
what particular keyword and so there's a
lot of factors and so here I can see on
average year to date I've spent a dollar
eighty per click on this particular ad
for a total of
32.33 so I can really see how much I've
actually spent and so clicks is just
refers to how many times somebody
clicked on your ad so if your ads been
shown you need an impression and when
somebody sees your ad they're going to
click on your ad so the whole idea is to
get the click remember you want to be in
positions one through three so I want to
make sure that my average position is
between one and three and so if you're
looking in Google ads at metrics and you
don't see average position well you can
always add that as a column so if I
click on columns here and then I go to
competitive metrics and I click on
average average position and I'm going
to move average position all the way to
the top here so if I click move average
position all the way at the top I'm
going to be able to see what my average
position is over that particular period
of time so here I can see I'm in
positions one through three and that's
where you want to be you want to be in
positions one through three so if you're
in positions one through three that
means you're at the top if you're on
Google search or that means you're in a
problem position on the Display Network
so if your ad is shown meaning it gets
an impression then likely somebody's
going to click on that ad and if
somebody clicks on that ad it's going to
generate a click which in turn is going
to generate cost and so ideally what you
want to do is you want to measure the
rate at which people click on your ad
based on how many times it was shown so
here I can see 28 clicks over
3549 Impressions that's a point seven
nine percent click the rate so ideally
the higher the click the rate the better
the ad then the higher the clicker rate
the chances are you're going to get more
traffic to your site so we want to be
able to measure clicks and we want to be
able to measure click-through rate and
we also want to measure cost per click
which is really the total cost divided
by the number of clicks so if I go back
to Google ads here I could see you know
17.57 over 28 clicks that averages out
to about 63 cents per click so that's
how I get cost per click now your cost
per click is going to vary a little bit
okay so it's going to vary based on
keyword it's going to be based on where
you're advertising what position
Etc so there's a lot of factors involved
with cost per click but that's how you
would actually calculate it but Google
ads actually does a calculation for you
for collector rate and cost per click
but in case you want to know you can
always divide clicks into cost okay so
conversions probably one of the most
important metrics you're going to use
and Google ads because you're paying
Google and if you're paying Google for
advertising you want to make sure you're
going to return on your investment so
conversions are added when a user clicks
on your ad and performs an action that
you've defined such as purchasing
something downloading something viewing
something sign up for a newsletter Etc
so you want to make sure that if you're
in Google ads that you're measuring
conversions and so you simply want to go
to tools so if you go to tools and then
click on conversions you want to make
sure that you're running conversions
ideally what you want to do is you want
to run conversions from Google analytics
but you can certainly set up conversions
within Google ads as well notice I also
have call from ads as set up as a
conversion so you have an opportunity in
Google ads to add a number of different
conversions and the more conversions you
add really the better off you are
because you want to measure up all your
campaigns against conversions if I go
back to campaigns I want to be able to
see what campaigns are driving
conversions and if I can measure that
and I have a campaign that's really
driving conversions that I'm going to
continue to advertise on Google okay so
here over this particular period of time
I can see one campaign has driven nine
conversions at
128.67 cost per conversion and so how do
I get cost per conversion well I get my
total cost divided by the number of
conversions and then I could see my
conversion rate the rate at which people
convert so really if I have 241 clicks
and nine conversions that's 9 divided by
241 that's 3.77 conversion rate so I can
measure conversion rate cost per
conversion and conversion just by
setting up conversions in Google ads and
so ideally if you're going to pay Google
for advertising you want to be able to
measure return on investment via
conversions so again seek cost per
conversion is just really then the total
cost divided by the number of
conversions and then click the rate
again just as a reminder the total
clicks divided by the total number of
Impressions and then one other metric
we're going to talk about here today is
quality scores so quality score is
really Google's way of measuring how
well your keywords are are compared to
the ad associated with it the expected
click the rate and the landing page so
quality score is the backbone of Google
ads so if I go back to Google ads and I
click on keywords quality score is
something you want to measure and if you
don't have it in your columns you could
certainly just click on columns and add
it and so here I can see my quality
score and quality score is a measurement
between one and ten and so if you have a
good quality score for Google's gonna
score you higher because your keyword is
relevant to your ad it's relevant to the
landing page and you have a good
expected clicked array if you don't have
a good quality score Google is going to
let you know why you don't have a good
quality score so again your three
categories that make up quality score
are landing page experience which means
really Google looking at the landing
page or sending people to and they're
seeing if the page loads well fast does
it have ads does it have good content is
it a good landing page will the end user
have a good experience they also look at
the ad relevance okay is the ad relevant
to the keyword and they'll also look at
the expected click-through rate okay so
based on other advertisers and their
click-through rate are you achieving the
same click-through rate and so those
three factors make up quality score
quality score is a metric assigned to
keywords so if you don't have a good
quality score you need to fix it because
the repercussion is you're going to have
to pay more so having a good quality
score likely means you're going to pay
less per click so you want to make sure
that if you bid on a keyword that the
keyword goes to a relevant landing page
the ad itself is relevant and you're
getting a good click-through rate so
quality score is the backbone of Google
ads and how it works so you want to make
sure you have a good quality score so
optimizing your ads so what if you don't
have a good quality score what if you're
not getting conversions well there's
things you can do so remember we want to
make sure that we're adding extensions
whether that be call site link review
app add extensions to your ads because
it's going to increase the click-through
rate so you can also really hone your ad
copy if you're selling products and
you're running promotion maybe you want
to add in a little sense of of urgency
to help people you know realize hey if
this this promotion's ending maybe I
want to click on the ad and take action
okay with Google ads you can always run
a b testing on ads and so what you can
do is run two ads and one ad group and
see what ad is performing best in terms
of click-through rate or conversion rate
and whatever ad is running better you
can always run that ad and then continue
more testing so that way you're always
putting your best forward in terms of
advertising and the ad copy whether that
be text or display you always want to
use call to action you want to get
people to click on your ad when somebody
clicks on your ad it's going to improve
click the rate click the rate improves
quality score so as I mentioned several
times already you want to make sure your
ads are placed at the top between
positions one and three on Google search
so you can measure ad position in Google
ads and if you're not right Bank between
one and three you want to increase your
bid okay you can also optimize for local
search so local is an ad extension that
you can add to your ad you can also
advertise at a time when your audience
is online or you can advertise on during
business hours only so you can adjust
when you advertise on Google ensure some
of your ads you know capitalize on some
particular events that are related to
your industry so you can capitalize on
that okay you can certainly ask Google
to accelerate your ads okay or you can
do standard delivery so Google can
spread out your clicks and show your ads
throughout the day Google search is all
about keywords so you want to be able to
pick and choose the right keywords first
you can also add negative keywords so if
you're bidding on a specific industry
let's just say you have software and you
want somebody to sign up for your
particular piece of software but you
don't offer a free trial then maybe you
want to add free as a negative keyword
so if you don't offer anything for free
free should be a negative keyword so if
somebody actually does type in looking
for free software then your ads not
going to show up so that's the whole
idea behind negative keywords okay you
can use Dynamic keyword insertion into
your ads meaning you can ask Google hey
I want to dynamically insert a keyword
into my ad that somebody uses to make
your ad more relevant so relevancy
increases click-through rate and
improves quality score so as you can see
there's a lot of things you can do
here's some more things you can use
branded keywords you can use particular
match types in Google so let's talk
about match ties for a second so you
have different match types if I go back
to Google ads here I can see my keywords
that I'm bidding on so by default if you
actually bid on a keyword it's going to
be broad map match and so if I've been
on the keyboard medical computer is
somebody typed in something related to
medical and included the keyword Medical
but not computer then my ad May show up
however I can make an exact match so
somebody can type in exactly only
medical computers so if I click edit and
I can change the match type for that
particular keyword to exact then that
means that somebody that types in only
medical computer my ad is going to show
up I can basically do phrase match so
somebody types in looking for something
that's going to help me with medical
computers okay that's a long tail phrase
work keyword query but the query word
medical computer is in that order so my
ad is going to show up okay so with
phrase match your ad is going to show
when somebody types in that keyword
you're bidding on in that order you also
have broad match modifier so if you have
a plus sign front of the keyword then
that means that somebody actually has to
use that keyword in the query in order
for your ad to show up okay so you could
change the match type of any keyword so
if you use an X-Acto phrase then chances
are you're going to have lower volume of
queries but probably higher relevancy if
you use a broad match then your ad could
show up for any combination of search
queries so you really want to be careful
on the match type that you choose so
keep an eye on quality score remember
Google has quality score between one and
ten the higher quality score the better
you are so really if you have a quality
score I would say anything below four
you probably want to pause the keyword
okay so you can measure quality score at
the keyword level so if I go back to
Google ads and I have keywords that are
say three chances are I'm going to have
to pay more for the click and it might
not be worth it so I may want to to end
up pausing that keyword and try other
keywords that are more relevant that I
can send traffic to when we're rolling
landing page or I can have an ad that's
more relevant to that keyword in order
to help with the quality score okay you
can ensure that your landing pages are
mobile friendly so that's another thing
you want to keep in mind that most
people start their search on mobile so
you certainly want to make sure that
your landing pages are optimized because
if somebody starts to search on mobile
likes your products or service chances
are they're coming back via desktop or
even going into the store most searches
start on mobile so you want to make sure
those pages are optimized and there's
plenty more things you can do to
optimize your ads you want to make sure
you group and organize your keywords
into relevant ad groups why because you
can write relevant ads for those
keywords so if I go back to Google ads I
want to make sure if I go to ad group
that the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to one another so what's my
ad group name well if it's medical PC if
I click on medical PC I want to make
sure the keywords in that ad group are
all relative to Medical PC I want to
structure my campaigns and AD groups to
Target more ads effectively so you want
to be able to you know organize your
campaigns and AD groups and the rule of
thumb here is you should organize your
campaigns and AD groups based on the
site architecture of your site so the
way your website is laid out in the
navigation is how you should likely
structure your campaigns and AD groups
focus on your budget okay so you want to
put more budget to campaigns that are
converting okay you can use automatic
bidding for ads to maximize results so
meaning that Google has what they call
artificial intelligence so Google can do
a lot of the bidding and a lot of the
managing for you that's really a great
benefit to running your ads on Google so
their machines are learning behavior
from your keywords that you're bidding
on and so ideally when they learn what's
converting they're going to bid more and
try and help you get the conversion for
the keywords that have historically
converted and so ideally you can use
some of the automated bidding features
that Google ads has to offer in order to
improve performance now Google is the
dominant search engine on the web
customers turn to Google when they want
to find information about products and
services that means people are actively
seeking information to show your ads to
active Searchers or people looking for
your products and services you can use
Google ads which is Google's advertising
program
in this lesson you'll learn how Google
ads connects your business with
customers so you can reach your
marketing goals now by the end of this
lesson you'll be able to understand how
Google ADS works discuss the various
targeting methods and know the primary
benefits of using Google ads
that lets you connect your business with
prospective customers so for instance
let's say someone has a broken pipe in
their house and they want to find a
local plumber they often turn to Google
to search for their answers if you're
buying a new house you might search for
Real Estate or mortgages or moving
companies all of these are searches that
someone conducts every day so to reach
these Searchers you can use Google ads
now Google ads is a complex system made
up of multiple networks targeting
options ad formats budget management and
so forth so we need to take a look at
how the system works to ensure you're
targeting the users who can turn into
customers
now it starts with picking targeting
methods this could be a user searching
for a keyword in a specific geography on
a specific device and operating systems
so it will get more into targeting
methods as we go through our lessons so
you can write effective ads for those
targeting methods you set a bid for how
much you're willing to pay if someone
clicks on your ad now when someone does
a search and it matches your targeting
method then your ad can be displayed so
if the user looks your ad and says yep
that's what I'm looking for and the user
clicks on the ad they go to your site at
that moment is when you pay for the
click or for any action that can happen
from an ad directly such as calling your
company now once users click in your ads
they go to your site if they take an
action such as calling your company or
buying a product or filling out a form
or just watching a video then you can
measure those actions now this lets you
see your data for each targeting method
keyword and add data to understand how
each is performing now we'll Define this
information as we go through our lessons
so you know what to look for to make
data-driven decisions then from those
data driven decisions you can refine
your targeting methods test different
ads and set appropriate bids based upon
how each click or interaction is worth
to your business let's say that you're a
plumbing company and you're only in
Houston Texas so you could Target only
Houston Texas with keywords such as
broken pipes remodeling kitchen and
other services that you conduct then for
each of those keywords you write an ad
and set a bid if someone is searching
from within Houston for kitchen
remodeling they could see your ad so if
they were searching from Austin or
California or Seattle and they're not in
your targeting method they can't see
your ad so it's important to think about
where are your customers how are they
searching and then make sure your ads
are compelling and then you can turn
those Searchers into your next customers
now the first network is known as search
this is when someone inputs a keyword or
a search query into a search engine and
then sees results there's more than 167
billion searches a month
now then there's another Network that
Google also supports known as the
Display Network these are non-certs
places that can show ads so Google
Display Network is made up of more than
3 million websites and apps that
Encompass more than one trillion
Impressions a month now these ad
placements could be apps in your phone
or a newspaper publisher site with so
many possible ad displays you're
targeting methods help narrow down when
your ad is displayed so you can ensure
only those who you want to see your ad
will see your ad
the three primary targeting methods to
think about initially are location time
of day or day of the week and device the
location is where our ads are going to
be displayed this could be every country
in the world it could be a single state
it could be 10 states it could be a
radius around your business or your PIN
code you have a lot of control and
options over location targeting and next
we have time of day and this could be
time of day or even just day of the week
so let's say you have a call center
that's only open from nine to five
Monday to Friday then you could run your
ads only during those times nine to five
Monday to Friday now most companies run
their ads all the time but you can
adjust when they do run there are other
considerations such as you're a small
business where you really only answer
your phone from eight to four so you
could only run your ads during that time
now if you're a restaurant you might
want to run your ads later in the
evening to take reservations you can
also choose the device and operating
systems where you want your ads to run
such as mobile devices tablets computers
or all three so for example if you're a
pizza delivery place most pizza orders
are now on mobile devices so while you
may be on all devices mobile is your
primary one then you pick your location
based upon your delivery area and then
finally you choose the time of day for
when your business is open and actively
delivering pizzas now if you're a large
SAS company and you're International
your locations might be worldwide so you
want to think about breaking down our
ads and keywords by languages or regions
so we'll get more into how these
breakdowns occur in the account but a
location could be worldwide or time of
day is 24 7 and our devices are just all
devices so you have a lot of control of
your targeting methods and how people
can see your ads both when and where
keyword is an object you put into your
Google ads account now a search term or
search query is what a user types into a
search engine to see results so in this
search term matches your keyword then
your ad can be displayed so if you're a
modeling company and you do kitchens and
bathrooms and room additions but maybe
you don't do basements you could pick
kitchen modeling keywords and bathroom
modeling keywords but ignore basement
keywords because you don't do that type
of remodeling work now you can also
choose demographics such as age gender
and income level if you're a high-end
art dealer you might only sell the top
30 percent of income levels if you're
selling female only clothing then you
could Target just females now in
addition we can do things like
behavioral targeting which is based upon
how people use our websites this is
sometimes known as remarketing if
someone came to your site and they added
items to a shopping cart but they didn't
check out we know they're almost ready
to buy therefore you could Target those
users differently than someone who's
never been to your website let's say a
user searches for accounting services on
Google in Maryland in the US anytime
during the week they could see an ad for
a local Maryland accountant let's say
you're on a call center for mortgage
leads and you're only open on the
weekdays then you could want your ad for
the entire country only during Monday to
Friday during the hours your call
centers open and only show an ad if
someone searches for mortgage rates
mortgage quotes and so forth so as we
think about our targeting it's where our
customers are located what they are
looking for the devices they are on and
the types of people we want to serve ads
to
now Google ads is an auction based
system you set a bid based upon what you
believe a click is worth to you and then
Google looks at your bid and the
relevancy of your ads and they do this
for all the other advertisers as well
then they order the ads in this search
results were cross-display properties
based upon both the bid and the
relevancy now this is an important
consideration as useful ads are as
important as your bids in determining
position so we'll get into this later
when we look at organization now it's
not just who bids the most that will get
you into position one is your ad
relevant to the user there's a lot of
ways to make things relevant and we'll
walk through this later you know if a
user sees your ad you don't pay anything
only if a user clicks on your ad do you
pay the search engine that's why it's
called pay per click advertising is the
only hey when someone clicks on the ad
now you can then measure results such as
acquired customers return on ad spend
revenue and so forth now based upon the
results you're receiving from Google ads
you can then refine your ads or change
your bids based upon what those clicks
are worth to you
when we think about the Google ads
benefits we often call them the three
R's reach relevance Roi now from a reach
standpoint Google search and the display
networks have tremendous reach they can
help you reach your target audience
because your target audience is probably
using Google whether it's on search or
display or both so the advertising
system has the reach that encompasses
your potential customers the next think
about relevance this is a big thing in
advertising are you relevant to the
users right searches are often resistant
to ads that's why if you're watching TV
in a commercial appears you might hit
the fast forward button or switch the
channel when the ad is relevant users
like ads they'll interact with them if
they're useful and they're relevant so
you can Target users actively searching
for that word that means they're looking
for a solution so when users see
relevant adds the more likely to click
and do business with your company now
finally we have Roi known as return on
investment as our third benefit return
ad spend row us or Roi let us know how
profitable a channel is now as you can
measure results from your ad spent you
can make data-driven decisions based
upon how users interact with your ads
and how they're becoming customers so
Google ads has the reach that
encompasses your users when you make
good accounts and you have good account
structure which we'll get into later
videos you can ensure your ad is
relevant to users so they'll click on
the ads and come to your website so you
can turn them into customers now with
analytics and conversion tracking you
can see exactly how much that person's
worth to you so then you can adjust your
reach and your relevance data to ensure
that your return investment is fantastic
from using Google ads as a marketing
channel
so Google ads accounts have multiple
levels of structure in order for you to
be able to control how users can view
interact with your ads along with your
budget and bid controls now in this
lesson we'll examine each low of
hierarchy so you can understand how
average accounts fit together and how
data flows throughout your account so by
the end of this lesson you'll be able to
understand account level settings
understand campaign targeting options
and discuss the purpose of an ad group
so when we look at the overall account
hierarchy it starts where we have an
account then an account can be made of
one or more campaigns then each campaign
can have one or more ad groups and then
finally ad groups are a collection of
ads and keywords so as we look at
accounts campaigns and AD groups each
level has different items you set with
it so we're going to look individually
at each of these items to see how you
can use various settings at each level
now at the account level we have several
options that we can set the first is
account access this is who can log in
and access your data so when you open an
account you use a Google account the
list doesn't have to be a Gmail address
you can make your own email address for
your company a Google account and then
use that for login purposes but then you
can give others access to your account
as well from a security standpoint it's
useful just to have one administrator
who gives access levels to other
individuals that way if someone leaves
your company or no longer needs access
to your data you can disable just that
access point instead of using shared
account logins now you'll also choose
your time zone now some items such as
time zone and currency cannot be changed
once you open the account so your pick
your time zone and when you think about
it you it's useful to have your
analytics your server and your marketing
such as your Google ads account on the
same time zone now because if you've got
inside account in Pacific time and your
servers on Eastern time there's a three
hour period of time a day when your data
doesn't agree with each other so it's
useful to sync servers Google ads
account analytics so forth into a single
time zone now you'll also choose your
currency do you want to be billed in
Euros or dollars or Pounds or Canadian
dollars and so forth again currency
can't be changed once you've set up your
account as well and then you have
billing how are you going to pay for the
clicks that you accrue and then you can
connect other accounts to your Google
ads account such as Google analytics
Google merchant center Firebase Etc so
if you're using multiple systems you can
connect them all together at the account
level so they can all use the same data
and then you have notification settings
how do you want to be notified of
suggestions or disapproved ads and so
forth in some preferences like display
language number formats Etc so that when
you open an account the two most
important options really to think about
though are time zone and currency they
can't be changed you can change your
billing later on or you can change who
has account access some preferences but
time zone and currency are set once your
account is open let's look at the
campaign settings you'll have an account
an account can be made up of one or more
campaigns so a campaign setting is where
you're going to tell Google glads how to
show the ads and keywords within that
campaign so first we have the network do
you want to be on search Network Display
Network or potentially both and when
you're first starting search is the best
place to start because users are
actively looking for Solutions so you
could have one campaign that search and
another campaign that is display now we
choose our devices at the campaign level
as well so might be on all devices we
could be on just mobile devices or just
computers or just tablets if we want to
run our ads at certain times of day or
day of the week we also set those and
the campaign settings so if you only
want your ads to run Monday to Friday
you can choose those options at the
campaign level now is say you want your
brand terms to run all the time and then
you have other keywords you only want to
run Monday to Friday then you can use
two campaigns campaigns can have
different settings from each other so
you could have one campaign for your
leech on keywords that runs Monday to
Friday clicks go to a call center you
can maybe have another campaign that's
brand terms that runs all seven days of
the week and they're in another campaign
so that way you can segment out which
items run when now locations are also
set up at the campaign setting so if
you're a multi-location business you've
got one location on Houston another in
Seattle another in New York and you only
want to run ads in those geographies you
could either put one campaign together
and Target all three of those locations
then go campaign now all those locations
would use the same ads and keywords or
you can make a campaign for each
location and if you make a campaign by
location then any other settings such as
time a day or budgets which use campaign
settings can be customized for each
location your bid method is also a cam
campaign setting so with bid Methods at
a high level there's two types one's
manual where you set the bid yourself
and another is automated where you're
setting a goal for the system and the
system is bidding on your behalf and
then you have budget how much you're
willing to spend on a daily basis so if
you have one location and you want to
spend a hundred dollars a day and then
you have another location where you want
to spend 500 a day that would be two
different campaigns so you can have
different budgets for each of the
campaigns so when you want a campaign
level setting to be different for some
reason aesthetic keywords location or
something else that's one of the reasons
to make a different campaign so if you
want certain ads to run only in certain
locations only certain times a day if
you have budgets by product line you use
different campaigns to control those
items so when you think about budget
management if you want on a different
budget by product line you make each
product line its own campaign so when we
think about search here's a couple
examples of how we might set up
campaigns might have one campaign is on
search it's on all devices it's only set
to the country of say the United States
it uses an automated bid system that can
spend a hundred dollars a day you might
have another campaign it's on search
it's only on desktops it's set to France
it's based on manual bidding it has a
fifty dollar a day budget so when you
want these campaign level settings to be
different that's one of the main reasons
to create a new campaign for the ads and
keywords that are inside of that
campaign
now ad groups are a collection of
keywords and ads and only an ad from
that ad group that contains the same
keyword that matched to a search query
right can be displayed so ad groups
should be closely related collections of
keywords and ads so we think about the
work involved in setting up a Google ads
account it's really quick just to make
an account it can be very quick to make
a campaign but where you're going to
slow down and spend your time is
thinking about your ad groups someone
did a search they are looking for
something they're going to then see an
ad so that ad is going to take them to a
page of your website so you want that
user experience be very cohesive so you
may have one campaign the campaign could
have 20 or 50 or a thousand AG groups in
it right for each type of idea that
you're advertising so if you want to
show a user a different ad based upon
their search term changing you want a
different ad group
let's say we sell shoes now we sell
hiking boots we sell running shoes we
sell dress shoes now we don't want to do
is put all of those in one ad group
because if someone searches for hiking
boots versus a running shoe versus a
dress shoe you want a different ad
there's not a good ad explains all those
Concepts so we could write and add shoes
for sale right but shoes for sale
doesn't really speak to the user if
someone's doing a search for hiking
boots right and they see an ad that says
shoes for sale and another ad that says
hiking boots for sale right walk on the
trails comfortably right they're gonna
look at the one that says shoes for sale
and say it's not relevant to what I'm
looking for and the ad that mentioned
the product they search for hiking boots
would be relevant we get a lot more of
those clicks and conversions so why we
may take some keywords like hiking boots
Trail hiking boot hiking boots for sale
our best hiking boots and put them in an
AG group together right we make an ad
only for those keywords so we create an
ad hiking boots for sale walk the trails
in Comfort but then someone searches for
running shoes that ad would not be a
good result for them right High key
boots and AD that they're looking for
running shoes so you'd want a different
ad group for running shoes so you might
have keywords running shoes best running
shoes shoes for running marathon long
distance running shoes right and then we
can make an ad that says running shoes
for sale maximize your performance now
if we really focused on running shoes
and that was our Core Business then we
wouldn't want to run just the running
shoe ad because that's very general we
want to get more specific if someone's
running a marathon they want long
distance running shoes others want
minimalistic running shoes you'll see
see people search for running shoes with
high arches is or better Arc support
wide box shoes since you can even get
into those very specific terms to create
ads for them in the ad groups when you
think about ad group structure only the
keywords and that ad group can show for
that ad right if we have two ad groups
and someone searches for running shoes
right they can't see our hiking boots ad
because it's in a different aggregate
only so the running shoes at so you can
make multiple ads in an ad group and do
some ad testing to see which is best so
if we look at an ad group and we see
here's another keyword that we really
want to look at and the ads we have
aren't great for that keyword we can
move it to a new ad group so we may have
one ad groups that stress shoes another
for high heels and we can make new
aggers for all of these items so that
the ad and then where the user goes on
your website or it is specific to each
of those types that idea of keywords so
you might have many aggers but the trick
about ad groups is you have a core set
of keywords in each ad group and then
you have multiple ads in an Aggregate
and so as long as all the ads and the
keywords are reflective of each other
then you've got a good ad group now if
an ad does not represent a keyword that
keyword should be in a different anger
settings are inherited downwards across
the account so for instance the account
level you set billing the billing method
is used by all the campaigns in the
account and all the ad groups so you set
access level by account so anyone with
account access level can see are your
campaigns in ad groups so then at the
campaign level we enter settings like
budgets location so that goes to the
campaign level is inherited down to the
ad groups so any AD group in the
campaign that can show to all the users
and a location that set up the campaign
level or budgets and so forth so then
that goes from campaign is inherited to
the ad groups so any AD group in the
campaign can show where it may reach the
campaign settings such as location or it
uses that same budget right all the ad
groups on campaign use a budget so if we
have different campaigns then only the
ad groups in that campaign would use
that campaign's budget and that
campaign's targeting method so when you
create create a setting at the account
level hd's at the campaign level and
then anything at the campaign level is
used at the ad group level so if you
create ad group level settings for
something you can set up the ad group
they're only used by the ads and
keywords in that specific ad group AD
group data is never inherited to another
ad group so setting hierarchy flows
downwards across the account from
account to campaign to ad group and then
the ads and keywords
so the first step to getting started
with Google ads is opening an account
now once you open an account then you
can fill in your billing information add
additional users and connect your
analytics account to your Google ads
account
so in this lesson we will look at how to
create the initial account
now by the end of this lesson you'll be
able to open a Google ads account set
permission levels and user access data
and then connect additional accounts now
before you begin creating a Google ads
account you'll need a Google account to
access it if you use Gmail then you can
use your Gmail account if you want to
use your business email then you can
create an account and use your business
email address you'll need to verify your
account through a text message code or
through an email to the email address
you're using access your Google ads
account now once you've established how
to access your Google ads account
proceed to setting up your first
campaign each person who can access your
data should have their own login this
lets you choose their permission level
remove someone when they should no
longer have access and see what changes
were made in the change history tool
which logs changes by user access before
adding a user you should consider the
permission level that the user needs so
for instance if you want someone to see
information but not change anything you
can give them read only access if you
want a user to be able to make any
changes but not add or move other users
they can have standard access by giving
each user access you can maintain
control over your data and also add and
remove other users as your need for
accessing your data changes
there are times when you all want your
Google ads account to connect with other
applications so they can share data back
and forth this is really common with
Google analytics by connecting Google
analytics and Google ads you can see a
lot of data in both places in addition
you can create conversions or audience
lists in Google analytics and have them
imported into Google ads if you're an
e-commerce company then you want to
create a Google merchant center account
and Link it to your Google ads account
so you can create shopping campaigns a
common problem you might come across is
that one email is the admin for one
account and another email is the admin
for your Google ads account you might
need to give someone permission to log
into Google ads to connect accounts but
they might need to give you permission
to access the accounts that you want to
link to Google ads so you have the
necessary permission level levels in
both places to connect the data once you
have the necessary permissions in place
it's easy to connect other accounts to
your Google ads account using the linked
accounts tool inside of your Google ads
account so I want you to imagine having
the world at your fingertips especially
when it comes to advertising imagine
having the entire world at your
fingertips for advertising so just
imagine you have the ability to
advertise your brand to any website in
the world can you imagine that well
imagine having that entirety at your
fingertips the entire world so it's not
really an imagination so no need to
imagine anymore because Google ads has
come to the rescue so no need to imagine
the world is at your fingertips and why
is it at your fingertips because of
Google and specifically Google Display
Network work okay so we're gonna talk
about what the Google Display Network is
so let's start out by asking the
question or answering the question what
is the Google Display Network so Google
has two networks basically one the
search Network one the Display Network
so you as an Advertiser if you want to
advertise on Google you have a choice
can I go with Google search or can I go
with the Display Network well the search
Network is for Google search only so if
you want to advertise when somebody
types in a keyword query and you want
your ad to show up that's the search
Network so it looks something like this
somebody types in a keyword data science
and lo and behold ads show up and here
you can see the first ad from Simply
learn why did that ad show up because
simply Learned was bidding on the
keyword data science and so that's how
the search network works you bid on
keywords so many types on those keywords
and your ads show up and the search
engine results at the top above organic
listings so that's the search Network
and it just simply comprises of ads that
respond to what people are querying okay
the display network is a little bit
different so that's the search Network
today we're going to talk about the
Display Network okay the display network
is a little bit different so imagine
you're on the lookout for a new shoe on
Amazon as an example but you don't have
end up buying the shoe you're looking at
shoes you don't buy it well you might
have noticed in the past you've done
something like that whether it be shoes
or shirts or coats or belts or cars or
radios or headphones or phones it
doesn't really matter you might have
been looking at something and then
notice an ad show up it might have been
exactly that same product or might have
been something similar to the product
you were looking at but on the same
website so why does that happen well it
happened happens because Google's
Display Network specifically remarketing
which we'll talk about so on Google's
Display Network you have the option to
advertise as somebody's been on your
website so that's one of the powers and
one of the features of Google's Display
Network and that's remarketing or
retargeting somebody that's looked at
your product so let's take a little bit
of a deeper dive into how the display
network works so if you're a customer
you go to a website and you leave that
website again from a remarketing
perspective your product can appear on
another site okay so that's remarketing
so you can retarget that person who's
been to your site so that's again one
great example of how to use the Display
Network in Google terms and call it
remarketing and again somebody goes to
your website they leave in this example
not buying something it could be a
technology company where we want
somebody to watch a video or download a
a PDF okay whatever they do that that
you want them to do but they don't
actually do it then you can go back and
retarget them so if they actually go to
a page and look at your product but
don't buy that product then you have the
opportunity to advertise to them again
so the whole idea is if you advertise
them again wow that person can say okay
I remember that I was in still
interested in that product let me go
back and purchase that product so they
go back to the site and make the
purchase so that's again the power of
the Display Network you can reach people
who have been to your site before so
let's take another look here it's a
retargeting evolves around adding a
piece of code or pixel on your website
which uses browsercookies to add website
visitors to your audience so let me just
summarize that for you so if you want to
use Display Network and you want to
Target people who've been to your
website well you need to add a simple
script or pixel if you will to your
website that's all and so when somebody
comes to your website they're gonna get
cookied and that cookie is stored in
their browser and so that's an import
important piece of the whole process
because that's how Google determines who
that visitor is so without that cookie
then Google won't know to show their ad
your ad to them again so that's the
first piece in all this so when somebody
does get cookied they're going to be
added to that audience and so when we
say audience we mean you as an
Advertiser to finding who you want to
retarget to so in this example we're
talking about people who have looked at
a product and didn't purchase that could
be a whole audience in itself people who
look at a product and don't purchase it
could be everyone who comes to your
website it could be only returning users
it could be only new users you define
the audience but however you define that
audience they're going to get cookied
and placed on a list and when they're
placed in that list they're going to get
shown the ad again so past visitors will
see your product ads when they're
browsing the web watching videos on
YouTube going through news sites and so
on so if that's your audience list past
visitors that's where are they going to
be able to see your ad because Google's
Display Network is much more than just
websites it's also YouTube it's also
news feeds it's also social networking
sites so there's a lot involved with
Google's Display Network so the network
involves several websites that are
partnered up with Google along with the
likes of YouTube along with the likes
and millions of other websites in fact
these websites together tally up to more
than 2 million that encompasses more
than 90 percent of the internet so you
can imagine Google's Display Network is
just made up of a bunch of websites
including YouTube okay so you have the
opportunity to really reach somebody
that's been to your website before so
again if they're past visitors and they
looked at a product and they didn't
purchase it you have an opportunity to
really put your ad in front of them on a
lot of different websites so that's just
an intro about the display network
remarketing is just one benefit but
let's take a step back so we dove into
the deep end with remarketing let's just
separate out the two again just so
you're clear on what the display network
is versus the search Network well let's
go some through some of the differences
so Display Network on the left search
Network on the right so the Display
Network as we just discussed is great
for retargeting people who have been to
your website whether they're new users
returning users users who looked at a
product users who added a product to
your cart users who looked at a specific
page whatever that behavior is you're
defining that now the search network is
usually for top of funnel why do we say
top of funnel because users are actively
searching for something they're looking
for a product they're being active so
they're going to search and seeing who
has that product okay the Display
Network we know remarketing is a benefit
but usually it's bottom of funnel like
brand awareness so if nobody knows who
your brand is is what your brand is or
what you have to offer what your
services are then the Display Network
remember made up of millions of websites
you have the opportunity to put your ad
out there okay so display bottom of
funnel search Network top of funnel
somebody actively looking for something
let's take a look at some other
differences here so Display Network
easier to advertise products that don't
satisfy an immediate need this is true
because again if you have a new product
you want to get that product out there
you want people to just know about it
some people may not be ready to buy that
product but at least they're going to
know what the product's about on the
search Network on the other hand if
somebody's looking for something like a
particular product that you're offering
then they can type in a keyword that
describes that product in Wham your ad
can appear at the top okay remember top
of funnels so products and services
usually fulfill a particular requirement
now the Display Network can be used to
familiarize users to your brand so again
going back to remarketing somebody comes
to your website they really don't know
who you are well you can reach back out
to them on the Display Network with
another ad retargeting and that's how
you can get users familiar with your
brand we're on the search Network users
are shown ads based on what they search
for so it doesn't really matter if they
know your brand or not hey if they're
looking for something then they're ready
to buy and you have that product at the
right price then the chance of them
converting are pretty good so you're at
the right place at the right time where
the display Network's all about
familiarity retargeting to people with
your brand getting your brand out there
getting your product out there in front
of millions of people now on the Display
Network users are shown these ads in
over a million different websites so
with the Display Network you have the
opportunity to kind of hone in and pick
and choose those websites we're on the
search Network users are shown ads in
Google apps and on the search engines so
you have the opportunity to place your
ads not just on desktop search but also
on mobile and also on apps whereas again
the display network is made up of much
more it's made up of websites YouTube
apps Etc okay the display network has a
multitude of different formats okay when
we say different formats we mean text
ads image ads rich media ads meaning ads
that have some functionality to it like
movement okay and then video ads where
the search network is really only text
ads and I say really only text ads where
you can have image ads those are called
shopping ads but mainly it's text ads
where Display Network you have an option
between text image rich media or video
ad so you can see the differences here
really there are big differences between
the two networks where search you're
just really responding what somebody's
looking for they're really active and
ready to go display hey you're trying to
reach out to these people you're trying
to introduce them to some something and
in some cases with remarketing you're
reaching out to them again okay you're
trying to get them familiar with your
product and brand and you're trying to
do that via video via rich media via
regular image ad via text ad so you're
trying to do it in a multitude of
formats so again bottom of funnel for
display top of funnel for search so
that's an intro to the Display Network
those are the differences between search
and display now let's go through the
steps of how to set up a campaign in
Google ads using the Display Network as
our option so here I am I'm in Google
ads I'm in an account and I want to set
up a campaign on the Display Network so
you can see here if I'm in Google ads
I've selected display campaigns I can
already see I have some Display Network
campaign set up in fact they're all
remarketing campaigns and so remarketing
remember it's targeting somebody who
fits a list or just description okay so
it could be somebody looking at a
particular product they get cookied
meaning that text file is going to sit
on their browser and then they're going
to see your ad the next time they're on
Google's Display Network wherever site
they may be so we're reaching out to
somebody who fits a particular
description okay so if we're going to
set up a display campaign meaning a
campaign on Google's Display Network we
want to go to campaigns and we want to
click on the plus button here and we're
just going to say new campaign now we
have the opportunity now to pick and
choose what our goal is for that
campaign and so most the time with
display you're going to choose brand
awareness and reach okay so here you can
see the campaign types for brand
awareness and reach display and video
usually when it comes to sales or leads
or even just driving traffic okay you
might go with the search network but if
you're just really trying to just
promote your brand you may go with
display because remember you have the
option to get your ad in front of
millions or websites we're going to
choose brand awareness and reach okay
and we're going to choose the campaign
type so here you have display we want to
run different kinds of ads or we can run
just video okay we want to run if we're
running video we can reach and engage
viewers on YouTube and across the web
meaning other websites okay which shoes
display here so we're going to go ahead
and just put our website in there so our
businesses website
and when that loads up we're going to
have a number of different options
available to us so here we can name our
campaign okay so here you can see brand
awareness and reach is the name of our
campaign and for now we're just gonna
contest now we have the opportunity to
choose our location here we're going to
choose the United States we have just
like a search campaign we also have
language as an option so with search you
have locations and languages same thing
on display so we're going to Target
English as our language and what are we
trying to do what are we focusing on
well we want to get our product out
there so we're going to choose
Impressions viewable Impressions that's
really what we want to focus on we want
people to see our ad okay it's an
impression is the number of times
somebody sees your ad okay so we have
viewable Impressions that's what we want
people to do we want them to see our ad
and if you take a peek over here on the
right side you can see your targeting's
reach so we can reach over 10 billion
million plus in Impressions meaning
that's a lot of eyeballs the number of
people looking at our ad right now is
over 10 billion plus okay so that's just
gives you the scope and some idea of how
big Google's Display Network is so just
like search we could set a budget I'm
just going to choose a hundred dollars
for now and I can choose how to deliver
that budget just like on search I have
standard accelerated I can ask Google to
speed up the spend or I could just do
regular standard which means they're
going to spend my budget evenly over a
period of time over the course of the
day now remember with Display Network we
have different options on ad types we
have text ads rich media ads regular
image ads and video so we can rotate our
ads how we like so we could say hey look
I want to run my best performing ads
okay so that means I want Google to
optimize for me meaning if I have an ad
that's performing better than some
others then I'm want to let Google run
that one more and that's the one I would
recommend but you do have other options
here you can just have them rotate
evenly you could say hey optimize for
conversions but it's really remember our
goal here for display is to get
impressions eyeballs we're not
interested in top of funnel conversions
in here we could say rotate evenly and
that's not supported for display so
really our best option here is prefer
best performing ads we want our best
performing ads to run okay we have an
option to schedule them we have an
option to start and okay and we have an
option to set a cap how many times we
want somebody to look at that ad so we
can limit how many times our ad is shown
to the same user okay so we're gonna let
Google optimize how often your ads are
shown however we do have the option to
set that limit okay so we could set the
limit to x times per day for the entire
campaign or it could be for a particular
ad or ad group okay so we could set the
limiter sounds and we can let Google
optimize for us here we have some
exclusions okay and then we have the
opportunity to set up our ad group now
the ad group is the same as the search
Network the ad group on display is where
your settings are going to be your ads
are going to be located in your ad group
and now the important part we want to
get to audiences so if we're remarketing
we're going to choose our audience and
if we're not remarketing we still have
the opportunity to choose our audience
so if I'm a tech company and I just type
in Tech then Google's going to give me
some options here so here I can choose
some tech companies technology products
new inventions
Etc or I can choose some ideas that
Google has in mind for audiences like
they have an in-market audience so this
is based on network system and Services
Network management so the bottom line is
Google is giving me suggestions on who I
can Target my ad to okay that's what
really what this is choosing your
audience now you don't have to choose
anything here in fact you can just clear
all and be done with it now you can go
down to demographics now I can pick and
choose based on gender I could pick and
choose based on age parental status and
household income really depending on who
you're advertising to that's really what
it comes down to it okay so you have
demographics and you have audiences
audiences are really for remarketing so
again you can go with some of Google's
recommended audiences or you can create
your own audience okay and we're going
to talk about that here in a minute but
this is all part of the setup for the
campaign so I'm saying hey these are the
demographics and these are the audiences
but if you're not remarketing you don't
necessarily have to go with an audience
okay once that's done you can set up a
bid just like you want on the search
Network and then you have the option to
choose your ad so that's part of the
campaign setup so when you actually
choose your ad again you have different
options image ad okay rich media ad
video or text once you choose your ad
then you pretty much have your campaign
set up now we're gonna tweak it after we
set it up but that's pretty much the
steps and terms of setting up a display
campaign very similar to search in fact
minor differences really are choosing
your audience and choosing the ad type
that's really the main differences
between setting up a campaign on display
and setting up a campaign on search the
main differences now there are other
subtle differences but those are the
main ones so we talked about remarketing
to people who have been on our website
so going and showing our ad to somebody
who fits a particular description
meaning they've looked at a product or
they looked at a particular page so if
you're going to retarget the people then
as a best practice I would set up the
audience in Google analytics so Google
analytics talks to Google ads in fact
you can link link up to in analytics so
regardless of whether you're creating a
display campaign or search campaign you
want to link up analytics with Google
ads so you can see we've done that here
okay now that we've linked the two up we
could set up an audience in Google
analytics for use on a remarketing
campaign on Google's Display Network so
here you can see I have audiences set up
if you want to just create a new
audience you can do that so if I click
new audience here here I can choose
choose returning users or new users
these are audiences that Google has set
up by default I can create a new one if
I want so I could say hey I want to
Target you know 18 to 24 year old males
who speak English for example
and who came from mobile so if I go here
technology I'm going to say including
mobile so that could be my audience so
anybody who fits that description of 18
to 24 year old coming to my website from
mobile who speaks English I'm going to
retarget them and you can go ahead and
save this so if I go ahead and click
apply I'm going to name my audience 18
24 year old male English mobile one
thing about remarketing on the display
network is you can choose how long
somebody stays on your list meaning how
long is that cookie gonna live so
depending on your funnel if they're
buying a car the funnel may be six
months long if they're buying a pair of
shoes then the funnel may be seven days
long maybe even shorter so really
depends on your business the default is
30 days so if you go with 30 days and
that means any 18 to 24 year old male
who speaks English and comes from mobile
is going to get cookied and that cookie
is going to live for 30 days so if I
click next step I can go ahead and
publish it I can say I want this to be
available in my Google ads account so
I'm going to go ahead and pick my
account and it'll be available in that
account so I'll choose my account and
then go ahead and click publish so now
this audience list is going to be
available for me to use in my display
campaign when I go to choose my audience
so if I go back to Google ads so Google
ads and Google analytics talk to one
another why because they're linked and
so now when I go to actually set up my
ad group and I'm choosing remarketing I
can go ahead and choose that audience
list so for example this campaign that's
already set up I can go ahead and choose
to set up another ad group with that
particular audience list so if I choose
new ad group and now I'm going to search
for the audience I just set up so here
you go I just did a search and here's my
audience I'm going to select my audience
and I'm going to now use this audience
in my ad group for my remarketing
campaign so now all I need to do is
align find the right ad with this
audience so that's how remarketing works
you choose your audience list you set up
your ads remember you have different ad
formats video rich media image and text
and the whole idea Beyond remarketing is
you know who your audience is you know
what you want to say to them so your ads
should really Encompass that message the
message of what you want to say to that
particular group in this case 18 to 24
year old male who speak English who came
to your site from mobile so if you don't
really want to retarget somebody who's
been to your website you could certainly
still use the Display Network to your
advantage remember bottom of the funnel
the goal of our campaign is just get our
ad out there so that people recognize
our brand our services our product so
when you actually go to set up an ad
group you don't have to choose an
audience to retarget to you do have
other options so if I look at this group
here you can see I have image ads
already set up so where do I want these
image ads to appear so I do have options
available to me in the Display Network
so if I choose keywords then that means
if I go ahead and add a keyword then
what Google is going to do is
contextually place my image ad on a
website that fits the description or
matches that keyword so if I add one or
two or three keywords then what Google's
going to do is going to look at that
keyword and it's going to map a website
on the display network using those
keywords so that's keywords now you got
to be careful here because it's a broad
way of advertising meaning your ads
could appear on sites that you don't
necessarily deem relevant to those
keywords so you're allowing Google to
match the the website with the keywords
you choose so that's choosing keywords
audiences again audiences are there if
you want to retarget so if you're
retargeting you can set up your audience
in analytics in fact that's the best
practice so again if I go back to
analytics and I go back to admin under
my property audiences I can go ahead and
choose my audience to be used in Google
ads so that's using audiences on a
display campaign on Google's Display
Network when we're setting up our
campaign we had an option to choose
demographics so we can exclude a
demographic if we wanted to we can
always go back and exclude a demographic
just by removing them from the ad group
notice if we choose all demographics we
can actually then see over a period of
time in Google ads how many people based
on this particular age group or gender
or parental status or household income
saw or ad but not only SAR ad that would
be Impressions but clicked on our bad
and how much they spent per click and
how many conversions so you have all
that data available to you in the
Display Network okay so that's
demographics I can also use topics so I
can take I can choose a particular topic
to advertise on so if I choose topics I
can choose a particular keyword find a
particular topic or I can drill down on
Google's topic categories and
subcategories so here you can see online
communities if I choose that one I could
see there are other subcategories under
online communities okay I can choose the
whole category of science or I can drill
down to see what subcategories are under
science so I can do that for any one of
these topic categories and if I choose a
category notice that's where Google is
going to place my ad whatever I select
again notice upper right here I can take
a sneak peek at how many I buy Google is
expecting to see my ad so here by
choosing astronomy and science I have
310 million impressions that's how many
potential eyeballs can look at my ad so
if you're setting up a Display Network
campaign you can choose keywords you can
choose demographics or you could choose
topics now if you decide not to go with
a topic then your last option here is
placements so I can pick and choose a
specific placement if there's a
particular website that I want to
advertise on let's just say
newyorktimes.com or or latimes.com or
webmd.com remember there are over two
million websites on Google's Display
Network so I can pick and choose
specifically where I want my ads to be
displayed now when you're done choosing
your audience or your keywords or your
demographics your topics or specific
placements you can always then go to
your placements and then click on where
ADS showed and so now over this
particular time frame I'm going to be
able to see where my ads have been shown
and so now I can see my ads have been
shown my mobile apps and on particular
websites now if you don't like any of
the particular websites that your ad is
showing on you can always select it and
you can always exclude it can exclude it
from the ad group or the campaign okay
so that's how you manage where your ads
are showing up on Google's Display
Network again you can go ahead and go to
where ADS are shown under placements and
over that particular period of time
Google's going to show you where your
ads been shown and if you don't like
that placement then you can always just
exclude it or if you don't like the
performance meaning you're not getting
many Impressions or you're not getting
any clicks or the click-through rates
very low you can go ahead and exclude it
so this is an opportunity for you the
advertiser to take control over where
your ads are shown so in summary when
you set up a display campaign on Google
Display Network you have options if
you're remarketing you're going to
choose your audience you're going to
choose your audience using a list you
created in Google analytics if you're on
the display network not remarketing you
have the option you can choose a keyword
and have Google place your ad on a
website that fits the description of
that keyword you could choose specific
demographics you could choose a topic or
subtopic category or you can choose a
specific placement okay those are all
the options available to you when you
run your ad on Google's Display Network
now let's go back and take a look at
some of the advantages of the Google
Display Network so I just went over with
you how to actually create a campaign in
an ad group I actually went over how to
set up upper marketing campaign and set
up a marketing list and analytics and I
went over all the differences between
the search Network and display but let's
really hone in on those advantages here
so with the Display Network we can
provide Advanced targeting meaning I can
particularly point to a specific website
that I want to advertise on so that's
what I mean by Advanced targeting or if
I don't want to advertise to 18 to 24
year olds or 25 to 34 year olds I can
exclude them or I can really pick and
choose a specific audience that I want
to remarket to so those are all examples
of advanced targeting and that's all
done with an analytics or Google ads so
Advanced targeting enables you to target
the people that didn't engage with
previous campaigns and get in front of
people with look-alike audiences that
can be created based on the audience you
usually advertise to so in other words
we can really hone own in and pick and
choose who we want to advertise to
another Advantage is relatively low
starting cost so what we mean by low
starting cost is normally on the search
Network you're bidding on keywords and
some keywords can be very competitive
whereas on the Display Network you could
pick and choose who you want to
advertise to and pick and choose where
you want to advertise so you can really
advertise on websites that get a lot of
traffic may not have a lot of
competition and therefore may not cost
as much so if you compare it to
traditional forms of advertising like TV
or radio display advertising reaching a
large broader audience is a lot cheaper
okay you can do Advanced tracking
meaning when we talk about perform
Advanced tracking we're talking about
again remarketing we can really pick and
choose who we want to remarket to and
cookie them and pick and choose how long
they are going to be cooking so when we
talk about Advanced tracking that's what
we're really talking about so we can
also talk about how how many times our
ad is shown to somebody we really can
pick and choose how many times we want
somebody to actually see our ad on a
site based on performance okay let's
take a look at some other advantages the
ability to advertise your brand to a
broader audience can Google has over 2
million websites so we can pick and
choose where really where we want our
ads to show up again it could be by
topic it could be contextually via
keywords or it can be specific websites
so we can create demand for our products
and what we mean by that we can create
really cool ads remember rich media ads
video ads these are all engaging type of
ads those are ad Types on the Display
Network we create engaging type of ads
it's going to appeal to somebody and
they're going to engage so we have that
opportunity just based on the different
ad types of course increasing web
traffic we can't say that enough if
you're advertising on Google's Display
Network you have the opportunity to get
your ad in front of millions of people
get in front our ads in front of
millions of people we have the
opportunity to get a lot of clicks and
we do have that wide range of formats
search Network only has text ads here we
have text we have rich media we have
image we have video so all these types
of AD formats allow us to really get our
ads out there in a number of different
ways again remarketing our product the
services of the big big big advantage
using Google's Display Network that's
how we started today's webinar we
started talking about remarketing
because it's such a key feature so if
somebody comes to our website and
doesn't do it we want them to do we can
cookie them and we can retarget them
with a more specific ad tailor to that
audience today we're going to talk about
Google analytics we're going to start
out with how to set up a Google
analytics account and so we're going to
talk about everything that entails
including creating your Google Analytics
account we're going to talk about
setting up a property in your account
and what a property is we're going to
talk about setting up a reporting view
in your property and we're going to talk
about installing the tracking code so
those are the series of steps we're
going to go through today in terms of
setting up a Google analytics account so
let's get right to it and so really the
Bruin prerequisite here when it comes to
setting up a Google analytics account is
to have a Google login and ID so when
you actually go to Google analytics you
need to be able to sign up or sign in
and so once you actually sign in then
you're going to go walk through a series
of steps but really that's really all
you need to get the account going is a
Google ID and login so if you have a
Gmail account or an other email account
that you use for other Google products
then you're good to go that's all you
need to do so when you actually go to
sign up for Google analytics you're
going to be asked to set up a new
account and these are the series of
steps you're going to walk through or go
through to set up a new Google Analytics
account so you're going to choose an
account name and then you're going to
choose a property name okay so the
account name can be anything you want it
to be the name your company your name
whatever you want to name it the
property name is really the website name
so what website are we talking about so
here I'm going to set up a fictitious
website name for now it's called demo
simply learn so the URL for this website
demo simply learn is going to be
demo.simplylearn.com so that's the
property when we talk about properties
in analytics we're really talking about
what websites we want to measure and
then you're going to be asked to choose
an industry category and so for simply
learn we're in jobs and education but
you have a number of different industry
trees that you could choose from it's as
important go ahead and choose the most
relevant industry that your particular
business is associated with okay and I'm
going to talk about why that's important
here in a minute and then you're going
to choose your time zone and the time
zone is also important because that's
when the day starts in analytics then
the day ends based on that time zone so
the data that Google analytics collects
starts and ends with that time zone so
very important to choose the time zone
your business is located in okay and
then you have some additional options
here okay so you have some settings and
so the first setting is to allow Google
products and services so if you opt into
this then basically what Google's going
to do is share some products and
services with you via email I would go
ahead and opt into that that's of course
recommended by Google it doesn't hurt to
hear from Google on related products and
services that may enhance your business
the second is benchmarking so
benchmarking to me is something you
should opt into so going back to that
industry and category we chose jobs and
education so by opting into benchmarking
basically what Google's going to do is
share your data that it collects on your
website in this case
demo.simplylearn.com it's going to share
that data anonymously with others in the
industry in this case jobs and education
and because you've opted in it's going
to do the same exact thing for you it's
going to share Anonymous data on other
websites in the same industry and the
benefit of that is we get to see what
other websites or how other websites are
performing compared to ours what's the
Benchmark in our industry and so the
benchmarking to me is important and I'm
gonna go over that in a few minutes when
we go over the different reports but to
me I would always opt into benchmarking
because this is the only report Google
provides in analytics about how others
in your industry is performing versus
your website okay so it's a way to
compare your website performance against
others in the same industry the other
options here technical support and
account specialist I would also
recommend you opt into those because
then it allows you to basically Google
allow Google access to your account and
they'll be able to help you if you occur
or run into any issues so these are the
options in setting up a Google analytics
account it's very simple very easy to do
you're just entering in a few Fields
note that we talking about a website
right now so I'm talking about
demo.simplylearn.com but just know that
if you want to track a mobile app Google
analytics will allow you to do that as
well you just choose the option mobile
app so we're tracking a website we want
to know how users behave when they get
to my website and that's what Google
analytics is going to allow us to
measure and look at we just need to do a
couple more steps in the process so once
we fill out these fields here we're
going to click get tracking ID now I'm
going to accept the terms of service I'm
going to accept another terms and
service in relation to data protection
I'm going to click accept once I accept
I'm going to be able to get some
tracking code the tracking ID is the ID
associated with your account and so this
number is going to be associated with
your account so your account ID starts
with UA and it's going to be this number
here now the dash 1 is the property you
set up so in this case I set up
demo.simplylearn.com if I wanted to
track multiple websites under that same
account then I can certainly set up
multiple property just know that every
property I set up in that account is
going to have a dash 1-2-3-4
Etc depending on how many properties I
set up so by default I set up one
property so my first property ID is dash
one if I set up a second property the
same account number it's just gonna have
a dash too and that's important because
that ID that account and property ID is
going to be associated with that
particular property or website so again
once you finish setting up the account
settings then you're going to be asked
to add some tracking code to your site
and that tracking code is going to be
related to the account and the property
so notice my tracking ID up here notice
the tracking ID in the snippet of code
now this snippet of code needs to go on
every page of your website that you want
to track and you don't have to put it on
on every page but if you want to track
website behavior on every page or
website then it needs to go on every
page of your website so if you're using
a you know platform like Drupal or
Joomla or even more popular platform
like WordPress adding the tracking code
site-wide is as easy as maybe adding a
Google analytics plugin to Wordpress for
example and then just simply plug in the
ID now there's an alternative to adding
the Google analytics tracking code to
your site and that's Google tag manager
so Google tag manager is the way I would
recommend going so if you're not
familiar with Google tag manager I would
recommend watching the YouTube video we
have on Google tag manager you can just
go to YouTube Type in simply learn
Google tag manager and this will give
you a nice overview of you know what
Google tag manager is and how it works
but basically this is the way I would go
and I would recommend that in addition
having Google analytics you set up a
Google tag manager account and then that
way you can put the tracking code in
Google tag manager so if I go to Google
tag manager and I just go into an
account on tag manager I can just simply
put in the Google analytics ID right
into tag manager and so if I have it in
tag manager then tag manager is going to
be the place that holds the code and
fires page view when somebody comes to
my website so that way I don't have to
add the tracking code to my website if I
do it in tag manager so that's the
recommended method for me is to add the
Google analytics ID associate it with
tag manager if you can associate it with
tag manager then that's the easier route
to go versus putting code on your
website okay so again take a look at the
video we have on YouTube for Google tag
manager that that's the route I would go
now once you do get the tracking code on
your website whether that be through
Google tag manager or through a Plugin
or you know just simply adding the
script to your site to pages on your
site then what's going to happen is
you're going to start collecting data so
that's ideally the way it works you need
to add this code to your website now if
you're not ready to do that and you
simply want to basically understand how
Google analytics works then I would
recommend getting access to Google
analytics demo account and so if you
just type in and search Google analytics
demo account basically what you're going
to do you're going to choose the first
listing there and you're going to go to
demo account so if you have a Google
analytics or Google login then all you
need to do is click on access demo
account and so what Google is going to
do is put this demo account into your
account and so it's going to look some
something like this if I click on demo
account here it's going to add to my
Google analytics account so I'm going to
have then access to the demo account
from Google and Google analytics so I
would recommend going this route here if
you're not familiar you're not sure what
you're getting yourself into so think of
the demo account as kind of a test drive
you're test driving Google analytics
before you even add any code to your
website so again all you need is a
Google account and if you have a Google
account and you add the demo account to
your Google analytics account you're
going to be able to see how analytics
works okay and so that's what I would
also recommend so if you're not ready to
start adding code to your website then
what you can do is just simply add the
demo account and then once you add the
demo account you're free to peruse
around Google analytics to see the
different types of reports it has to
offer now when you do actually set up a
Google analytics account you're going to
have some settings that you're going to
want to pay attention to so when you set
up the account you have the account name
and then you have a property so under
each property you have by default you're
going to have one View and so here you
can see this view here so if we look at
the account we set up we set up a demo
simply learn account property is demo
simply learned so that's associated with
the website we're going to track and
then again by default under each
property you're going to have a view and
so by default the name of the view is
going to be called all website data and
so in that view is where all your
analytics data is going to be stored so
you can see my screen here there's a lot
of different settings you have you have
settings under the account you have
settings under the property and you have
settings under the view so we're going
to talk more about these settings and
future webinars for advanced Google
analytics users but for now know that
there's a bunch of settings that you
have that you can play around with when
it comes to Google analytics anything
from adding users to your Google
analytics account your Google analytics
property or view you can actually set up
goals you can set up filters you can set
up segments you can link up Google ads
you can you know set up remarketing list
there's a lot you can do in terms of the
settings as it relates to Google
analytics but so know those settings are
there they're located right down here in
this little sprocket icon that's the
admin icon so if you need to get to
these settings at any time you could
simply just click on the sprocket or the
admin icon and then you'll be prompted
to choose any one of these settings here
that you want to edit or alter so now
let's take a look at some Google
analytics reports so once you've
actually set up your account you have a
number of different reports reports that
you have available to you in Google
analytics so we're going to take a look
at you know customized reports we're
going to look at real time audience
reports acquisition behavior and
conversion so these are all the
different reporting buckets if you will
that you have available to you in Google
analytics so if I'm an admin and I'm
looking at the Google demo account let's
start out by looking at real time so if
I click on the real time report and I
just click on overview so basically what
this is going to do is show me at this
point in time how many users I actually
have active on the website okay so
that's why they call it real time
reporting because it allows you to see
the behavior of users who are currently
on your website and so this is the
overview report under real time and you
can see here I can see that 79 percent
of my users are coming from desktop 18
20 are coming from mobile and then
approximately three percent are coming
from tablet here I can see how they
actually came to the website so this is
the referring Source if they came from
say search or social I can see the
source there and I can see what pages
they're active on and then here I could
see what locations where they're located
and so if I want to see a breakdown of
everything in the overview I can
certainly do that if I go to locations
under real time I could see a majority
of my users are coming from the United
States okay where are they coming from
I'll just click on traffic sources and
here I could see the different sources
and mediums medium is the means in which
the traffic was driven so if it's Google
it's either paid search or organic
search so I can see here it's organic
then I can actually see what contents
they're looking at on my website so I
could see currently I have three active
users on the home page page two active
users on the Google's women's white t
page so forth and so on now most
importantly if you have a vent tracking
set up so if you're taking a look at our
Google tag manager webinar you know that
you could set up event tracking in
Google analytics to measure engagement
on your website whether that be a form
submission or somebody clicking on the
play button of a video so if I click on
events I'll be able to see what events
are firing so here I can see we have
event tracking set up and I can see how
many different events are firing on my
website in real time so here I can see
e-commerce somebody clicking on the
quick view click some a couple of users
clicking on add to cart a couple of
users clicking on the promotion click
and as these events are fired you're
going to be able to see them highlighted
so if something gets fired it's going to
get highlighted and I could see that
these are the current events that I have
currently firing on the website and
that's what's currently fire now if I
want to look at the events that have
happened in the last 30 minutes I could
just click on this link here last 30
minutes and it's going to give me an
overview of the events that have
happened over the past 30 minutes okay
so that's event tracking and then more
importantly we can also look at what
conversions are happening in real time
just by clicking on conversions and so
now I could see I had one active user
who entered the checkout so that's goal
number four so in analytics you can have
up to 20 goals and so here I can see we
have goal number four has already had
one active user and so if I look at the
last 30 minutes I can see I still have
only one goal over the last 30 minutes
and that was somebody who entered the
checkout so that's real time reporting
in summary it just gives you an idea of
what's currently happening on your
website site and so for me ideally if
I'm launching a campaign or let's just
say you do a new website redesign and
you want to see how users performing and
behaving then real time is a good option
for you so you can see how things are
happening in real time now let's jump
down to audience reporting so if I click
on audience this is just right
underneath real time I'm gonna see a
number of different reports available to
me under audience and so let's click on
the audience overview report so audience
reporting basically allows us to get a
sense of who is coming to our website
when I say who is coming to our website
it doesn't necessarily have to be a
specific person in fact Google doesn't
allow personally identifiable
information in Google analytics personal
identifiable information such as a
specific name uh social security number
credit card information
Etc however ever we could still paint a
nice picture on who is coming to our
website meaning what country city or
state did they come from what language
what device did they get to our website
from how old were they okay were they
male or female or other what interests
do they have what browser did they use
so we can paint a nice picture based on
all this information that Google
analytics is providing us under audience
so if I go to audience overview here I
can see I have all these different
options available to me to get a basic
understanding of who is coming to our
website so for example I could see a
majority of the people coming to our
website speak English and are from the
United States okay in fact that
represents 61 of the users and so Google
analytics does a great job of giving me
an overall percentage so if I have a
hundred percent of the users I could see
61 percent of those users represented
English-speaking users from the United
States seven percent represented
English-speaking users from Great
Britain and so when it comes to
analytics we have users and users are
broken down into two categories they're
either returning or they're new so when
you add the Google analytics tracking
script to your website what's going to
happen is if a user or when a user goes
to your website they're going to get
cookied if it's the first time they've
been to your website what Google
analytics is going to do is store a
cookie in the browser so when that same
user comes back another day in the same
browser analytics is going to recognize
that that cookie is in the browser and
so then analytics is going to categorize
that user as a returning user okay so
that's how analytics is able to
differentiate new versus returning so if
that user doesn't have a cookie in the
browser then analytics is going to
recognize that store the cookie and then
count that user as a new user and so
when you're looking in analytics you're
going to be able to see a breakdown of
new versus returning so here I can see
over three quarters of my traffic over
the past week here I can see April 6
through April 12th three over three
quarters are new users to the website
here I could see about twenty three
twenty four percent are returning users
okay so I can get a good breakdown of
what type of users are coming am I
driving new traffic am I driving traffic
that's been to my website before what
language are they speaking okay I can
also paint a bigger picture how old are
they are they what gender are they do
they come from mobile so let's take a
look at some of these different reports
under audience and so if I skip down now
to demographics I can click on overview
and when that report loads I can see now
under demographics overview I can see
the breakout of age ranges and so here I
can see the majority of the traffic
coming to my site again over the past
week now if I want to change this date
range I could simply do that I can
change the date range just by clicking
on the date range and then maybe going
say the last 30 days and I can even
compare it to the previous period or the
previous year I'm going to choose the
last 30 days I'm going to click apply
now I'm looking at data over the last 30
days and again you can change the date
range to any range you want you can only
go back as far as when you actually
created the Google analytics account you
can't go prior to that so here I'm
looking at the last 30 days and I can
see almost 47 of my users were in their
age range of 25 to 34. now when it comes
to gender I can say 66 percent represent
males so I can get a breakout of gender
and age as well as interest I can click
on interest and look at the overview
there and see what the interest is of
the users who are coming to my site
based on in-market segments or Affinity
I can also choose language and location
so if I want to know exactly where my
users are located when they're coming to
my website I can click on location and
here I can get a breakout 43 percent of
the users of the last 30 days were from
the United States more importantly I can
align my audience with goals and we'll
talk about goals here in a minute but
here I can see if I have an e-commerce
website I can see of those 43 percent
0.29 of those converted or purchased
something and that equates to 94
transactions so I can get a good sense
of not only how many users are coming
from a specific country but are are
those users converting if I click on
mobile and mobile to me is one of those
reports I tend to spend a bit of time on
because I want to know what devices
users are coming to my website and so
for my website here or this is the
Google demo website I can see mobile
represents approximately 27 of the
traffic so desktop still represents a
majority of the traffic so for you you
want to keep an eye on mobile because
mobile is definitely a majority of what
people use nowadays that's how people
start their day that's how they transact
Via Mobile whether that's purchasing
something communicating or searching it
all starts with mobile so you want to
keep an eye on mobile and more
importantly you want to keep an eye on
Behavior so Google analytics is telling
me that yes I have approximately 27 of
my traffic of the last 30 days came from
mobile how are they interacting with my
website so if I look across this report
I'm going to be able to see different
metrics so if I'm measuring specific
metrics against my dimension in this
case the dimension is what we're
measuring and in this example we're
measuring mobile I can see that the
bounce rate is approximately 48 and
bounce rate means that if a user in this
case for mobile landed on a page they
left the site without going any further
so they consider it a bounce if they
don't go to another page if they leave
the site from the page they landed on
and they don't go any further that's
considered a bounce so bounce rate is
the percentage of people who come to the
site and leave the site without going
any further so in this case we have 48
bounce rate that's almost half of our
users who come from mobile leave the
website from the page they landed on so
is that good is that bad well it's open
to interpretation is definitely
subjective but you want to keep the
bounce rate as low as possible you want
to keep people on your site especially
if you have an e-commerce website you
want people who come to your website to
purchase and so here we could see 48
mobile and desktop it's a little bit
lower at 41 percent now if I look a
little bit further at engagement I can
see how many pages on average do mobile
users look at so versus desktop it's a
little bit lower you can see 3.86 on
desktop it's 4.5 now if I look a little
bit further in engagement I want to be
able to measure how long somebody from
mobile stays on the website if they're
bouncing at 48 but they're also looking
at 3.8 Pages 3.9 almost four pages per
session then that means in this report
analytics is telling me they're spending
about two minutes on the site and
interestingly enough I can see that
mobile over the last 30 days had more
transactions so 51 transactions versus
34 transactions from desktop and
interestingly enough the e-commerce
conversion rate is at 0.29 percent
that's higher than desktop at .07 it's
lower than tablet but it's higher than
desktop and mobile has the most
transactions and since they have the
most transactions they have the most
Revenue at 2 380. so yes the engagement
isn't exactly as great as it is as
desktop but we can see that people are
still purchasing with their mobile
devices so it's something to keep an eye
on and mobile is something I definitely
look at in fact since it's such an
important report one thing you can do in
analytics is if you actually like a
report and you think you're going to
look at that report multiple times then
you can simply just go ahead and click
save at the top here so if I click save
I'm going to enter a name for this
report I'm just going to call it mobile
report and click OK and then what's
going to happen is it's going to be
located under save reports and save
reports is located under customization
customization is located above real time
okay so if I close that up you can see
audience real time customization if I
click on customization if I click on
Save reports I should be able to see my
save report here and I do so here I can
see mobile report if I click on it I can
simply go to the report I was looking at
before I saved it so save reports to me
is a good feature and analytics because
it allows you to quickly access a report
that you've saved in the past so just
take a look at one more report under
audience and let's let's go to
benchmarking so remember when we were
setting up our analytics account we had
the option to opt into benchmarking and
I recommended you do so and so if you
did I actually opt into benchmarking
then you're going to be able to see how
your site compares to others in the same
industry so if I click on benchmarking
and then click on channels what I'm
actually able to do now is compare my
website with others in the same industry
so if I go back to say jobs and
education and I choose education all
education as my industry vertical I
should be able to see websites that are
in the same particular industry and how
I compare with those websites so I'm
choosing all countries I can narrow that
down if I wanted to I can just search
for the United States I can choose a
specific State and then I can choose a
particular site size so here I'm
choosing sites by daily session so these
are sites that have an average of 5 000
to almost 10 000 sessions a day and so
in this vertical education in the United
States sites that have five thousand to
nine thousand nine hundred ninety nine
sessions per day that means that they're
approximately 310 web properties
contributing to this report okay based
on this criteria I chose now if my site
is similar meaning if I'm in the United
States if I'm in education and I'm
receiving 5 000 to 9 999 sessions per
day then I'm able to compare my site
against 310 other websites now Google
sharing this data anonymously from the
other websites and they're doing the
same with your website to those
particular websites benchmarking reports
okay so it's a shared data anonymously
in particular Industries and verticals
and so now now I'm looking at a channel
report so if I want to see how I compare
to others in my industry then I can go
ahead and see my channel for example am
I driving as much traffic as others in
my industry and you can see I'm not in
fact I'm 76 77 percent worse in terms of
the amount of traffic being driven from
organic search so anything in red is
going to show as a negative result a
negative comparison whereas something in
green is a positive comparison so if I
look at engagement I can see that I
might not be driving as much traffic but
I can see that the pages per session are
better than the side average or the
industry average I can see if I go over
again looking just at organic search I
can see the bounce rate is better than
the industry average so the channel
report under benchmarking allows you to
measure how you you compare to others in
your industry and you could do so by
looking at location and devices so if
you opted into benchmarking when you set
up your account then you'll be able to
compare your website against others in
your industry in your country region and
based on the size of your website in
terms of how many visitors or sessions
you're getting per day so let's go from
audience to acquisition so if audience
is who is coming to your website
acquisition allows us to see how the
traffic was driven to your website so
how do these users get to our website
and so under acquisition if we click on
overview we'll be able to see an
overview of how users whether they're
returning are new came to our website
and so what analytics does by default is
they have a number of default channels
and when we say channels we mean
analytics is grouping different channels
based on how you users got to your
website meaning how did users get to our
websites they come via organic search
meaning do they type something into
Google and find you in the organic
listing analytics also groups users
based on whether they came to your site
directly meaning did they type in the
URL directly into the browser or did
they bookmark your website and come back
via the bookmark so they're grouping
users under direct they also group users
under referral meaning do they come from
another website they group users by
social do they come from a social media
platform like Twitter or Facebook if
you're running paid search meaning if
you're running paid search on say Google
then do they come from Paid search ads
now if you're running display ads on say
Google's Network Google's Display
Network that's a default channel so
analytics for group users there so if
they don't recognize a channel then
they're going to group it as others so
by default all Google analytics groups
users and how they came to your website
via these default channels and so I
could see how many users came to the
site from each Channel now if I want to
drill down on this report I can click on
all traffic and then if I click on all
traffic I can go to channels I can look
specifically at the channels report and
so now I can see organic search again
over the last 30 days is the number one
channel driving traffic and they
represent approximately again you can
see this number here in parentheses next
to the raw number of users I can see
that number's about 56 percent so 56
percent of my traffic over the last 30
days came from organic search and so
those are the number of users again as a
metric you're also going to have
sessions and you'll see sessions a lot
as a metric so users are broken down
between new and returning so every time
a new or returning user comes to the
website basically what they're doing is
initiating a session so you can have a
user who can come back multiple times
every time they come back to the website
it's a session so session is simply the
start of somebody coming to your website
and the session ends when they leave the
website and so just like we looked at
with the audience reports when it came
to mobile we can also look at engagement
by channel so just like mobile we looked
at bounce rate pages per session average
session duration we can do the same
thing here with our Channel report more
importantly in addition to behavior we
can see conversions and since we're
running an e-commerce platform we could
see what the conversion rate is by
channel so organic search did drive the
most traffic and they did have the most
transactions over the the last 30 days
and the conversion rate in this case is
0.17 okay so how Google determines the
conversion rate they basically take the
number of transactions and divide that
by sessions so that means that over the
last 30 days organic search drove 38 123
sessions and of those 38 000 123 64
actually turned into a transaction which
equates to 0.17 which also equates to 3
000 in Revenue so I'm able to determine
not only how users are getting to my
website by looking at the channel report
I can actually see if they're engaging
and if they are converting and notice
when you look at a report in analytics
you can look at it by Channel you'll
also get a summary so here I can see a
summary or a total based on my date
range so I could see over the last 30
days I've had fifty four thousand years
scissors 49
000 of them were new okay that meant
that at this 54 000 users I had 70 000
sessions I could see my average bounce
rate was 43 the pages per session were
just over four and the average session
duration how long did somebody stay on
my website on average about two minutes
and 55 seconds the average conversion
rate was 0.14 and I had a total of 97
transactions totaling fifty five hundred
dollars okay and that's all over the
last 30 days so any report you look at
in analytics is going to have a summary
and note that any report you look at in
analytics is going to allow you to save
it so if it's a report you think you're
gonna go back and look at at a future
date then you simply just have to click
on the save button conversely if you
don't want to save it you can simply
just export it so you can export it as a
PDF if I click on PDF it's going to
allow me to export that as a PDF now you
have other options available to you as
well you can do a Google sheet you can
export it as an Excel or you can export
it as a comment delimited file so here
you can see I can save it as a PDF if I
want to and if I click OK it's going to
save to my desktop or location of my
choosing and then I can go back and look
at it in that format at a later time so
that's the export feature available to
you in analytics again if you you could
save it as well or you can export it
okay some other reports under
acquisition if you're running Google ads
note that you can connect Google ads to
analytics and this is key because now I
can see how many people are coming from
Google ads to my website and are they
converting now this is important because
with Google ads I'm actually paying for
the click so you can see here I'm
running a report based on campaign data
so I could see what campaigns are
driving traffic how much of paying per
click and you can see on average I'm
paying 34 cents per click and then more
importantly I want to be able to see if
they're converting so you can see I've
spent 810 dollars over the last 30 days
and received 858 dollars in Revenue so
you want to make sure that you link up
your Google ads account to your Google
analytics account for this very reason
you want to be able to see how your
Google ads campaigns perform once the
users get to your website and so I want
to see if they're engaging and I want to
see if they're converting so there are
all sorts of reports under Google ads so
you can look at it by keywords by search
queries by hour of the day if you're
running display campaigns you can look
at display targeting says all sorts of
reports under Google ads you you just
have to link it up and you link it up
under the admin now there are other
reports that you can look at so if I go
to campaigns I can look at all campaigns
so if you're running all sorts of
different types of campaigns whether
that be on Facebook whether it be email
whether that be you know other types of
advertising let's just say Twitter or
Instagram you're going to be able to see
those campaigns here and that's under
all campaigns and again you'll be able
to see the campaign name and you'll be
able to see metrics associated with
those campaigns and more importantly
you'll be able to see your e-commerce if
you're running e-commerce platform or if
you have goals set up so you'll be able
to look at how your campaigns are not
one not only driving traffic but two are
they converting let's go from
acquisition reporting to behavior so
Behavior reports are going to actually
show you how users behaved once they I
got to your website once they landed on
a page on your website how did they
behave so when we looked at audience we
got a sense of who is coming with
acquisition we get a sense of how the
traffic got to our website did they come
from organic direct social Etc the
behavior reports allow us to actually
measure how that traffic behaved once
they landed on a page on our website and
so if I go to overview under Behavior
now I'm looking at this graph here it's
showing me how many pages I've had and a
page view is simply once a page is
viewed it's counted as a page view so if
a user comes to my site they're
initiating a session and if they look at
a page then that page is going to have a
page view okay so a user can look at a
page multiple times in a session and
every time they look at that page it's
going to count as a page view so here I
can see in this graph how many pages
I've had again over the last 30 days and
if I look further at my overview report
I can see the specific pages and how
many pages they've had and I can also
look at some other metrics okay the
average bounce rate the average time on
page I can look at the exit rate which
means how many people actually exited or
the percentage of people who exited from
that page so I can dig deeper into my
behavior reporting so if I click on site
content and I click on all pages then
I'm going to look at a report by Page
this is my Dimension this is what I'm
measuring my page and now I can see how
many page views each page had over the
last 30 days now note you also have
something called unique page views so
unique page use is equivalent to one per
session in other words if a user came to
my site and looked at the home page then
the home page is going to have one
unique page view and one page view now
if the user in that same session looks
at other Pages then every page that user
looks at it's going to have one unique
page view however if the user goes back
to another to the same page in the same
session then it's still going to be one
unique page view but in this case the
home page if they look at the home page
a second time then the home page is
going to have two page views if they
look at the home page five times in one
session then the home page is gonna have
five total page views and one unique
page view okay so that's why unique
pages is equivalent to one per session
where pages is an accumulation of how
many times the page was viewed in the
same session so in other words you're
always going to have more page views
than unique page views okay so this
gives me a sense of how my pages
performed so again I can look at total
page views and then engagement so
ideally what you want to do with a
report like this is if a user is not
engaged gene on the page then that
should tell you something about the page
itself if they're not engaging if the
bounce rate's high if the time on page
is low if the exit percentage of exit
rate is high then you probably want to
do something with that page now these
are all pages but if I jump down to
landing pages my landing page report is
showing me how many people actually
landed on that page and so here I can
see under my landing page report I can
see the home page had 36 000 17 sessions
in the last 30 days that's how many
people landed on the home page so here I
can see 71 percent were news sessions
meaning that I had a lot of new users
who landed on the home page in fact 25
000 or 52 percent of the people who
landed on the home page for new I could
see the bounce rates about 42 percent
but of those who didn't bounce they went
on to look at about 4.5 pages per
session and spent about three minutes on
the site and the one thing I like about
the landing page report is I can also
see whether that particular page in this
case the home page did it help
contribute to a goal or conversion and
in this case I can see of those 36 000
sessions I had 22 transactions totaling
1200 in revenue and that's an e-commerce
conversion rate of 0.06 percent so the
home page over the last 30 days
contributed to 0.06 percent of the
revenue so this gives you an idea of
when somebody lands on your website and
they land on a page is that page helping
to move that person along meaning are
they not bouncing and is that page
helping to move people towards
converting and so that's what the
landing page in effect allows us to
measure is the engagement and in this
this case we're measuring transactions
okay so analytics also gives us some
other reports under Behavior including
site speed so site speed to me is an
important report to look at just like
the mobile report to me site speed is
important because what Google analytics
does is they take a sampling of pages
and in this case you could see over the
last 30 days they sampled
2835 page views and of that sample they
came back and said the average page load
time is about four seconds now ideally
you want to keep it as quick as possible
I would say even under three seconds
okay now there are other factors
involved with page load time the browser
you're using the country that you're
actually browsing that page from mine
know how to have the best infrastructure
you may not even be on the best internet
Network meaning you're on a cell network
or the Wi-Fi is not that gray or or you
can be on a page that just has a lot of
images or a lot of code that may slow it
down so there are other factors involved
and so what Google analytics does is
show you what those factors are so here
I can see by browser with the average
load time is if I want to look at
Country I could see what country is
contributing to the load time now the
great thing about the site speed report
is if I go to speed suggestions okay
what speed suggestions is going to do is
it's going to show me the page load Time
by Page and then it's actually going to
provide a link where I can actually
click on to get suggestions on
increasing the page load time so for
example I can look at this particular
page here this Google redesign shop by
brand slash YouTube page line number
five if I look at line number five I can
see the average load time of this page
is eight seconds almost nine seconds
okay that's an eternity to some people
now notice this link next to it so
Google's recommending seven total
suggestions so if I click on seven total
what it's actually going to do it's
going to open up a new window and it's
going to open up another Google report
called page speed insights and Page
speed insights is going to give me some
information about what I can do to
create correct correct the page load of
that particular page so look at the site
speed report it's important because
there is a correlation between site
speed or page load time and user
behavior of that page and there's also
correlation between page load time and a
page ranking organically on search so
page load time is very important it's so
important that I'm even going to save it
so I'm going to click save and click on
speed site speed suggestions as my name
and click OK and now that report is
going to be saved under customization
under save report parts let's jump from
Behavior to conversions now conversion
reporting is arguably the most important
section in in Google analytics because
what the conversions reporting allows us
to do is see how people are converting
or if they're not converting on our
website and so in Google analytics we
have the opportunity to set up goals now
you have the opportunity to set up 20
goals in your Google analytics View and
so to set up a goal okay so you're going
to click on admin and Under The View
you're going to see goals and so if you
don't even have goals the first step is
to create goals and so you have four
different goal types in analytics so you
have pages per session so how many pages
per session is so if your goal is set to
say three or two if somebody actually
looked at two or three pages per session
it's going to count as a goal okay so if
I look look here I can see I have pages
per session set at 10. so that means
that if a user came to the site looked
at more than 10 pages per session then
it's going to count as a goal another
goal type is destination so destination
means that if somebody actually went to
a specific page then it's going to count
as a goal and in this case I can see
here that the goal is set to this
particular page here and so when
somebody actually lands on that page
it's going to count as a goal now there
are two other goal ties we can look at
one is duration so just like pages per
session in our previous example is
somebody looked at 10 pages per session
it's going to count as a goal with
duration it's based on time so in this
particular case if you set up a duration
goal and the duration is set to say one
minute and 30 seconds then that means if
a user comes to my website and they
spend at least one minute and 30 seconds
then it's going to count as a goal okay
and then the fourth type of goal in
Google analytics is an event based goal
so when you set up event tracking you
could turn that event into a goal so if
somebody clicks on say the submit button
of a form you can turn that event into a
goal so here you can see the category
equals contact form so you can always
verify if a goal works just by clicking
on verify this goal and in this case
this event is turned into a goal so
anytime somebody fires this event it's
going to count as a goal so you have
four different goal types in Google
analytics you have pages per session
destination event and duration and so
once you've set up a goal then you can
measure goals under conversions so now
if I look at goals overview I can be
able to see how many total goal
completions I've pad so if I want to
look at it by goal I can just choose the
goal option here so if I want to look at
for example goal 2 engaged users this
was the pages per session I can see that
I had a conversion rate of 10 meaning
that I had 7 000 of all the users that
came to the website 7 000 goal
completions meaning
7106 users looked at 10 pages or more on
my website and so that's how you want to
be able to measure whether users
wherever they're coming from whoever
they are whatever Pages they look at you
want to be able to look at the
conversion reports to see if they're
actually converting based on the goals
you've set up whether that's pages per
session duration destination or event
goal conversion tracking reports can
help you measure who is actually
converting and then the great thing
about Google analytics here is that I
can actually see by segments so the
default segment in a segment is just
looking at a specific user set so the
default segment is always all users
however I can choose a different segment
so if I want to choose instead of all
users if I want to choose Mobile Traffic
I can select Mobile Traffic hit apply so
I'm actually now looking at a subset of
data I'm looking at mobile traffic so if
all the mobile users have come to my
site I can see 1400 engaged or looked at
10 pages or more okay and that's a seven
percent conversion rate so the great
thing about Google analytics is you have
the opportunity to set up four different
goal types okay based on those goal
types you can go to goals overview and
look at the conversion rates of each
goal but you can also change the
segments of that particular goal to see
who exactly can heard it okay another
report I like under conversions is the
multi-channel funnel report so if I
click on multi-channel funnel basically
what this allows me to do is see how
different channels work together to
convert so remember the channel
reporting we looked at under acquisition
here I can see now how different
channels work together to drive the
conversion so if I look at three
channels direct organic and referral I
can see all three together drive two
percent of the conversions if I look at
direct and referral twelve and a half
percent if I look at direct and organic
12.24 so I can see how different
channels work together and so if I look
at top conversion paths as an example I
can actually see what channels how
channels work together to drive the
conversion so in this example I can see
over the last 30 days that my top
channel grouping was direct times two
meaning that that somebody came to the
website directly meaning they typed in
the URL in the browser or they
bookmarked it and came to the site okay
they came the first time but didn't
convert but then they came back a second
time via direct and then converted so
that combination is my top conversion
combination of the last 30 days my
second best conversion grouping is
organic search and direct meaning that a
user came to the website via organic
search first did not convert and then
came back via direct the second time and
converted so basically what analytics
does is give credit to the last referral
meaning if you came to the website via
referral or referring website and
converted then the referring website's
gonna get the credit for the conversion
but analytics does a good job of showing
you how different channels work together
so a channel may drive a lot of traffic
like organ search but that traffic may
not convert the first time around for a
number of different reasons whether it
could be brand recognition Price
shopping reading content whatever the
case analytics is able to measure if
that channel actually did contribute at
a later point and in this case we could
see organic search drove traffic that
didn't convert but that traffic came
back a second time via direct and did
convert so that's our second best
Channel grouping and so the
multi-channel funneling Report top
conversion pass to me is a good report
to look at so you can actually see not
only have channels work together but you
can see sources and mediums and
campaigns and how all that all those
different campaigns and different
sources work together to convert so
that's just a good report to look at
there are so many different reports
available in analytics there's so many
that we haven't even gotten to yet so my
advice if you look at the demo report
you can get a feel for each of these
reports under each section whether that
be audience acquisition Behavior or
conversions take a look at these reports
see what makes sense to you see what you
can use to improve your website
performance how to set up goals in
Google analytics so for this particular
webinar we're going to jump into Google
analytics directly and spend all of our
time there because it's about learning
practical applications so goals are
important goals uh let me just say this
goals are in analytics something that
should be aligned with your business and
we call goals that are align with your
business kpis are key performance
indicators so it's very important as a
precursor that you know how to set up
goals in Google analytics because if
you're using Google analytics you want
to measure everything against the goal
so without further Ado let's jump right
into Google analytics so if I go to
Google analytics and I log in okay what
I want to do is go down to admin click
on admin here and admin will take you to
basically a screen that looks like this
where you have an account column you
have your property column and then you
have your view column now the view
column is where you're going to go to
set up goals okay so every view in every
property has up to 20 goals okay so by
default in analytics you're going to
have at least one view for your property
so if I have a property I'm gonna have
at least one view but if I happen to set
up multiple views like you see here then
I know for every view I set up I have 20
goals to work with so where are those
goals so Under The View I'm going to
click on goals and now I could see I
have 20 at my disposal now you can see
here by clicking on the recording column
I can see I have in this particular
property this particular view I have
five goals that are active so you can
use up to 20 but you don't have to have
20 active Okay you can have one active
two active my recommendation at least
have one goal again when you set up a
goal you're going to measure everything
in analytics against that goal okay so
in this case we have five particular
goals we're measuring so we have five
active out of 20 total so if I don't no
longer want to use a goal I can simply
just turn it off if I want to continue
using it just turn it on okay it's that
simple you could turn on and off goals
so here I already have five set up so if
you want to set up a new goal the one
thing you need to know in Google
analytics is in order to set up a new
goal okay you need to have edit access
at least the view level I would say at
the property level so you want to make
sure whoever's in charge of Google
analytics for your organization or if
you're in charge okay you simply just
want to go to user management and user
management you want to make sure the
email address you're using to log into
Google analytics has at least edit
permissions so you're going to need edit
permissions to add new goals so I have
edit permissions I'm going to go to
goals and I want to set up a new goal
but before we jump in and set up a new
goal what is it that we want to achieve
that's really the question we want to
ask ourselves what is the goal of the
website well if it's somebody
downloading something okay are you
measuring that download via an event
okay our are they filling out a form
submission before they download so if
they submit that form submission is that
the goal or do you have any Commerce
site is somebody purchasing something so
these are things you want to ask
yourself before you actually set up the
goal what is it that I'm trying to
measure now when you actually do go to
set up a goal you're going to click on
the red CTA button that says new goal so
analytics actually has some templates
set up for you okay you can see them
here okay if you're somebody's
registering online or creating an
account or reading review downloading
something sharing something you could
choose all of these options here what I
normally do is choose custom 99 of the
time I'm just going to choose custom it
doesn't really matter if you use the
template or not it's just a template is
basically some free pre-filled
configurations but my recommendation is
always just go with custom you want
Total Control troll over how to set up
your goal so we already have in mind
what type of goal we want to set up so
for example if somebody goes to fill out
a form submission and they go to a thank
you page after that well what's the URL
of that thank you page we want to be
able to track how many people go to that
page because we know if somebody does
type in or fill in a form submission and
goes to that page we know that they
filled out the form and so for example
if I go to continue I'm going to name my
goal first so I'm going to say thank you
page as an example notice analytics is
assigning an ID so notice this is goal
ID 15. that means that that's the next
available goal there are 20 goals
available in analytics and so what
analytics does is they group goals
together so one through five six through
ten eleven through fifteen 16-20 into
goal sets so for example goal 16 through
20 is part of goal set for and why does
Google analytics combine these goals
into different goal sets well because
it's easier to measure and look at data
by goal sets so for example if I jump
into any report here if I go to all
traffic channels and I want to measure
how many goals by Channel I can look at
it by goal set so if I have goal set one
selected then I know any goal I have
active in there between goal ID one
through goal ID 5 I'm going to be able
to see those goals and goal set one and
now I'm going to be able to measure
every goal I have active and goal set
one against the channel so if I choose
goal set two whatever goals are active
there goal set three Etc notice I don't
have any goals 16 through 20 active
veteran goal set four therefore I don't
have that op option available to me so
back to admin the bottom left navigation
again goals okay we want to measure
somebody going to the thank you page we
have edit access we're going to choose
custom as our goal setup we're going to
type in a goal name I'm just going to
say thank you okay this is goal 15. now
this is the important part Google
analytics has four different goal types
destination duration pages per session
or screens per session to screens per
session is related to mobile because
Google analytics measures mobile app
activity and then you have an event so
we're going to cover all four of these
but for the sake of this simple example
I'm going to choose destination why
because if somebody goes to that thank
you page we're going to go ahead and put
in the thank you page as the goal the
goal URL so for example destination is
my choice I'm going to click continue
now this is where I'm gonna put the URL
so if my URL is just simply thank
you.html I can just go ahead and put
thank you.html or if it's just thank you
then I can just do thank you depends on
the website depends on the URI structure
so whatever that URL is that's what
you're going to put in and when you're
done you can verify it so what Google
analytics does is actually we'll verify
over the last seven days if anybody's
actually gone to that particular page so
if we click verify we can see zero
percent conversion rate so that tells us
that if this is the correct URL then
we've had zero percent people go to that
page this is just an example however if
you didn't see a conversion then you
might want to make sure you check the
URL here that you put in and if you do
see a conversion rate then you know it's
working so Google and analytics actually
has options so we're saying thank you is
equal to so the destination URL is equal
to thank you or thank you.html or thank
you.esp or whatever that thank you page
is okay you do have options so if you
have a long URL you could say it begins
with and you could say it begins with
say thank you so this is the logic we're
going to say hey if anybody goes to a
URL that begins with thank you then
count it as a goal or you could say
equals to so if anybody goes to a URL
that equals two thank you then count it
as a goal you have one more option Here
regular expression so Google analytics
understands the language of regular
Expressions so regular Express
expressions are just special characters
used to communicate with Google
analytics in order to hone in on exactly
what you're trying to track so we can
always say you know starts with or ends
with F so we can you know use characters
like the dollar sign ends with or begins
with so we can always do that so you can
use regular Expressions as well if
you're familiar with regular Expressions
if you're not then you don't have to use
them but there are special characters
where that you can insert in that are
used as regular expression so if you're
not familiar with regular expression
don't choose that option you could
choose the other option of equals to or
begins with now note that on all three
of these options I didn't put the domain
so if my domain is Amma
dashfoundation.org and then thank you I
don't need to put the domain because
analytics is already knows what domain
we're tracking so you don't have to put
in the domain here when you're entering
in in this case the Google URL so you
can omit the domain so when you put in
that URL you know that you have have
three options to work with and then you
always always want to verify that goal
URL you always want to verify it because
if you see zero percent conversion and
in this case of the last seven days then
that should tell you something either
your goal is not set up correctly or you
just don't have any conversion either
way you want to double check that now
when it comes to the destination URL
goal you do have an option here for
funnel so if I turn on funnel then that
means I have the ability to track how
people went through my funnel so if I
have a cart and I want to be able to
check how many people go in and out of
the cart then I have the option of
adding specific Pages as part of the
cart so we could say you know step one
which is basically cart we could say
step two is billing information that
could be slash bill Lane we could see
step three is shipping information slash
shipping and then step four could be you
know confirm and that could be slash
confirmation so whatever your url
structure is for your cart and it
doesn't necessarily have to be a cart
basically all I'm doing is putting a
series of steps with URLs as each step
and why do I want to do that because I
can then track how many people go
through my funnel that I've created okay
so here I could see this is my funnel
that I've created for this particular
goal okay and the funnel is only
available for the destination URL so the
funnels available if you want to see
traffic through the goal okay and how
people go through the funnel and where
they drop off now you have an option
here to make the first step require so
if you make that first step required
then that means you're measuring the
funnel through the first step only now
if I turn that off then I'm measuring
the funnel through each step meaning
that I can measure people as they drop
in and out of the funnel where if it's
required the first step then I'm only
measuring traffic as it enters in the
top of the funnel so you have that
option available to you the funnel and
then for all goals you do have a value
so if somebody did actually convert Okay
Google analytics is going to count it as
a conversion and you can assign a value
so if you're not an e-commerce website
then you may want to think about
assigning value if you are an e-commerce
website then analytics has the ability
to track e-commerce revenue for your
website so you don't need to add a value
but in this case let's just say your
non-profit organization and you're
collecting donations
and on average over the past year every
donation that somebody contributed was
equal to five dollars well you can just
go ahead and put five dollars in there
as the value for that goal so that means
that if somebody did go to in this
example slash thank you and convert
analytics is going to count it as a goal
and then assign five dollar value
alongside that goal so if you're
non-ecommerce if you're say a non-profit
like this organization or your B2B and
you want to track some value then you
have that option there so with the
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel with all goal types
you have the option of adding a value
all goal types and we're going to go
through the rest of them you have the
option of verifying that goal so that's
the structure of setting up a goal
destination URL is just one goal type
we're going to talk about the other
three goal types because in Google
analytics there are four goal types
again destination is one of the with
destination as you do have the option
with all goal types is you have to be
able to choose your logic here so we're
going to cover that with the other three
but just know when you set up a
destination URL goal you have the option
of adding a funnel now when you actually
do set up a funnel what's going to
happen is analytics is going to measure
traffic as it goes to the funnel so
where do you look for that funnel
information well you want to get out of
admin you want to go to the left side
navigation you want to click on
conversions then goals then funnel
visualization So based on the funnel you
set up you're going to be able to see
traffic as it goes through the funnel so
notice on this particular funnel we
don't have the first step required why
because I could see traffic as it goes
in and out of each step of the funnel so
let's go through this funnel and see how
people react so here I can see the first
step is the store front page so over
this particular period of time I had 84
sessions enter the storefront page so
out of those 84 I can see 21 left the
storefront page 63 went on to the next
step in the funnel which is the cart
page I can then see 24 people went on to
the cart page directly and five exited
the site all together okay so that gave
me 87 total and from 87 I saw that 82
went on to the next page for the next
step what analytics does is they give
you a percentage so in the first step we
had 63 move on to the car page out of 84
that's 75 percent so from the cart page
to the create your account page we had
94 move on so we didn't have anybody
enter in the create your account page we
didn't have anybody leave the create
your account page so if 82 percent 82
create your account and then we have 82
move on to the payment page so that's a
hundred percent okay we have one exit so
we have 81 that proceeded to beyond the
payment page which was purchased so 81
of 82 is 98
and we started with 84. so that gave us
plus the 24 that we accumulated along
the way so they gave us a 75 funnel
conversion rate so 75 percent of the
people who entered in the funnel went on
to purchase okay so don't be confused
with the overall e-commerce conversion
rate so 75 percent is the funnel
conversion rate the overall conversion
rate for this particular goal is 18.45
over this particular period of time why
because that takes into account all
sessions that have won to the website so
18 of all traffic went on to convert but
those that did go into the final 75
converted so that's a look at the funnel
so if you set up a funnel that's what
it's going to look like you have the
option to measure everything from step
one and Beyond or measure as traffic
goes in and out of the funnel so the
purpose of this is we're going to be
able to see where traffic drops off how
effective our funnel is what pages we
need to address in that funnel okay so
that's the whole point of the funnel and
the funnel is available with the
destination URL goal so if I go back to
admin if I go back to goals Under The
View I can actually see what that funnel
looks like so here we chose regular
expression so this is what the URL is
okay you can see our funnel in each of
the steps we have set up notice we're
using regular Expressions here and then
and if we verify this goal we could see
over the past seven days 19
conversion rate so that tells me
something's working in this particular
with this particular goal because we do
have a conversion rate okay so that's
the destination URL goals let's now talk
about the other three types of goals so
the next goal type we're going to talk
about is pages per session so if you're
not sure what type of goal to set up for
your website at the very least you
should try and set up either duration
related goal or pages per session
related goal so let's talk about the
pages per session so basically what this
goal is going to allow us to measure is
for example if we set the goal to three
pages per session then we're going to be
able to measure if how many people went
to the site and looked at three pages
per second session so let's take a look
at that goal so if I open up the goal
here I can see three pages per session
is what we're naming it so basically
what we're asking analytics to do is
anything greater than two pages which
would be three and Beyond count as a
goal so if anybody comes to the site
looks at more than two pages three pages
or more then it's going to count as a
goal and so here we can verify it so if
we verified over the last seven days we
could see a 4.12 conversion rate and
that tells me that four percent of my
traffic over the last seven days looked
at at least three pages or more so
you're probably asking yourself well
what number should I put in for the
actual variable so in this case we see
two well what you want to do is you want
to look at on average let's just say
year to day you want to make sure you
have statistical significance so you
want to look at a period of time so if
you go to analytics go to audience okay
and then if you go to overview and if I
change my date range to year to date I
could see on average right now I have
1.21 pages per session so that's on
average
so we don't want to make our goal one
page we don't want to make our goal two
pages we want to make it three so we
want to be able to basically measure at
a higher rate okay why do we want to
measure at a higher rate because if 1.21
is the average then two pages per
session really isn't moving the needle
so what we really want to do is get
people to stay on the site longer look
at Pages more during their session so
look at more pages and so we want to be
able to see what segment of the audience
is looking at more pages what channels
driving traffic that's looking at more
pages what pages are contributing to
more pages per session so the whole idea
is you want to hone in on what your goal
is and see what's working and then see
what's not working so you can make
adjustments the whole idea be on Google
analytics is to improves website
performance and so if our average is 1.2
then if we change it to just 2 it may
not be good enough so in this case you
know we want to up the bar a little bit
so we're going to choose three now you
can choose four or five that's perfectly
fine just know if your average is 1.2 I
wouldn't choose one page per session as
my goal and I probably wouldn't choose
two so I'd set the bar a little bit
higher now the third goal type available
in Google analytics is also engagement
related and that's duration so just like
pages per session we can measure how
long somebody stays on the website and
we could set up a goal for that so in
this case I have a goal set for one
minute 30 seconds so my goal type is
duration so if I click continue then
basically I'm asking analytics in this
case anybody who stays more than one
minute and 30 seconds on the website
count it as a goal and so so before you
actually put in the number of hours
minutes and seconds you want to look at
that average so if you go back to
audience overview here I can see a
minute and seven so do we want a minute
and 30 maybe we could do that maybe we
can go with two minutes so again the
whole point is you want to set the bar a
little bit higher than what the average
is and so here I could see over the last
seven days if I verify this particular
goal I can see eight percent of my
traffic over the last seven days stayed
on the site at least one minute and 31
seconds okay they stay greater than one
minute and thirty and so the whole point
is you can hone in because this is a
goal I can go in this is goal okay this
is a goal here and so I could see that
this is gold 13. so now I can go to
acquisition as an example I can go to
channels as an example since this is I
go this is goal 13 so that would be in
goal set three so I can actually see
what channel is basically driving that
goal okay in other words what channel is
driving traffic that is staying on the
side at least one minute 30 seconds and
so that's the whole idea behind goals so
likewise for pages per session we can go
into channels and here I can see we have
a over this period of time year to date
pages per session we have three percent
conversion rate and here I could see for
example organic search has a 13
conversion rate here I could see social
media has a 10 so I could see that or
people coming from organic search are
staying on the site longer or they're
looking at more pages than any other
channel so just like duration or
destination or any goal you set up you
can measure that goal against any
Dimension just because his engagement
doesn't mean you can't you absolutely
can and so the whole point of Engagement
related goals is to figure out what's
driving traffic the site but what
traffic is engaging so you want to be
able to pinpoint that so you can improve
website performance now the fourth goal
type available in Google analytics is an
event so if you click on new goal
include custom click continue you have
the option to choose an event so an
event is something that you can measure
on your website that analytics can't
measure by default so if you want to
measure PDF downloads or clicks on
buttons or clicks on play buttons on a
video or click on a submit button or
click on an external link I mean you can
measure pretty much anything with an
event then you want to be able to turn
that event into a goal so let's quickly
summarize what an event is so again we
want to be able to measure a particular
event that happens on the website so in
order to do so we need to identify that
event so if I go to for example this
particular website here and I want to
measure how many times somebody clicks
on the Donate Now button well if I met I
can measure that as an event so when you
set up an event in analytics you have to
actually assign a category and an action
for that event so that's the first thing
you need to do when you identify an
event or let it go first you need to set
up the event in order to set up the
event you need to assign a category in
action okay so once you identify what
you want to track as an event on your
website you're actually going to go on a
tag manager or have your web Master go
on a tag manager and set up a tag and in
that tag they're going to assign that
particular category in action and so
here you can see we have this set up our
category is named donate now and our
action is click and that's what we want
to do we want to measure how many people
click on that donate Now button so
anytime somebody does that then the
category donate now is going to appear
in analytics with the action click so
when you actually do set up an event you
can go into analytics and you can test
that event so if I go to the website and
I click donate now Okay the reason why I
have this as an event is because I'm
taking to a third-party website to
handle the donations so here I can go
into analytics and now I can see a
category is being fired for header
donate with the action click so that's
my category and that's my action so that
category in action is what is firing
after somebody clicks on the Donate Now
button so if I want to turn this event
into a goal I can easily do that now
that I've set up the event now that I've
identified the category in action I want
to go back to admin and set up the event
with these parameters in place so just
turns out we already have the goal set
up so let's go through how this goal is
set up so first we chose custom we chose
event we gave it a name it has the best
practice when you actually set up a goal
as an event or turn an event into a goal
I would add the prefix event colon to it
and then that way when you're
identifying goals in your reporting you
know it's an event so I'm going to click
continue and now that I've actually have
set up the event already in Google tag
manager I giving it a category give it
an action okay see here you can see we
have a regular expression set up so
anything with the header donate or
donate is going to fire this goal so
over the last seven days I have a 0.81
conversion rate okay I could have easily
put in equals two and put in whatever
the action what or the category which is
donate now or I could have put action
equals click I could have done that as
well so let me show you another example
here so if I do this custom continue
events donate now here's my goal ID it's
going to be in advance so all I need to
do is put in the category in action so
donate now and then click so that's all
I have to do and that's my goal so I can
verify it okay to see if anybody's fired
it and basically that's what I need to
do to turn that event into to a goal
okay so you need to set up for an event
first you need to identify the event set
it up and Google tag manager which is
another platform and once you've done
that then you have your category in
action once you have your category in
action you're again going to go into
analytics and then simply put in that
category and action into the appropriate
fields to set up your event related goal
now all events don't have to be turned
into a goal if you actually do set up an
event and you're not worthy of a goal
meaning it's not a kpi or a dozen align
with your business goals well don't fret
you can always just go to behavior okay
you can always go to events you can
always go to overview and measure your
events that way so here you can see all
of our events that are fired now we do
have this one turn into a goal so if
it's important for a business then we
want to make sure we we convert that
particular event into a goal okay if
it's not important for example
somebody's just clicking on a social
button then you don't necessarily have
to turn that event into a goal if you
don't want to know that it's sitting
here under events under Behavior so the
point I'm trying to make here if it's
important to your business and you're
already tracking it as an event via
Google tag manager then feel free to
turn it into a goal all you need is a
category all you need is that action and
so so one final note on that event
related goal just like any other goal
you can add a value okay so if I have an
event set up I can choose to add a value
here or in Google tag manager if I've
assigned a value to that event so if I
go back to the actual event and Google
tag manager you could say I have a value
set up for one dollar then I could just
go into analytics and say you know what
I already have the value added so go
ahead and use the value added in Google
tag manager okay so I'm going to choose
yes now if I choose no I have the option
to add the value here just like I would
with any other goal so just keep that in
mind you can add a value to any gold
type with an event related goal you can
add the value right into the tag in
Google tag manager just as I've done
here so remember when you actually set
up your goals whether it's a destination
pages per session duration or an event
you can just go ahead and choose that
goal set that it's in and measure any
Dimension against that particular goal
so here I can see e newsletter sign ups
by Channel I can go into another goal
set here I can see contact form
submissions okay I can see what
particular channels driving contact form
submissions okay so just know that you
can align a goal against any Dimension
so if you have e-commerce you don't have
to set up for goal for that that's
separate but if you want to take a look
at your goals and analytics on its own
you can just go to conversions goals
overview here I can actually get a good
sense of how my goals are performing
over a period of time so again if I
choose for example year to date now I
can see based on the goals I've set up
how many total goal completions value
which takes into account the value we've
added into these goals okay the total
conversion rate and here I can see it
broken down by the goal I actually have
set up and I could see it by Page or I
could see it by source and medium so I
could see Google organic is driving the
most gold completions then Google CPC
direct and then I could see some others
in here as well out contributing to
goals now I do want to point your
attention to another report in Google
analytics that does take into account
goals and that's multi-channel funneling
so again under conversion goals
multi-channel funnels if I go to
assistant conversions I can actually see
what channel in this example is
assisting with the conversions I've set
up and so what do we mean by assistive
conversions well that means that if a
channel let's just say organic search
drove traffic to the website and that
traffic didn't convert when it arrived
at the website and left but it came back
a week later via another Channel let's
just say email and when they came back
via email they did convert during that
session well what analytics does is they
give an assist to organic search because
they help Drive the traffic to the
website so it's similar to the game of
basketball if I have the ball and I pass
it to my colleague and my colleagues the
one who scores because they had the ball
last well they get the credit for the
point I.E the conversion but I get an
assist and so analytics works the same
way they're always going to give credit
to the last click or direct conversion
but they will give credits to the
channel in this case that assisted with
the conversion so that's under assisted
inversion and that's based on the goals
you have set up you can highlight any
particular goal here if I want to hone
in on say the Donate clicks only then
I'm going to be able to see what
contributed to that particular goal so
there's another report in here top
conversion pass that I think is
important so after you set up your goals
you can actually see what channels in
this particular example help to Drive
conversions again this is year to date
so I can see all the different
combinations of channels that work
together
to contribute to a conversion so again I
can choose a specific goal or I can
choose all my goals so those two reports
are under multi-channel funneling
there's also another report that I think
is good that's time lag meaning how long
did it actually take somebody to convert
so here you can see most of our
conversions 265 year-to-date happen on
the day somebody arrived on the website
but I could see I did get some
conversions a day later two days later
Etc so if time lag top conversion pass
assistant conversions they're all under
multi-channel funneling and they're all
available after you set up at least one
goal and so if you're not sure what goal
to set up okay don't fret you can always
at least set up an engagement let it go
so that's available to you duration
pages per session you also have
destination and event tracking and
they're all available to you you have 20
available per view now if you're not
quite sure exactly what type of goal to
set up there is an option available in
analytics and that's the gallery so you
can always import a goal from the
gallery so in other words we could take
a look at what other people have set up
in terms of goals so you just have to
click on the button import from gallery
and it'll take you to the gallery and
you'll be able to see what are the goals
others have set up how to set up event
tracking in Google analytics so welcome
and let's get started so many of you out
there have a website similar to the one
I'm looking at now this is a non-profit
that I work with I'm a foundation and
like this website and probably like your
website you probably have some
interactivity on there that needs to be
tracked for example buttons uh if you
have buttons like this one that says
donate or newsletter sign up or there's
a PDF download or a video that needs to
be you know tracked based on the amount
of people who click on the play button
so I mean all sorts of inter activity on
a website have you ever wondered how to
track that well there is a way to track
that because by default Google analytics
can't track interactivity and engagement
on your website like you probably want
to have your website tracked so if you
have buttons and videos and things of
that nature that you want to attract but
you're going to need event tracking and
if you're in analytics and you're always
wandering around the data and you happen
to find yourself under events well if
you want events on your website and you
want data to populate under Behavior top
events you're going to need to set up
event tracking so event tracking is a
two-part process and we're going to talk
about that two-part process the first
part of that is to identify what you
want to track okay so if we go back to
our example website here I'm a
foundation again we noted there's a lot
to track here we got to donate now Bob
we got a newsletter sign up we have some
social icons okay we got a donate Now
button here we got a play button here
got all sorts of interactivity you know
we got a button here that says you know
purchase tickets for an upcoming event I
can go throughout the website and find
different buttons and things to to track
let me just say this there's no shortage
of what you can track on your website
with event tracking so event tracking is
just basically in layman's terms
tracking engagement on your site because
Google analytics by default is only
going to track page view data meaning
how somebody got to your website what
page they look looked at how long they
stayed on that page what page they left
from more or less their timing how long
somebody stays on the website and what
pages they look at so there's more to a
website than just how long somebody
stayed on a page and so in this example
we want to be able to track everything
here not just the donating album but
everything because once you get the hang
of event tracking then it's very easy to
set up okay so step one identify what
you want to track okay so there's a lot
we want to track we're just going to use
one example to start off with and that's
going to be this donate Now button okay
so this donate Now button we want to
track now we have a newsletter sign up
we have Facebook and and that's fine you
could track all that but for the sake of
going through a step-by-step process
today let's just focus on the Donate Now
button what's focused on the Donate Now
button then we'll come back and start
tracking these other things but this is
what we want to track to start out with
okay so step step one identify what you
want to track now when it comes to
tracking events on a website you want to
identify those events so we did that by
choosing this donate Now button now once
we identify what we want to track we
need to assign two parameters for that
event so with event tracking you have
three parameters but one is actually
optional so you have two mandatory
parameters that you have to assign to
everything you want to track on your
website and that's the category and then
the action so event label or label is
the third parameter but again that's
optional okay so basically when we
identify an event on our website we want
to assign it a category and an action
okay so why do we want to assign it a
category in an action because when we're
in analytics under Behavior under events
top events we could see we have
different categories here and we have
different actions we have different
labels so if I click on any one of these
Dimensions I'm going to be able to see
some of the parameters I've entered in
for previous events I'm tracking okay so
the whole idea is you want to be able to
group different events together into a
category and assign an action and assign
a label to it that's really what you're
doing you're just grouping and
identifying the events you're trying to
track and so in this case I have this
donate Now button sitting in the header
okay in fact I have a lot of things
sitting in the header so if I wanted to
and I want to track all these buttons I
can create a category called header and
then if I track all these buttons all
these buttons can sit in that same
category if I wanted to or I can create
a separate category for each of these
buttons it's up to you how you organize
your categories because basically all
you're doing is giving a name to what
you're trying to track and the name is
equivalent to a category so in this case
the Donate Now button is very important
I'm just going to call it category
header donate now I need to give an
action to each category and so in this
case I'm just going to say click because
that's what the action is doing it's
it's somebody's taking the action of
clicking now if it's a video and it's a
play button I can assign an action of
play it's up to you whatever you name
these parameters you just need to be
organized and methodical about what you
name it that's all and so in this case
header donate and then click okay and so
that's our category in action and so
that's clearly step two so step one
identify what you want to track step two
assign a category action and or label
but remember label is optional so if I
go back in analytics here I could see
some categories and if I click on action
I can see some actions that I've named
now step three so we've identified in
Step One what we want to track we've
assigned a category in action so step
three is going into Google tag manager
to set up the event okay so if you're
not familiar with Google tag manager
then you can easily just you know do a
Google search for Google tag manager and
basically you'll have all sorts of
information on it there's a good video
overview of tag manager here that you
can watch so tag manager basically is
what we want to use to set up event
tracking now tag managers use for a lot
of different things but the main thing
we're doing here is setting up an event
for our website and so I'm logged in to
the same email address I'm using for
analytics okay so now I'm in tag manager
and I want to set up my event for this
donate Now button so what do I need to
do well for every event I want to set up
I need to set up a tag okay so if I go
to tags I can see I already have some
tags set up and some of these are events
and so when you actually set up a tag I
recommend having a naming convention so
here you can see any event we set up we
start out by calling it GA Dash event
Dash whatever it is we're trying to set
up and so in this case we want to set up
a new tag for the Donate Now button on
our website so we're in Google tag
manager because tag manager is what's
going to fire that event so if I click
on new okay and I click on tag
configuration I'm going to choose Google
analytics and then I'm going to choose
events as my track type so we want the
data to show up in Google analytics and
we're tracking an event we're not
tracking a page we're tracking an event
and so now remember in step two you
identified what you want to call that
category you identify what you want to
call that action and you have some
optional parameters like label so first
things first header donates the name of
our category and our action is click and
if you want to add in a label and a
value so if you want to sign a value you
can if you want to add in a label you
can okay those are optional so you just
need to focus on category in action and
then the last setting here that's
probably worth mentioning is a
non-interaction hit okay so this is
automatically set to false and why is it
set to false because it's a
non-interaction no that's false we want
this event if somebody clicks on the
header donate to be an interaction so
for example if I land on this page here
and I click on that donate Now button
that I'm tracking as an event and I
actually leave the site because I have
my settings set to false I want that
click to be an interaction then
analytics is not going to out a bounce
if I change it to true so from false to
true then that means it is going to be a
non-interaction if somebody lands on the
page and if somebody clicks on the
button so I don't want it to be a bounce
I want it to be an interaction so my
advice is leave it set to false we're
going to choose Google analytics as our
setting here this is our variable for
Google analytics so in other words that
variable is set to our analytics
property ID and more or less that's what
you need to do to set up the tag okay
you need to in step two identify the
category in action and or label and or
value now value can be anything you want
you're assigning a numerical value so if
you just assign one anytime that event
fires in analytics it's going to have a
value of one okay and so we have our
non-interaction set to false so anytime
the event fires it's going to count as
as an interaction and therefore not
count as a bounce if somebody landed on
that page so that's more or less all you
need to do to set up the tag and Google
tag manager now if somebody else is
setting up the tag for you then again
you want to revert to step two you want
to be able to give that person the
appropriate category action and or label
and or value why because you're the one
that's going to be going into Google
analytics and you're the one that's
going to have to go to behavior events
top events and look for the particular
at category in action and or label so
you need to be able to communicate that
information to whomever is setting up
the tag now if it's you great you
already know what it is because you're
entering that information into tag
manager so in this case I'm going to go
ahead and choose a variable for my label
parameter and and why do I want to do
that because in tag manager I have
something at my disposal called
variables and variables allow you to see
specifically things that are being
tracked so in this case I chose pagepath
okay so pagepath is a URL and why did I
choose page path as my variable for the
parameter label because if somebody does
click on the header donate button and
the header donate button on our website
is on every page if I go to the
children's page I'm still going to see
that header donate button and so for me
I want to be able to see what page
somebody clicked on that hitter donate
button and so this allows me to actually
see in Google analytics what page
somebody clicked on the header donate
Now button and so now if I go back to
GTM Google tag manager I have a category
I have an action and I have a label
which is a variable okay so note that in
Google tag manager you have a lot of
different variables at your disposal and
variables are there to help you identify
specifically what is being tracked so
take a look at all the variables at your
disposal and tag manager in this example
I'm using page path so now once you set
up your tag pretty straightforward again
tag types Google analytics track type is
event you are assigning the category
action and or label and or value you're
changing or leaving the default in place
for non-interaction hit and then you're
choosing the variable for Google
analytics which is your property ID so
once you've done that you have a tag the
second part of setting up a tag is to
assign a trigger to that tag so tag
manager needs to be able to know when to
fire that event and so here I'm going to
look at a trigger I've already set up
for this particular event and so if I
click on it I'll be able to see that
what it is is a click on some links not
all links but some links I'm actually
saying Hey Google tag manager fire this
event when the click ID equals header
donate button now it just so happens
that if somebody did click on this
donate Now button they're gonna go to
another website in this case
networkforgood.com so in tag manager I
could have set the trigger to equal URL
equal instead of Click ID I could have
said URL equal
networkforgood.com so that could have
been my Logic for my trigger in this
case I decided to go with the click ID
and so in this case that button has an
ID associated with it called header
donate button so if you wanted to use
click ID for your event for your button
you could simply just go to the website
you can right click on that button and
click inspect element and so when I
actually inspect the element I can see
now the button here you can see it's
highlighted in the upper Pane and in the
lower pane I can see where it's linking
to it's linking to networkforgood.com
but here you can see if I hone in a
little it I could see ID equals header
Dash donate dash button so that's the
click ID notice there's also a class I
could have set the trigger to equal this
class or again I could have set the
trigger to equal the URL or the page
that this button is pointing to I could
have chosen any one of those but I
decided to go with the ID so this is the
ID I chose and that's the ID I have in
my trigger okay so that is what's going
to file higher that event so if somebody
clicks on a button that equals header
Dash donate dash button it's going to
fire that event which is going to equal
category header donate action click and
then the label is going to be page path
so now that we've set up our events we
want to test to see if it actually works
so there's two ways to go about testing
an event and the first way is through
Google analytics so if we go to Google
analytics and then we go to real time
okay we can go to events and here you
can see one is already fired so let's go
ahead and go to and test this and go to
the website so if I go here for example
and I click on omagar alumni okay so if
I click on that you can see I'm under
our family and if I click on that button
then go back to analytics and look at
real time I should be able to see this
event fire so if I click on it I'm going
to go to network for good now if I go
back to analytics here in real time
under real time under events per second
I can see that event firing category
equals header donate the action equals
click now if I click on the category
here I can see the label the label
remember was page path and here you can
see this event fired on the our family
page which was the page I was just on so
that's one way to test to see if your
event works and in this case analytics
recognized the event so it works it
fired and so therefore it's going to
show up under Behavior under events you
can go under overview or top events okay
and what am I going to look for in this
case I'm going to look for header donate
okay if I click on hit or donate as my
category I'm going to be able to see my
action and if I click on action I'll be
able to see my label in this case home
page and then later on when the data
propagates in analytics I'll be able to
see under label the page that I clicked
on that header donate button which is
slash our family okay the second way in
which you can test to see if an event
fires is if you preview so if I click on
preview in tag manager okay I'm going to
go into preview mode okay and preview
mode allows you to see in analytics and
tag manager and on the website what tags
are firing so here I could see I'm in
preview mode now so I'm going to go to
the website and I'm going to refresh and
in my browser same browser I'm using for
tag manager I can see the tags that are
being fired on this page already okay
because I'm in preview mode so here I
could see remarketing I could see page
views I could see Google optimize I
could see some tags that are already
firing on this page now if I click on
this button here by holding down my
shift command and then click on that
button I'll be able to see that the tag
fired in preview mode there's my event
header donate and I can see it fired so
now I can see it fired in the preview
mode so in addition to Google analytics
in preview mode I could see that that
tag is fired and I know that it's
working so there you have it you have
two ways to test to see if the event
fires again you have real time in
analytics okay so in real time if you
just go up to real time all you need to
do is go down to events go to your
website click on the button if you see
it firing in real time then you know it
works the second version or second way
to test your event is through the
preview mode okay if you see it firing
in preview mode then you know it's also
working okay so let's rehash our steps
first step is we want to be able to
identify what we want to track okay so
it could be this newsletter sign up it
could be click on a Facebook it could be
anything we want to be able to track an
image a click on a CTA button whatever
we want to track identify it second step
identify the category action and label
because that's what's going to show up
in Google analytics remember label is
optional variable or excuse me value is
optional third step go into tag manager
actually set up your tag and your
trigger so if you set up a tag and it's
an event name it GA Dash events that way
you can see in your list of tags and tag
manager what event tracking you have
already set up so when you set up your
tag you set up your trigger your trigger
is based on logic that can be a URL it
can be a click ID can be a class ID
whatever you want to use to fire that
event and then once you do that you want
to test it you could test it in GTM or
you could test it in Google analytics if
it doesn't fire you want to tweak your
trigger if it does fire then great and
then one thing I would recommend is if
you're setting up various events for
your website that's the best practice
what I would recommend is set up a
spreadsheet and in that spreadsheet you
know you want to put a note what's
firing what are you doing to fire it
could be in this case someone somebody
clicks on the Donate Now button in the
header you want to put the tag name in
here the type okay then you want to
record your category action and label
and then the great thing about events is
you could turn those events into goals
and that's as simple as going back into
analytics okay so if I go into analytics
and I go to admin and I go to go tools
if you set up a new goal okay all you
need to do is choose custom click
continue you're going to choose event as
your goal name and then from a naming
perspective in Google analytics for your
goal I would definitely put event first
and then click on header donate okay so
if I click now continue what is my
category it's equal to head or donate my
action is click and so I can verify to
see if this is working and here I can
see in analytics that the goal would
have a 0.22 conversion rate so that
tells me that the goal is working and I
can turn this event into a goal and when
you turn something into a goal in
analytics then you can measure it across
all dimensions that's what I would
recommend if the event is equal to a kpi
or business goal or it's of importance
it's something you really want to
measure okay if it's just a click say on
a Facebook button I wouldn't recommend
setting that up as a goal okay so once
you've set up your event you recorded it
in your spreadsheet it's firing you want
to be able to then go back into Behavior
back into events okay you can go to top
events okay so top events tell you by
category as a default what events are
firing or what category is firing the
most okay so if I choose my date range
here I can just go to here to date so
here I can see my enter donate button
fortunately for me has the most total
events now notice in analytics you also
see unique events and so the difference
between unique events and total events
is that unique events are equivalent to
one per session where total events means
that somebody can come to your website
initiate a session and click on that
button multiple times in the same
session so if I go to the Yama
Foundation website okay I can click on
that donate Now button three or four or
five different times in the same session
so what analytics is going to do is
actually in that session count it once
but accumulate the number of clicks as a
total event for that session so you're
always going to have more total events
than unique events because in some cases
users May click on the button more than
once in the same session and so here I
can see total events unique events and
if I added a value to that event I
should be able to see it here so if I
added a dollar as an example to this
particular event because it had 164
unique events I should be able to see
164 as my value but since I see Zero
that means that I did not assign value
and so average value basically is just
giving me how much average I have have
per event so it's taking into account
the number of or the value the total
value divided by the total number of
unique page views or sessions and so
because I don't have value I'm not going
to have average value but here you can
see because value is optional here I can
at least see how many events or how many
clicks I receive for a particular button
again it could be a video if I clicked
on this video as an example I can see
how many people actually started it I
could see the unique and the total
events and if I click on label if I have
a label assigned then I'll be able to
see what page triggered that event so if
we go back again to our header donate
button back to category if we click on
label as our primary Dimension here we
can see the home page had the most
unique events been followed by the
children's page the contact form Etc so
what you can do in analytics you can
also look at the pages that have driven
events so here I could see the home page
has accumulated the most total events
followed by the contact us so that's how
you would look at the data in Google
analytics under Behavior under events
and then under top events or overview is
where you can start analyzing your event
tracking so first you need to do
identify it assign a category action
enter label set up that tag and Trigger
once you do that once you test that it's
working this is where you're going to go
to analyze the data
building a presence on YouTube is like
fine-tuning the engine of a car to get
maximum performance in YouTube terms
this means maximum views and maximum
subscribers to your YouTube channel
the instruments you have for this are
the video itself how you optimize it in
YouTube and the quality of the YouTube
channel you create to promote your
YouTube presence
if you do get maximum performance out of
your YouTube presence YouTube will
reward you by giving you the opportunity
to monetize your YouTube videos through
the YouTube advertising platforms
by the end of this lesson you will know
how to use the new YouTube Studio beta
how to upload and optimize a YouTube
video
how to create and optimize a YouTube
channel
how to create a playlist on your YouTube
how to make a great video and how to
monetize your YouTube presence
YouTube has just launched the new
YouTube Studio beta most of the YouTube
features like uploading and optimizing
your videos have been brought into the
new YouTube Studio better some of the
features like creating your YouTube
channel still need to be accessed
through the old version of YouTube
Studio soon these features will be
brought into the new version which will
make the old version obsolete
when you are successful in YouTube in
views and subscribers YouTube will give
you the opportunity to monetize your
YouTube presence
upload video on desktop
to upload a video on YouTube you can do
that on the desktop and you can also do
that on the mobile
let's have a look at the desktop version
of uploading your video
so what you do is you go to the
youtube.com home page and as long as
you're logged into your Google account
you see your little login account info
here
you will then see on the left a little
camera with a plus sign and that's where
you can upload a video click on that you
can then upload your video or you can go
live streaming so let's click on upload
video and that takes you to this screen
where you can select a file to upload or
you can drag and drop the video file you
can immediately add the settings for
published public unlisted private or you
can schedule the video you can also
import videos from your Google photos
drive you can start live streaming from
here as well and there is a new feature
which is called Premiere this is where
you can schedule a video and invite your
followers to watch the video together
with you and when the schedule dates is
there the video goes public on YouTube
and you can watch it together on a
Premiere screen
so what I'm going to do is to select the
file to upload I just click on the
finder and then I can drag the video
file here in the Box
and while it is uploading I can enter
basic info of the video in this case I
will call it flower garden in Malaysia
you can then give a description you can
set tags
so when the processing of the video is
complete you can pick your thumbnail and
then you click publish and you will see
that the video is Live on YouTube
so let's select set the thumbnail you
can see that the processing is done and
here I click to publish the video is now
live so if I click here on the link it
will actually take me to the video and
there is my video on YouTube The Flower
garden in Malaysia
upload video on mobile
to upload a video through your mobile
you have to use the YouTube mobile app
once you start a mobile app you will see
at the top of the little video icon
when I click on that icon there are
various options you can choose from I
can click record if I want to create a
video that I want to upload I can click
on go live that takes me straight into
the live streaming of my video or I can
select a video from the video library on
my phone so for this demo I will click
on select the video and then I can
select a video that I want to upload
there are some basic editing functions I
have on the video I'll show that in a
later demo and if I want to select this
video I click on next and as we saw with
the desktop demo I can add a name and
the description of the video and I can
then upload a video on YouTube
the video is now uploaded so once the
video is ready you will see it in the
list of the videos and then obviously
you can go into the edit mode to add
more details in the title or in the
description and optimize your video
so now you see that the video is
uploaded to my list of videos on YouTube
and you can also see it's just placed
above the video that I just uploaded
through the desktop version of YouTube
YouTube Studio bedtime
YouTube has come up with a new version
of the interface to manage your videos
on YouTube it's called YouTube Studio
beta not all the features have moved to
the new version for those features that
haven't migrated yet YouTube will but
direct you to the old version of the
interface or if you prefer the old
interface YouTube will still give you
the option to switch back to it
but like they do with migrations to new
interfaces after a few months they will
switch the option to move back off
the new interface is very simple to use
let me show you the desktop version of
it and then I will show you the mobile
app for it
to access YouTube Creator Studio beta
you have to be logged into your Google
account and when you're on the
youtube.com home page you click on your
little photo here on the right and then
you click on YouTube Studio better
that will take you to the YouTube Studio
beta dashboard
what you see here at the bottom left is
Creator Studio Classic so you can still
switch back to the classic format of the
Creator studio and again if you want to
switch back to the studio better you
click here on Creator Studio better to
go back to the new interface
there are still a few features like
creating playlists translations
transcriptions that sit in the old
version
when you select those you will go back
to Creator Studio Classic
so what's there to see on the dashboard
first of all you have your latest video
that you uploaded with some basic
information
you can go to the video analytics of
this particular video and to see
comments
you also get a list of your channel
analytics highlights
it gives you a link to your channel
analytics and your top videos of the
last two hours
and then here you see content that
YouTube presents like YouTube news and
information about Creator Insider
here they give you additional videos
where you can learn about how to use
YouTube
it will also show you some ideas on how
to improve your Channel or in this case
help navigating the new interface
here on the left you have your main menu
you can go into your videos analytics
check out the comments go to the
transcriptions of your videos and other
features
and then down here you have your
settings and Link back to the Creator
Studio Classic
so if we click here on videos you have a
list of all the videos that you have
uploaded on YouTube
it's much friendlier and much better
accessible than in the old Creator
Studio Classic so here you see the two
videos that we've just uploaded
and then here you see what is the
visibility of the video and the date
that you published it
you'll also see how many views how many
comments and how many likes or dislikes
a really good new feature here is the
inline editing as we call this if I want
to quickly change the title or the
description of this video I don't have
to open the video and click on edit I
can actually click it here I can
actually change it here in line so
there's a few things I can do in line
edit the title and the description get a
link promote for advertising download or
delete the video
so if I say edit title and description
and add in Cotswolds and then in here
I'm just clicking and then I'm just
clicking save and you see it will
automatically change the title so this
is a very easy and convenient new
feature I can click here and see the
video directly on YouTube as well
and here you see the analytics so when
you click on analytics it takes you to
the general overview of the analytics
where you can see what's the activity
and what's the views that we got in our
Channel
what are the top videos that people are
watching what is the real-time activity
happening on your videos and then you
can see here about the viewers the
interest of the viewers the built-in
audience and how to earn Revenue
so we'll get back into the analytics
later but at least here you have an idea
of what you can get from the Analytics
you can then check out the comments that
you had on the various videos
you can look at the transcription files
that you've had for your videos and
which ones have been published and then
it takes you to your other features as
well
in the settings you can set things like
the currency that you're using what your
default experience is for the classic or
for the new YouTube Studio better
you can have your channel settings like
the name of your channel the keywords
for your channel and the country for
your Channel
you can check on your community you can
add filters you can look at the
moderators and the proved users that you
can add and you can look at other
settings like your Advanced channel
settings or Channel branding
but you will access these through the
Creator Studio Classic
so this gives you a short overview of
the Creator Studio beta
using YouTube Studio on a mobile
to access YouTube Studio on your mobile
you have to download a mobile app and
then when you open the mobile app you
could almost like a similar experiences
on the desktop
it starts with your dashboards this
gives you an overview of your analytics
of the last 28 days the last videos that
you uploaded the last comments that you
received and the total number of
subscribers you have to your Channel
to access the menu you tap on the
hamburger button on the top left and
this gives you a similar list of options
that you have on the desktop version you
can go to your videos you can check your
playlist check the comments go to your
analytics and change your YouTube
settings
when I click on videos it gives you a
list of all the videos that you uploaded
for each video you see the number of
views the number of comments the number
of likes the number of dislikes you can
sort the videos by most recent most
viewed and you can look at all the
videos you can filter by draft by public
unlisted and private videos
the few from your mobile is very easy
and it's simple to browse through all
the videos that you've uploaded on your
mobile you can look at your playlist and
make some changes to your playlist
and then you can also check the comments
on the videos
if you click on analytics you get more
detailed stats about your videos
you can see your overview any Revenue
that you would have made you can look at
analytics for your playlist and it also
gives you analytics of any interactive
content that you have used in your
videos like click-throughs or cards
let's go back to the dashboard to
complete this demo this gives you an
idea of what you can manage through the
YouTube studio app
now that your video is uploaded on
YouTube there are two things that you
may want to do first you may want to
edit the video like trimming the
beginning or the end or adding some
special effects to the video and you
definitely have to optimize the video
for search on both YouTube and Google
so let's have a look at both of these
areas and to start with editing the
video let's take for instance this video
here a video blog that I did a little
while ago
if I click on the video it takes me to
the area where I can add the information
to optimize the video and I'll come back
to that later
but here you can click on editor and
this takes me to a full screen video
editing mode it's a very basic video
editing so it doesn't give you all the
functionality like for instance iMovie
or Adobe Premiere but it does the thing
for you if you want to make some quick
changes to the video you can trim the
video you can add music or play with the
sound of the video you can add an end
screen to the video and you could blur
faces for instance on the video These
are basic functions but they work really
well let's have a look first at the
sound
if I click here on audio and I open the
audio library that YouTube has it gives
you a full library of royalty-free music
tracks that you can add to your video so
for instance I can select hear the noise
I can add that to my video when it's too
loud you have a slider where you can say
favorite to the original audio so now
you hear my voice in the background in
today's video blog let's go back now and
close this
you can also add an end screen to the
video and there are a number of
templates you can choose from
an end screen will show during the last
20 seconds of the video you can show a
playlist or a subscribe button or you
can have reference to two different
videos or two videos or playlists so
different formats that you can choose
from let's pick the two video template
when I click on apply then here you
would see how that will show in the last
20 seconds of the video when I play the
video you see that I haven't added any
video but this is how it would show as
an end screen in your video
and then you can add blur to a video as
well you can blur faces or you can blur
specific areas in your video
this is all I will be showing you on
editing your video as I said before it's
a basic video editor but if you want to
do some quick editing on your video
before you publish it then this is a
really good tool to do just that
so the next thing you want to do is to
optimize your video for YouTube search
and for Google search so how do you go
about it when you select a video let's
take this one Epic Fail how to ruin your
life on an EasyJet flight
you click on the video and that takes
you to the basic optimization screen
there are a few things that are
important here first of all the title
this title epic fail how to ruin your
life on an EasyJet flight is an
interesting title it tells people
there's something happening here it's
very important to use your words like
epic fail people like seeing videos with
epic fails so remember title is
extremely important
there are two reasons why people decide
to watch a video on YouTube number one
is the title number two is the thumbnail
and that's the next thing you want to
optimize YouTube will pick a few
thumbnails based on your video but you
can also upload your own thumbnail the
third part is also important the
description of your video it's important
that the description of the video is in
line with the title and what the viewer
is going to see
make sure you use keywords that are
relevant to the video and to your
business
and here you can add tags tags are key
for the search it helps people to find
your video based on the tags that you've
set
here you can see the public URL of your
video and here you can decide on the
visibility of your video do you want
your video to be public private or
unlisted unlisted video will be public
but they won't show up in the search
here you can select a playlist that you
want the video to be part of you can
assign a video to the various playlists
that you have on your Channel
this is where you can create cards in
the end screen in the video editing demo
we looked at how you can add end screens
and how you can add video cards to your
video
if you click on it then you see the
editing mode and here are the different
types of cards that you can add
like a video or a playlist or a Channel
or you could even create a poll where
you encourage viewers to participate
so you just click on the create and then
you can pick a video from the list that
shows up
that video will actually show up and
then here you see where the video card
will appear
so if we go to the beginning of the
video and we will click play Then here
you see the suggested video popping up
so you can now save the changes and go
back to the editor
so these are the basic settings for the
optimization of your video and you can
also go to the advanced settings there's
a lot more that you can add in the
advanced settings
you can add the recording date the
location of the video and you can also
add the license and write ownership of
the video
if you are part of the commercial
network with YouTube you can select a
syndication where you want your videos
to show
you can select a category for your video
the language and the caption
certification when there may be
television FCC regulations regarding
closed captions
also upload your subtitles and closed
captioning YouTube will actually create
subtitles for you and then you can check
that later
it is not 100 accurate but at least it's
a good starting point for your subtitles
finally you can set things like allowing
comments and ratings and enabling age
restrictions as well
you can allow people to embed the video
and you can also tick whether the video
contains paid promotion like product
placement sponsorships or endorsements
so lots of things that you can set in
the optimization and when you're happy
with it you just click save
Google and YouTube will then include all
these settings in the indexing of the
video and the better you do all this the
more likely your video will show up in
the search
so let's go to Google and check this
Epic Fail video
we have a good thumbnail and a good
title
if you go to Google and search for epic
fail EasyJet for instance then you see
that the video immediately shows up here
in Google and that's obviously what you
want for your videos you want them to
show up high in the videos or in the
image section of the search results page
and if you do the same search in YouTube
then you would like your video to show
up as well and you see here immediately
it shows up as the first video
so this is all there is to optimizing
your video
another important part and we briefly
touched on this are the subtitles and
the transcriptions that you may want to
add to your video
first you want to check if YouTube
created transcriptions for your video
take this video blog for example if I
select other Futures you see here
translation and transcription
the automated transcription from YouTube
has not been brought into the new studio
beta so I need to go to the old Studio
of YouTube
so I click here on the old classic
Creator Studio translation and
transcription and then here you see the
link to the published transcript file I
haven't put these in this is something
that YouTube will do when it's a video
that's worth transcribing
you could copy the texture you can
download it and then use that for a blog
post or for the show notes of your
podcast you can also add language and
you can set the transcription on
published or draft
very useful features and very important
to make sure that your video is
optimized
creating a YouTube channel
to create a YouTube channel you have to
go to your YouTube homepage and then you
click on the little photo here that you
will see when you locked into your
Google account
when you click on the settings it will
take you to the screen where you will be
able to click on the button see all my
channels or create a new channel
so let's click on this and now you will
see the screen where you can enter the
name of your Channel
and in this case I'm going to call it
Riyadh for Russia
I click create and you will then get to
the page where you can start customizing
your Channel
if I click on customize Channel I see
the blank version of the YouTube channel
where you can add your logo your channel
art and where you can add a channel
description
so let's start with adding a short
Channel description
welcome to my YouTube channel of Riyadh
farasha
when we're done with that we can add a
logo to do that you click on the little
pencil icon it will actually take you to
the brand page of your Google account
click on edit and you can upload a photo
click on upload photo and here we are
going to upload this image
once it has uploaded the photo you can
play a bit with the size of it you can
move it up a bit if you want so I'm
going to move it so I only show the
mosaic
I click done and then my brand page has
been updated with the image
if I now go back to the YouTube page and
I do a refresh you will see that the
image has been added to the YouTube page
I can do the same for the channel art
click on the channel art you need to be
aware that you don't have a lot of space
to play with for your image so you need
to make sure that you have a horizontal
photo that will show enough of what you
want to cover in the banner
a nice feature is that it will show you
how it will look on the desktop how it
will look on the TV and how it will look
on the mobile
and if you're not happy with it you can
adjust the crop a little so I can zoom
in and then move it up
so at least I see a little bit of the
mountains and a bit of the mosque on the
photo
when I'm happy with it I click select
and then you will see that you have
uploaded a banner
and you are now ready to start
optimizing your YouTube channel
checking the YouTube channel settings
so the first thing you want to check
when you start optimizing your channel
is your settings of the channel
you can access the channel settings by
clicking on the little card wheel on the
top right
click on that and this will take you to
the basic privacy settings
you can keep your videos private
subscriptions private your saved
playlist private you can customize the
layout of your channel and you can show
the discussion tab
so you can basically switch all these
options on or off and you can also
translate your channel info the basic
settings you can find on this little
screen but there are more options in the
account settings and in the advanced
settings
so let's look first at the options in
the account settings this is where you
can look at what you're going to share
on YouTube
you can look at your connected apps for
instance in this section
do you want any other apps to connect
with your YouTube you can also set how
to connect your TV to the YouTube
channel you can connect your YouTube to
a particular TV device and you can look
at your Billings and payments and your
playback and performance this is where
you can control your video experience
you can show annotations and in-video
notifications you can also set that the
captions are always on or when that's
available Show automatic captions by
speech recognition
you can also set the notifications for
your YouTube so you can receive emails
about your activities if you want
updates from YouTube or notifications
around Channel subscriptions and other
notifications like recommended videos if
I go back to the main Channel page and
I'm going back into the settings I can
then also go into the advanced settings
for my channel in the advanced settings
I can check the country that I'm based I
can set keywords for my channels I can
disable interest-based ads and I can
link my AdWords account I can activate
Channel recommendations and display the
subscriber account this is also where
you can integrate your YouTube channel
with your Google analytics so look a bit
further up here I can see The Branding
options that I have so I can add a
watermark to my Channel videos I can
also set defaults for uploading my
videos this can be quite handy if you
have standard text that you want to use
for every video
and I can set some standard tags for
instance this can be helpful when you
upload lots of videos so the standard
defaults are already set and then
finally here you see the status and
features of your channel this is where
you have all the different options that
you have with your channel and you can
check what the status is the different
elements that are enabled and elements
that you are eligible for and the
elements that you are ineligible for for
example we're not eligible for
monetization because we haven't signed
up for it and we haven't passed your
requirements for this
so for all these things we can see
whether we have it enabled whether we
are eligible or whether we are
ineligible
and that's all there is to the settings
so let's go back now to the channel by
clicking on the logo and we can then
start looking at the optimization of our
Channel
how to optimize your YouTube channel to
start customization and optimization of
your YouTube channel you have to go to
the standard Channel page and click
customize Channel
here you see the structure and elements
of your YouTube channel an important
feature is that you can look at your
channel as yourself
as a new visitor or as a returning
visitor
you can set a video at the top of your
YouTube channel which will change
whether you're a new visitor or a
returning visitor
but let's first look at the different
elements of your YouTube page that you
can change
you can add videos to your channel you
can add playlists to your channel and
you can connect with other channels you
can manage your discussions and you can
put more info in your about section
this is also where you can link to your
other social media Pages these will show
on your channel Banner and you can
feature other channels that you would
like to promote on your YouTube channel
so you start with adding some videos to
your channel click on videos and you see
this channel has no video yet
remember how we uploaded a video in
YouTube by clicking this little plus
icon and we say upload video we can then
select a video that we want to upload
let's take this short video at some
basing settings and set some tags
once the video is processed you can then
publish it on your channel page
and if you go back to your Channel
you will see that the video has been
added so that's how you can upload
videos to your Channel
you can then look at playlists here you
can add a playlist to your channel a
playlist is a group of videos around a
particular topic and then you can
feature those playlists as chapters in
your YouTube channel it makes it very
easy to organize your videos
to create a playlist I click on new
playlist I give it a title Marrakesh in
this case
edit if I click create and then your
playlist has been created then you need
to add videos to your playlist
if you go back to the video and play it
to get into editing mode then in the
settings of the video I can say to which
playlist I want to add this video
I select a playlist that I just created
and click done and I save it and then I
have added a video to my playlist
so if I now go back to my YouTube
channel I can click on playlists and
there is my Marrakesh playlist and it
currently has one video
I can add channels so I can link to any
other channel I may have
I can manage my discussions and I can
manage my about page in this section as
well
I can activate business inquiries so
people can send me an email through my
channel
I can specify my location and I can add
my social media links who will then show
up in my YouTube channel Banner
you can also add featured channels for
instance I want to add the social media
examiner YouTube channel I can add that
and I can click done and then it will
show in the featured channels
if I'm happy with the settings I can go
back to my channel and then you see what
we've done through the channel right now
we've got our first video we have our
feature Channel and we have our playlist
so this is how I can optimize my YouTube
channel
one more thing I would like to show you
if I click customize Channel
then I can see here the featured content
which will show up on the channel for
either returning visitors or new
visitors
if I click here on feature content and
then I pick for instance the video that
I just uploaded then this is how it will
show
I can add a heading for this content so
for example I can say feature
presentation and I click save
and now you see I have a feature video
for the returning visitors
I can also do this for new visitors I
can create a channel trailer for
instance I pick this video and then I
click save and that's how it will show
for new visitors so these are the basic
things you need to look at when you want
to optimize your YouTube channel
YouTube channel views and subscribers
now that we know how to edit and
optimize your videos and your YouTube
channel we will turn our attention to
how to grow views and subscribers on
your Channel
first there is your channel optimize
your channel page write a compelling
Channel description use a great Channel
logo and a banner and create a channel
tagline
then there are your videos make an
awesome Channel trailer video publish
long videos of 10 minutes and more
promote videos in your end screen add a
branded Watermark and add a subscribe
button and enter videos with a strong
call to action thirdly there is your
channel management
reply to every comment and hard grade
contents
and finally promote your Channel
embed YouTube videos in blog posts and
promote your channel in ebooks webinars
presentations and Lead magnets doing all
these things right will certainly help
you in growing views and subscriptions
to your Channel
tube buddy is a great tool that can help
you in growing your video fuse and your
channel subscriptions
it's a Chrome browser extension and it
adds a layer of functionality on top of
your YouTube channel
it has features that focus on SEO
promotion and analytics and it also
tracks the video rankings of your videos
but also the videos of your competitors
it's a great tool to find keywords for
your videos and you can go to your
competitor video and check what tags
they have set and use these as keywords
for your videos
it also helps you in publishing videos
on your channel you can schedule videos
to be published and added to playlists
you can make bulk updates to your videos
including the descriptions and it also
helps you to create eye-catching
thumbnails
factors that make a great video of
course it's not only the optimization of
the video that makes the video
successful it is also about the video
itself done well you can use your iPhone
to make highly professional Cinema
quality videos that are being watched by
millions as insane a feature movie from
film director Stephen Soderberg proved
let me give you some tips how to make
great video think about composition
point of view and Lighting First
composition is about how you place the
different elements in the scene put some
thought into this use the rule of thirds
and focus on people's eyes I'll explain
the rule of thirds shortly point of view
is the angle you are using of the lens
of the camera in relation to the subject
be creative with this use a low angle or
a high angle and change these regularly
lighting can make the difference to a
good or a bad video always be aware of
your light source and also know that
daylight is the best light source there
is but different times during the day
can give different shadow effects in the
video for instance noon sunlight creates
unflattering Shadows whereas a cloudy
day can produce more softer lights using
the right equipment is also very
important in shooting great videos
obviously your phone can fulfill most of
the camera requirements like shooting
video and recording sounds and it will
give you an acceptable level of quality
make sure the resolution settings on
your phone are on 4K or 1080 HD and it's
set at 24 30 or 60 frames per second
avoid zooming avoid backlights and use
both hands if you want to up the quality
to professional then you may want to use
a high quality DSLR camera an additional
gear like a tripod and a microphone
the road leveler microphone is a great
mic that you can attach to your iPhone
and your color it gives excellent
quality sounds and you can overlay that
sound over the sound file of your video
earlier I promised you I was going to
explain the rule of thirds they are part
of the basic rules of composition the
rule of thirds is a compositional rule
that suggests dividing the image into
thirds and placing the subject on one of
those sides instead of in the center
it is one of the most important
composition techniques used by
professional photographers
but there are others as well for
instance using balance and symmetry in
your video or apply leading lines in
your video
these lines direct a fewer to a
particular section of the screen finally
as I mentioned before a simple rule is
to focus on the eye it gives a point of
focus
monetizing your YouTube channel
there are various ways that you can make
money with YouTube but it depends on how
strong your subscriber base is and how
many views you get on your channel if
you are qualified then you can
participate in Google's AdSense program
which means that you can get revenue
from ads being placed before or during
your videos when people watch them
this works very well and many Publishers
on YouTube get a significant Revenue
stream through this channel
you can also try to get sponsorships for
your channel this can take the form of
brand or product sponsorship for which
you will get paid
you can also look into affiliate
marketing with this you can advertise
products from your affiliate Partners on
your channel and you would get a
percentage of the sales that comes in
through your channel and finally if
people like your videos then they may
commission you to make videos for them
as I mentioned before you need to have a
strong channel to qualify for Google's
AdSense program which means you need to
have at least 4 000 watch hours in the
previous 12 months and 1 000 subscribers
to sign up for AdSense you need to go to
the old version of creative studio and
click on channel and monetization
you can set the monetization preferences
and which video you want to run the ads
with
if you qualify Google will then approve
your request and you are ready to start
earning money with YouTube here are the
key takeaways of this lesson YouTube has
recently launched a new version of
YouTube studio called YouTube Studio
beta getting few and subscribers on your
YouTube channel is based on your video
the quality and optimization of your
channel and how you promote your Channel
composition lighting and point of view
are important contributors to the
quality of your video
and you can make money with YouTube
through advertising sponsorships and
commissioned work welcome everyone this
is Rob Sanders and welcome to today's
webinar Youtube advertising So today
we're going to talk about YouTube
advertising so thanks again I'm Rob
Sanders and I'm with simply learn and
let's get started and we're going to do
a little role playing here and let's
just say you're an Advertiser and you're
not sure where you want to advertise
your products you have a product that
you want the entire world to see well if
you want to advertise your products and
let's just say you have some really good
video of your product that you want to
get out there really there's no other
place to look to than one place in
particular is YouTube hence the reason
why we're doing this webinar because
today we're going to talk about all
things YouTube advertising and for those
that don't know you YouTube is owned by
Google and a lot of what you're going to
do is advertise on YouTube via Google
ads So today we're going to talk about
YouTube advertising and we're going to
focus somewhat on Google ads so buckle
up and let's get started with why is
advertising on YouTube a good idea so
why is it a good idea well if you
haven't been on YouTube of late you
should check it out youtube.com and just
take a look at the vastness of videos
that are on YouTube now YouTube is a
video platform but if it was a search
engine it'd be the second largest search
engine in the world only behind its
parent company Google so it's a very big
platform with a lot of videos and hence
there's some good search functionality
on YouTube so you can look at it as a
search engine there's 1.9 billion and
growing logged in visitors on a monthly
basis so you have a lot of people that
go to YouTube and watch videos on a
daily basis okay it has local versions
and more than 91 countries so if you're
an Advertiser who's focusing on a
specific Market or you're in a different
Market with a different language you
have 91 different options to hone in on
okay so a little bit more about YouTube
here and why is advertising on YouTube a
good idea well most YouTube users are on
mobile almost 70 percent almost three
quarters of those that you use YouTube
use it from their mobile device which is
staggering but not so staggering
considering most people in the world now
have mobile phones or mobile devices and
most people use their mobile devices for
multiple reasons and watching videos is
one of those reasons so mobile
advertisements receive viewer attention
83 percent of the time so what do we
mean by that well on YouTube we have the
opportunity to get your ad in front of
people who are watching those videos so
if a lot of people are engaged and
watching a video on YouTube and you're
advertising on that particular video
well then you're going to get some
attention and so that attention has to
be in the 80 percentile okay so a lot of
people are going to you know pay
somewhat attention to your ad and it's
their secret video ads have proven to be
more effective and engaging creating
greater impact and and that's just not
on YouTube I mean that's that's on
Facebook that's on other platforms like
Twitter Instagram so video is an
engaging way to communicate it's a lot
better than traditional texts it's a lot
better than say a display Banner because
it's engaging people are going to watch
what you have to say and if they like it
they're going to share they're gonna
comment on it they're gonna subscribe
there's a lot of things that people can
do when it comes to video advertising so
video helps expand and your digital
reach so basically if you are running
those Tech stats and display ads well
having video kind of adds some more
Arsenal to your advertising portfolio so
to speak so if you're running just those
text ads and swipe banners that's fine
that's great because you can reach a lot
of people but having video just adds
another piece of the element and because
video is so engaging you might find that
even for yourself if you're advertising
different types of ads video display or
text you'll find that you know video
does have really really expansive reach
to a particular audience and the other
thing here about YouTube is YouTube
helps to find a relevant audience for
your ads using Advanced targeting so
just like anything else that we've
talked about here at simply learn when
it comes to advertising whether that be
Facebook or Instagram or Google ads we
can really hone in on our audience here
and that's really important and we'll
get to that later because when you're
advertising you want to make sure your
ad is in front of the right people and
if we're talking about video and we're
talking about high engagement if you
have your video in front of a really
relevant audience then chances of that
audience engaging are going to be even
greater and then YouTube and video ads
themselves provide provides a situation
that can be customized to fulfill your
marketing goals and so what do we mean
by that so basically YouTube allows us
some additional features where we can
customize our ads so meaning if our
marketing goal is to just get our ad in
front of millions of people well that's
not a problem if our marketing goals get
people who you know we want to convert
well we can customize our marketing goal
towards that as well so just like on
Facebook and some of these other
platforms we've talked about YouTube is
no different and so we could set
specific marketing goals uh for our
video ads some other good pointers to to
talk about here with YouTube so with
YouTube just like on Google ads we can
enable running cost-effective campaigns
and what do I mean by cost effective
well meaning we can really watch our
budget we can measure how how much it
costs for 1 000 people to watch our
video we can measure how much it costs
for somebody to click on our video ad we
can measure the cost of when somebody
clicks on our video ad and converts how
much does that costing us so you can
really run cost-effective campaigns even
on YouTube and YouTube helps determine
how successful your ads with Advanced
analytics so not only do we have
analytics on the YouTube side of the
house but we also have analytics on
Google ads and so we can really hone in
and use both platforms to really figure
out exactly how our ads are performing
and then ads that I've reported a 500
growth in views of the Channel's other
videos so basically you can see growth
in view just by advertising on YouTube
so let's get in now to what are the
types of ads you can run on YouTube so
we discussed all the benefits of YouTube
we can go on for another two or three
hours because there are plenty of
benefits but I think you get the point
of you know YouTube being a place where
you can grow measure and reach a custom
audience so you're already sold on
YouTube now let's talk about those types
of ads you want to run on YouTube so
depending on what goal you want to
achieve with your ads there are
different types of AD formats available
on YouTube so our first set of ads
evolve around building brand awareness
and app recalls so if you're in the
business of promoting your product or
your brand or your service then these
are the type of ads you want to run on
YouTube building brand awareness and AD
recalls because what it does is it's
really going to get your ad out there
and front of thousands and millions of
people lots of eyeballs lots of
Impressions impressions are the number
of times your ad was seen so ads
centered around brand awareness are
really ads that are going to put you out
there in front of a large number of
people with the goal of potentially
attracting new customers and ensuring
your brand is on top of their mind so
top of funnel brand awareness is always
introducing the brand getting people
familiar with the brand and getting them
to your website so that you can
introduce them to your brand and service
and product so that's the whole idea
behind the ads we're going to introduce
behind the goal building brand awareness
and AD recalls so let's take a look at
what those are so we can build brand
awareness and add recalls so we call
these these types of ads true view for
reach okay so when we say true view
meaning our ads go into pair and for
front of a video and we want to make
sure that that adds in front of a lot of
people so skippable ads that will enable
your brand to reach as many people in
your target audience as possible at the
most efficient price so the whole idea
is we're trying to build brand awareness
then we could set it up on YouTube so
there are ad appears before other videos
and that's going to ensure that our ad
is going to show up in a lot of places
based on the audience we Target and if
we can get our ad in front of a lot of
people a lot of targeted people at an
efficient price then how can you say no
to that so these ads are skippable have
an open video length and their bidding
is based on cost per 1000 Impressions so
cost per 1000 Impressions CPM means that
you're paying YouTube for every 1 000
people that looked at your ad okay so
that's what cost per 1000 Impressions or
CPM means that you're paying YouTube not
when somebody clicks on your ad but one
one thousand Impressions occur and
oppression is when somebody looks at
your ad and so that's what you're going
to be paying YouTube you're going to be
paying them for 1 000 views or
Impressions basically okay so the ads
are skippable but they have an open
video length and it's based on eyeballs
so that's the whole goal there when it
comes to Brand awareness you want to go
with a CPM model that ensures you're
getting your ads in front of lots of
people to accumulate Impressions and pay
by Impressions so this is what the ad
looks like and now we're going to talk
about the type 2 ad that you can run on
YouTube and we call these bumper ads so
they're non-skippable ads with which you
can share your Brand's message in six
seconds to drive reach and impact so
we've all seen these videos before and
I'm going to share an example with you
here when you're on YouTube you really
can't get to that video that you really
want to watch until you watch a few
seconds of that video ad and so that's
what these bumper ads are they allow you
to really make sure that your ad is in
front of that target audience still it's
still pay by Impressions but you know
that your ad is going to run for a few
seconds and the idea behind that is
really you want to get your message out
there and it really does help to drive
reach and impact and so let's take a
look at an example on YouTube of what a
bumper ad looks like so here's an
example of a bumper ad on YouTube again
it's only six seconds but this example
is pretty popular on YouTube it's Been
viewed a lot and we're just gonna take a
quick look at this video here this video
has six seconds but the whole point is
to really look at the ads purpose and so
if we hit play
[Music]
so that was it that was the ad six
seconds long it appears in in front of
other videos as an advertisement and the
whole point of these bumper ads is
really you have to get your message out
there quickly because the video is going
to start and you want to really make
sure that your message is being
delivered and you want to keep in this
case maybe keep users guessing as to
what it is and so this is why it's a
highly effective ad you know you got a
diver jumping off a diving board into a
pool that is basically drying up over a
period of time and so for curiosity the
old saying is curiosity kills the cat a
lot of people are probably going to
click on that ad to figure out what is
the subject what are we all talking
about here and really the point of the
the video was to bring awareness about
global warming but that's it that's a
six second bumper at example and you
really if you're gonna run bumper ads
you want to make sure that you your
message out there so it has to have
really high impact okay so again they're
non-skippable they have to be of six
seconds and their bidding is based on
again cost per 1000 Impressions so it
gives you an a chance to get that ad out
there in front of a lot of people again
you're paying on a CPM model you're
paying Google for every 1 000
Impressions okay so that's could be 1
000 different eyeballs looking at that
ad so if it's high impact you know if
it's non-skippable then chances are you
can get you know some clicks some some
eyeballs over to your YouTube channel or
to your landing page on your website so
let's take a look at this one from
Alaska Airlines better yeah let's take a
look at this example from Airbnb I found
it to be a little bit more impactful
than the Alaska Air ones so let's take a
look at this example actually so we went
on vacation with a toe different and
left with a cannonballer
okay so high impact ad great ad by
Airbnb really impactful we went on a
vacation with kids playing you have your
logo on the bottom right corner of the
video and you know it gets people
excited about travel so similar to the
Alaska Airlines which we didn't look at
this one is just as good high impactful
you know getting people to you know
react within six seconds isn't exactly a
very easy thing to do so you got to make
sure these videos really resonate within
the time frame that you have so let's
take a look at type 3 here so we're
talking about reservation of 15 to 20
seconds so these particular ads can span
up to 20 seconds to increase reach and
make a last impression so unlike the
bumper ads which are six seconds long
these reservation ads tend to run a few
seconds longer up to 20 seconds okay so
they're also non-skippable and like I
said can be up to 20 seconds and bidding
is Bay based on a fixed CPM and what do
we mean by fixed CPM well if you're
bidding on a regular CPM model meaning
that you're paying Google for every 1
000 Impressions that number could be
variable what you pay Google in this
case the fixed CPM is fixed at a certain
rate it could be you know ten dollars
for every one thousand Impressions
twenty dollars it really depends on
where you're advertising and who else is
advertising so let's take a look at some
examples of a reservation ad on YouTube
up to 15 to 20 seconds long so here is
an example of a 15 second ad you know
also called a trueview ad so you can see
this ad is going to run for about 15
seconds before the video actually plays
it's non-skippable and so let's just
play this ad
who can paint the corners is known as a
red brand at GMC we get that
everyone loves that kind of precision
this is GMC okay so you could see the ad
itself uh ran a little bit longer than
your traditional or your six second
non-skippable version and the 15 second
you know allows you to get you know more
of the message out there still high
impactful but allows us to get the
message out there
um with a little bit longer of a video
and that's non-skippable so it's so
going to run for its entirety up to 15
20 seconds before the video actually
starts playing so let's now turn our
attention to the fourth type of AD you
can run on YouTube and that four type is
an outstream video ad and so these ads
are going to reach users wherever
they're watching regardless of the site
or application so the whole point of the
outstream we want to be able to get our
ads out there regardless of the site or
application okay so these ads are also
non-skippable and they could be 15 to 20
seconds long and their bidding is based
on on viewable cost per 1000 Impressions
and so what do we mean by viewable cost
per 1000 Impressions what we mean by
viewable cost per 1000 Impressions is
basically if you're paying for ad
Impressions measured as viewable you you
can use this model and basically what
that means that an ad is counted as
viewable when 50 of your ad shows on
screen for one second or longer or plays
continuously for two seconds or longer
so there's some criteria about the
viewable but you're definitely paying
for Impressions you're just paying when
those Impressions showcase the ad 50 or
longer or for one second or longer for
you know other type of video ads or it
plays continuously for two seconds or
longer for video ads so if a play is in
short if it plays for longer than two
seconds then you're going to pay for
that impression and so that's going to
count as an impression and that's
viewable for 1 000 Impressions so if you
get your basically your ad to show for
two seconds or longer then then that's
going to count as an impression so for
example with the viewable CPM for
example if you bid
um 1000 viewable Impressions and you pay
for Impressions that are measured as
viewable and add is counted as viewable
again when 50 of your ad shows on the
screen for one second or longer for
display ads and two seconds or longer
for video edits so uh so that's
basically what it's about so really the
key number here with viewable CPM is two
seconds or longer that's the difference
between regular 1000 Impressions CPM and
viewable 1000 Impressions vcpm so let's
talk about the next type of AD format
you can run on YouTube and the next one
is Masthead and so Masthead is unique in
that basically they only run for 24
hours okay so and they run on YouTube's
homepage so you can imagine the amount
of reach that you can have by
advertising on YouTube's homepage so
they're highly visible okay they can run
on multiple devices desktop app mobile
and basically these ads sit at the top
of YouTube's homepage so their fixed
cost per day pricing involved and so the
best thing to do is to contact YouTube
if you're interested in advertising on
YouTube's homepage so that's the
Masthead advertising and basically these
ads are non-skippable they have an open
length and again their bidding is based
on fixed price per day so here's an
example of what the Masthead looks like
on the home page so you can see here
this is that GMC ad okay you can see
that they have video supported with a
banner and you know call call to action
out there and so what YouTube is
actually experimenting with are you know
different ways for advertisers to buy
Masthead ads okay so it's you know these
ads are very prominent so it's it's
basically YouTube is now offering the
option uh to buy Mouse head ads on a
cost per 1000 impression basis so
they're playing around with that cost
format so just keep in mind that this is
a recent change by YouTube so
traditionally it's cost per day but now
they're actually offering the option for
advertisers to buy a Masthead ad on a
CPM basis so just keep that in mind you
do you do have the option here so at the
end of the day if you're interested in
math test ads and having your ads show
up on YouTube's homepage for 24 hours I
would still contact Google and ask them
about hey I want to pay cost more 1000
Impressions so YouTube is actually
offering up that option on pricey model
so so the second set of ads we're going
to focus in on are centered around this
strategy of growth consideration and
interest and the whole idea behind
growth consideration and interest is
really we want to get our ads in front
of people who could be potential
customers but we want to influence them
okay we want to influence them at a
point in time when they when we think
they're going to be most receptive to
our message so that really means getting
our ad out in front of the Right
audience at the right time because the
message we put out there is going to be
centered around you know getting them to
not only take notice of our brand
potentially take action so it's moving
our audience a little further down that
funnel so really growth consideration
and interest it's all about placing your
ad your message in front of that
potential customer when you think
they're going to be most receptive to
the messaging you're putting out so
that's what growth consideration and
interest so let's go back and look at uh
let's talk a little bit more about those
true view ads so true view ads are one
of the most popular ways of advertising
on YouTube so if you're interested in
you know getting growth getting leads
getting conversions you might want to
think about some true view ads because
basically these ads can run before
during or after videos on YouTube or you
can run them on video partner sites and
applications again if you're interested
in driving not just brand awareness but
you know clicks to your site so if
you're interested in driving impact for
your brand of products you might want to
focus on the true View and stream ads
again these are the traditional ads
you've probably seen before on YouTube
that run before during or after a video
and these ads are skippable so you're
likely to have seen the skip ad uh call
to action button they have an open video
length in their video is based on cost
per view so you're paying when somebody
views your ad and so what what's what
does that mean cost per view well let's
break that down cost per view bidding is
the default way to set the amount you'll
pay for a true view video ad so when are
you actually paying well you're paying
when somebody views your video and but
there's a threshold here so a view is
counted on YouTube when someone watches
30 at least 30 seconds of your video ad
or if it's shorter than 30 seconds and
let's just say it's 20 seconds then
that's going to be considered a view so
30 seconds is the number here you need
to be concerned about when you're
running a cost per view model so if you
have a video that's one minute long and
they watch 30 seconds it's considered a
view and that's what you're going to pay
you're going to pay cost per view so
that's what the cost per view model is
and that's the really the default model
with trueview ads whether that be before
the video during the video or after the
video it's it's cost per view so let's
talk about the other type of trueview AD
and that's the true view Discovery and
so basically What trueview discovery is
is your ads are placed in YouTube search
results next to related videos or on the
YouTube homepage so you're getting your
ad discovered more or less you know
throughout YouTube and including the
YouTube homepage so here's an example of
what that looks for looks like and so
let's jump over to YouTube and take a
look at that so if I do type in let's
just say surfing I may scroll down and I
may see some ads I may not see some ads
so basically if you see an ad it's going
to have ADD next to it and so that's
when you know your ad is being
discovered on YouTube and so here in
this example we don't see any ads
showing up here so remember those true
review Discovery ads are going to have
something with the ad next to them that
way you know it's an advertisement and
they're going to be found in the search
results on YouTube's homepage or any
page where you're actually searching
okay third set of AD types center around
driving action and so the whole point of
driving action is getting that potential
customer to actually take action on the
ad that they see so in the case of
videos we're going to have some call to
action stronger call to action to get
these folks over to the website to
purchase or download or you know sign up
for a newsletter or do something you
want them to do in terms of your
business model so if your business model
is selling a product then the whole
point of driving action on your ad is
getting them to buy your product we want
so the whole point of driving action is
making it easier for customers to take
meaningful actions that you can measure
so the ads we're going to introduce are
centered around getting potential
customers to take action okay so that's
what driving action is further down the
funnel and getting folks to react to
your ad so that they can take the action
that's aligned with your business
talking about true view ads now and so
again these ads Discovery can show up on
search results on YouTube's home page uh
you have your traditional in-stream
trueview ads where they show up before
during or after and then here you have
true view for action and so these true
refer action ads are video ads to drive
any action that's important to your
business so again it goes back to that
marketing strategy so the ads we looked
at are early on were about Impressions
so a lot of the cost models for a lot of
the ad types were cost per 1000
impression and notice now that you know
it's it's now cost per view for trueview
ads and you want to be on a different
model when your marketing strategy is
more aligned with getting people to take
action that's important to your business
for example shopping or buying something
or getting a quote or or downloading
something so if that's your marketing
goal you want to go with a true view for
Action if that's what's important your
business because these ads are intended
to get users to interact with a
clickable button that leads to your site
so that's the whole idea behind trueview
for Action type ads okay so these are
skippable they have an open video length
and their bidding is based on cost per
acquisition so CPA different cost model
so let's now talk about what CPA is so
the cost per acquisition model is in
this case since we're trying to drive
action we're gonna pay when somebody
actually takes that action so somebody
actually does shop and they spend twenty
dollars then basically you're gonna pay
for that acquisition so basically if
it's to download something whatever it
costs for you to get that person over
and they actually download that's what
you're going to pay so cost per
acquisition is really a model based on
action so when somebody actually
performs that action that's when you're
actually going to pay Google so that's
what CPA is and that's what the YouTube
true view for Action ads are all about
trying to drive action so let's talk
about the universal app campaign for
video and so this is all about driving
action as well so these ads promote your
app on YouTube so where your ads are
more likely to be clicked and your app
downloaded so again targeting an
audience and really it's about you know
getting people to look at your
application your mobile app so that's
what these ads are all about they're
about promoting your mobile app on
YouTube okay so these ads are skippable
okay they have an open video length Okay
meaning you can make them as long as you
want and again their bidding is cost per
acquisition but you also have some
additional models as well so we already
talked about what cost per acquisition
is because this is a actional based ad
so we want people to do something like
download our app but you also have
another cost model here cost per install
and you only pay when that person who
watches or sees that ad clicks on it and
actually does install the app okay you
also have another model that you can
apply here and that's the return on ad
spend and a return on ad spend basically
is you're asking Google hey I want to
make sure that if I'm going to run this
type of AD I'm getting my return on
investment meaning if I spend a hundred
dollars am I getting a hundred and one
dollars back so that's the return on ad
spend that's a cost per install and a
cost per acquisition so you have three
models here for the univ reversal app
campaign about some important metric for
YouTube so we've thrown around a lot of
different cost models when we talk about
the different types of advertising you
can do on YouTube and so with that
there's a lot of metrics so let's go
through some of these metrics here you
have views clicks you have view rate so
you have all these different types of
metrics and for some of you it could be
confusing so what am I need to look at
look at what do I need to measure so it
really does come down to you know what's
important to your business that's always
first and foremost but here we listed
some of the most common metrics
available to you with YouTube Okay so
let's go through some of these and
basically a view is just it shows the
number of times people watched or
engaged with your video ad so a view
rate is basically the number of views or
engagement you're at receives and the
number times your ad is shown okay so
divided by the number of times your ad
was shown into the number of engagements
so if your ad was shown a hundred times
and you had one like or one click for
example then that would be one percent
so average cost per view is the average
amount you pay whenever your watch is 30
seconds of your video so remember when
you're on a cost per view model remember
30 seconds is the magic number so if
your video is only 25 seconds then
remember that's going to be the view so
it's got to be minimum or maximum 30
seconds if your video is under 30
seconds it's 25 seconds or 20 as an
example then it's still going to count
as a view if it's a minute and somebody
watched at least 30 seconds of it then
that's going to count as a view so just
keep in mind 30 seconds is the magic
number here for the view so if somebody
watches at least 30 seconds of your
video or engages with your video that
would be a cost per view so that's the
average amount you're going to pay and
watch time is basically it measured the
total amount of time people watched your
video ads shown in seconds okay so it's
the total amount of time so it gives you
an idea of how many minutes total your
video is run so it's focus on clicks so
clicks is a common metric across the
board it shows the number of times
people actually clicked on your video
not to be confused The View so views the
number of times your video was actually
watched a click is something also
measurable and it's when somebody
actually clicked on it so it's an
indicator for how well your ads are
doing with those who see it and so you
know we want people to click on our ads
if we're running you know actionable
type video ads if we're running those
action at type ads or Universal app ads
we're going to want people to take
action okay if you're running ads just
for Impressions that's one thing so
clicks is an important metric depending
on the type of video ad you're running
so click the rate is the number of
clicks you you receive from your ad
divided by the number of times the ad
was shown so my ad was shown a hundred
times and I received one click then
that's one percent click-through rate so
let's talk about engagement and
engagement is the number of clicks on
interactive elements such as icons in
your video ad okay so that's what an
engagement is here the number of clicks
on interactive elements and then if we
look at engagement rate then any clicks
on an interactive element that we
receive is going to be divided by the
number of times the ad will show so
that's why we have engagement rate as
well so we want people to engage with
our video is there something that
they're doing on the video if so then
what's the rate at which they're
engaging earned views sets a number of
views who have seen subsequent videos on
your Channel or watch Pages after seeing
your ads so watch Pages or videos on
your channel if you've seen those after
seeing your ad then that's going to be
called an earned view so somebody seen
your ad and was impacted by what they
saw if we look back at the examples we
shown earlier on with the global warming
or the GMC or the Airbnb ads you know if
I saw those ads and I said man that's
really a cool ad or that's really a good
message I'm going to go over to that
that watch page or I'm going to go over
to that channel and see what other
videos they have when you do that that's
an earned View and then if you can get
an earned view you're probably going to
get an earned subscriber because it's
the number of viewers who subscribe to
your channel after seeing your ad so
again going back to any of the ads that
you've ever seen if you've ever gone
over to their Channel and then subscribe
to the channel that's an earned
subscriber so your video ad is doing
something for you it's in this case it's
getting you a subscriber so let's talk
about how to create a YouTube ad so this
is going to require some access to
Google ads and we'll go over that in a
few minutes here but first we need to
think about setting up a campaign and
setting up a campaign goal okay what's
the goal of our campaign to get eyeballs
you know we want to pay costs for 1000
Impressions or we want to run some
actionable type ads to get people over
to our website so that really is step
one we need to identify what the goal of
our campaign is then we need to create
the ad so we want to be able to create a
video ad here that is going to show on
YouTube and to our target audience so or
whether it be a bumper ad that's only
going to be six seconds long we need to
be able to figure out what type of AD we
want to run so here I am in Google ads
if we're going to run a campaign on
YouTube we need to make sure that we're
choosing a display campaign and so
remember the first step is you know
setting up that campaign setting up that
campaign goal so we're going to go ahead
and select a new campaign here we're
going to run a new campaign 10 and so
what's the goal of our campaign so if
we're just out to generate brand
awareness and reach that's certainly
fine if it's all about sales or if it's
all about leads then you know the type
of video run is going to be a little bit
different so if we select Grant
awareness and reach okay here we're
going to select the campaign type and so
if we select video basically what we're
doing is we're going to tell Google we
want to go ahead and set up some video
ads on YouTube and so here you can see
the different types of video ads we
discussed today you know we got your
bumper ads you got your skippable
in-stream non-skippable so the
difference being that if it's
non-skippable somebody has to watch the
entirety up to 15 seconds okay so we
have our outstream which is basically
our viewable CPM model so we're gonna go
ahead and you know check one of these
types of campaign types or ad types so
we're going to click continue and then
once we do that you know we're going to
get prompted to you know move forward
with selecting our ad so you can see
here after I set up my campaign now I'm
just going to go through some of the
settings for my ad and I'm going to give
it a campaign name a budget okay when it
starts or ends the bidding strategy so
again we're going to focus on cost per
1000 Impressions and then here's the
network so this is an important
selection here so we're dealing with
YouTube videos so we also have the
option to select video Partners on the
Display Network so that means that if
you want your video to show on websites
that want to host ads in video format
then you can select this option here
notice you also have this option
available if you're running certain
types of ads on YouTube we're running
those bumper ads so bumper ads aren't
available on search results so I'm going
to stick with the video Partners okay
YouTube videos and here we can get into
some other specifics like language
country the type of inventory so here
you can see the default is standard
inventory so that means that this is
what Google recommends we want to show
our ads on content that's appropriate
for most ads okay so we can go expanded
or limited so we're going with the
recommended here okay and then when we
go down we're going to have an ad group
so when you create an a campaign you can
have an ad group so with an ad group
that means that we can have a more or
less a video in every ad group we have
but we have to have at least one ad
group so we're going to go ahead and set
up you know this ad group here and
here's where it gets interesting and
important because here is where we can
start targeting our audience so here we
got demographics okay so we can choose
gender age parental status household
income okay we can focus in on audiences
if we want to so we can we can choose a
specific audience that we've set up we
can get some ideas or browse specific
audiences we could also choose a
specific placement so here you have
YouTube videos or we can go with YouTube
specific channels okay or we can even be
on apps okay we have to set a bid for
our Target CPM and once we do that
basically it's all up to now for us to
add our video ad and so remember in this
example we're going to Bumper out so
we're looking at about six seconds and
once we do that then that's pretty much
the campaign but I just want to stress
here that when you're setting it up
ahead of time you want to make sure you
identify what the campaign goal is and
then that's going to align with the type
of video you're going to run and then
once you choose that type of video then
it just comes down to where you want
that ad to be and who you're targeting
so it's really crucial here that you go
through these steps and these options
very closely so because you want your
video to show in front of the Right
audience on the right placement so let's
talk about how you can optimize your
YouTube ads so once you get your
campaign set up once you select your
Channel or the type of videos where you
want your ad to be and you select your
target audience and you're off and
running with your video ad well we're
going to give you some tips here that
you can focus on for optimizing Those
ads and so going back to what I was just
saying on the setup you want to
carefully Define your metrics and goals
okay so that's step one so when you're
setting up the campaign remember you
have that option to choose the type of
goal for your campaign that can be brand
awareness it could be a sale it could be
a lead so to me that's the you know a
very critical step one so you want to
make sure you align your goal with your
video and then the second is track low
performing ad placements so if we just
ask Google to place our video ads
anywhere they want then it's up to us
then to go through and choose the ad
placements and remove them okay so let
me show you an example of what that
means so if I'm back in Google I'm going
to go to my campaign and I'm going to
select placements and here I could see
placements but then I'm going to select
where my ads show and so this is
important you want to be able to scan
the list of placements where the ad was
shown so if you don't like one of the
placements on YouTube you can always
select it edit it and exclude it from
the campaign or adverb so that's really
the key is you want to be able to manage
your placements properly and when we say
low performing ad placements we mean
really what what's your goal if your
goal is to get sales or leads if you're
that placement is not converting sales
or leads then you need to remove or
exclude that placement so it's all done
within the Google ads platform and then
you know know you can also use a custom
thumbnail image in your ad as well it's
always helpful in terms of optimization
so a couple of other pointers here to
help you optimize okay you want to drive
people to perform a particular action
with the appropriate CTA so again
depending on the ad type you know if
it's a true view ad 20 seconds long you
want to have a call to action you want
to maybe even have your domain name at
the end of the video so at least
somebody knows where to go so you always
want to have a call to action with your
video ad you want to use negative
targeting specify who gets to see your
ad and who doesn't Okay so that goes
back to your settings so you can pick
and choose who your target audience is
you can pick and choose who you don't
want your audience to be okay as an
other setting you can use closed
captioning in your ads to make it more
interactive so that way people can
actually see or read what the ads all
about just to make it a bit more
interactive you can always perform a B
test testing on your ads so if you have
one ad version you can create another
one just to see what it which one
performs better testing is always a
positive okay so if you're paying too
much maybe think about reducing your
bids so if you remember we said a ten
dollar CPM bit that may be too much
maybe we don't need to pay ten dollars
so we can always reduce our bids at the
ad group level so reduce bids and areas
where you see lower performance so in
other words you don't want to pay a lot
for poor performance you can also use
remarketing to re-engage with customers
so if somebody views your ads and
doesn't take action you can always
retarget that person uh to show your ad
another even another ad format it could
be text ads or display ads but if
somebody looked at your video and they
didn't take the action you preferred
them to take then you can always
retarget them with another ad so that's
a good way to optimize okay so we want
to to make sure the ad has content that
what viewers would find relevant okay
that really you want to make sure that
your ad is you know is with the end
viewer you don't want to put out an ad
that isn't going to give somebody you
know a good feeling after they watched
it okay so you want to make sure viewers
find the content relevant so if they
don't find it relevant then that means
your engagement rate and your engagement
is probably going to be low so you want
to take a look at those metrics that we
viewed earlier engagement rate
engagement and if they're low then you
probably need to look at the content of
the ad so try to make sure your ad
conveys your Brand's message in the
first six seconds so that's why bumper
ads to me are so critical because you
got to get the entirety of the ad and
make it impactful and so with any AD you
run any video ad you're on you really
want to make sure that that message is
conveyed at the very beginning early as
possible otherwise it's you know people
are going to be turned off or not
engaged and just going to go ahead and
skip it anyway so you want to make sure
you get the purpose of it right up front
and out of the way okay you can also
include Visual and auditory components
in your ad that can make it more
memorable to the viewers okay meaning
music or other cool visuals okay so
again you want to be able to play around
and test different ads and you want to
be able to you know measure the ad
Performance Based on the metrics we
discussed I mean click-through rate
engagement rate all of those are
indicators whether the ad is of good
quality or not with the end user and
when I say good quality I mean do they
find it engaging do they find it
interesting or so they're going to click
and if you don't have good click-through
rates or good engagement rates then you
definitely want to try doing something
different to the ad like adding those
audio components or other visuals that
could be appealing to the end user so go
ahead and and test some of those out
with a B testing because you have
nothing to lose but higher or lower
engagement rates or lower click-through
rates so you want to be able to improve
those metrics improving those metrics
means trying some different components
on different ads so let's take a look at
a case study if you will and let's focus
on super dry so they're a good success
story on YouTube so super Drive leaned
on some YouTube advertising to help lift
one of their products so in September
last year 2018 super dry if you're not
familiar with the brand they're you know
centered some Asian markets European
markets and they focus in on clothing
all different styles and sizes and
genders from jackets to jeans to
t-shirts and so they're a global brand
they really wanted to take a different
approach here and their approach was
they wanted to focus in on sales they
wanted to see if video can help lift
them with sales and so what they've done
is they set up some hands on YouTube and
their focus here was on jackets and
jackets to specific ages across the
board all genders and interests and so
what they did was they wanted once take
advantage of all the different ad types
that YouTube had to offer and let's take
a look at one of those ads here so if we
go to YouTube and let's just take a look
at this one minute ad here 53 second ad
by super dry
I'm ready now
this is the jacket the jacket you're
raving the jacket you're waiting the
jacket you're pulling the jacket you're
playing
you'll take five in this jacket you'll
wanna find this Jackie I washed a jacket
your breath not your death in this
jacket it's the jacket your cream is
a jacket you're hiding you're vibing
love live and praises
this is the jacket
the jacket that will get you through
so that's the video that's super dry ran
you could see that you know it was it
had some particular goals there and so
super dry is pretty well known so it
probably wasn't built around brand
awareness per se it was probably growth
consideration and interest and also
driving action okay it's a pretty cool
video it was definitely not a bumper ad
because bumper ads are six seconds so it
was definitely a true view probably take
action and so whatever ads they actually
did run specifically they did see a lift
and so we kept pulse on superdry's
account and these videos actually had
you know 4.8 million views and so cool
video ran for 53 seconds not a long time
not a short time was able to you know
Target Their audience a younger crowd
you noticed in the ad they had different
jackets both female and male different
gender types so they were messaging a
very broad audience of gender some
younger people is who they were
targeting so younger people tend to
slant on YouTube and so they were able
to get some nice views out of it 4.8
million but the more important thing is
because these videos were to drive
action and so they were able to see a
four to one ratio on return on
investment and as a result these jackets
saw a hundred and thirty eight percent
increase in brand lip I mean the jacket
ad so it was a pretty successful
campaign see as well choreographed good
audio good video just well
professionally done and they probably
were able to now get a few more loyal
customers under their belt because of
this at alone so that's the power of
video okay so you're able to know who
your target audience is you can go out
and Target them with a cool video and
given that YouTube is vast then you can
really take advantage of a lot of their
ads so what they probably did again was
those true view in stream ads with a
cost per view through a skippable video
ad format and they they also use the
shoppable ad format so that is another
option on YouTube so they took advantage
of all YouTube had to offer in terms of
who they were trying to Target the
length of the ad and given that their
product or selling a product or
promoting a product they will take
advantage of the trueview shoppable ad
format which basically lists your
products alongside the actual video app
and so this is just a good case study
you super dry we'll probably do this
again a based on the numbers that
they're reporting and so basically
that's the power of YouTube getting out
in front of your audience with a really
good video ad targeting an audience
taking advantage of different formats
hey guys welcome to this video on
YouTube ideas for 2021 YouTube is the
social media platform that needs new
introduction launched back in the Year
2005 YouTube was a fresh breath of air
for the people who were slowly becoming
aware of the hype that surrounded the
internet several other platforms like
Dailymotion redmi and VMO which
admittedly have their own fans have
tried to stand up against the Behemoth
that is the YouTube and failed slowly
but surely marketers began to realize
the enormous potential that YouTube
offered they could add small
advertisements like they do in the cable
TV they could show banner ads and do
much more and all of the thanks to the
robust advertisement features that
Google already offered if you're not
already sold on why it's important to
advertise on YouTube here are some facts
that might change your mind YouTube has
more than 2 billion users across the
world I've got fraction of that audience
could be shown your product and could
turn from users to customers next
important fact is that 8 out of 10
marketers consider YouTube to be one of
the best platforms to advertise their
products and services followed by that
people watch one billionaires of YouTube
per day as you watch this video you are
contributing to that number
next 62 percent of the business use
YouTube to post content this could be
just videos on their products tutorials
event announcements and much more 70 of
the YouTube watch time comes from mobile
this means that when you create an
advertisement for YouTube you keep the
mobile users in your mind and finally 90
percent of the people say that they've
discovered new products or brands on
YouTube which means that by posting on
YouTube your brand awareness is highly
likely to increase now let's talk about
the video ideas
the first one is behind the scene videos
these videos give you the opportunity to
showcase your audience how your business
or brand operates a creatively made
video on the inner workings of your
business will show off a more human side
of your brand and make you more
relatable to your audience it is also
guaranteed to get you loads of views and
engagement here's an example how Amazon
showcases the warehousing and
distribution aspects of its products it
takes the viewers into the factories and
involves the various people working
there this shows to the audience that
even a large organization like Amazon
how each individual has an important
role to play in the overall process
next we have the company culture a video
that highlights your company culture
will tell the audience what your
business goals are what its values are
and why it exists it can also focus on
the various people who make sure the
company works in the way it does this
can help better connect with your
audience here's an example a company
culture video created by GoDaddy the
popular domain register
the video talks about how GoDaddy
creates a fun inclusive and energetic
environment for its employees it
includes interviews of employees talking
about why they enjoy working in GoDaddy
so much and this helps the audience
relate with the company and could also
catch up the interest with some
potential job Seekers next we have the
third idea that is the marketing team a
brand is nothing without the people
working behind it and that's where these
videos come in these videos will help
shine a light on the people who create
the products that the audience knows and
loves this helps create a personal
connection with the audience these
individuals can end up becoming mascots
for your brand
here's an example of Meet the team
focusing on Olympus group the video goes
into the history of masket makers plan
and the people that make it a grand
success the lighthearted tone of the
video also greatly helps with making it
more relatable now we have number four
product showcase or announcement
a product Showcase Video aims to show
the features and benefits of the Brand's
latest offering to its audience these
short concise videos can inform the
audience about everything they need to
know about the new product or service a
product announcement video on the other
hand can be used to give the audience a
more detailed look into the product or
service than the product showcase it can
include comparisons to older versions or
competitors the aim of such video is to
show customers how the new product works
and why they need it
now this video needs no introduction
Apple's iPhone videos have always been
short but smooth sleek and concise
representations of what the product
would be like
next at number 5 we have event
announcements these videos can build a
hype regarding an upcoming event it will
also give you the opportunity to engage
with your audience and will their
interest
this promo video for the data Innovation
Summit 2020 Hypes up the event posting
the greatest Minds in the tech the most
Innovative companies and much more
the next video idea we have at number 6
is the explainer videos these videos are
aimed to tell users how a particular
product or a service works these tend to
be much more useful than wall of text
explaining how something works they also
have an added advantage of simplifying
complex Concepts and features to your
audience for example we have our own
video on digital marketing we cover a
number of different concepts like SEO
social media marketing search engine
marketing and more on a visual manner
making it more likely to grab the
attention of a viewer
next at number seven we have tutorials
tutorial videos give users some
actionable insights and knowledge that
your users can learn from these videos
aim to be guides to information complex
Concepts hints tips and tricks relating
to your industry here we have our own
digital marketing course video as an
example unlike the previous example I
mentioned this video goes into much more
detail regarding each of the concepts of
digital marketing on that note if you
guys are interested in learning about
digital marketing I suggest you start
from this video it's a great one to get
started with now on the next video idea
at number eight we have the product
tutorial a product tutorial video will
take your audience through the various
features of your product offers
alongside its intricacies it can also
detail some additional insights about
your product you can also explain the
best way the product can be used
here is a video of how the meditation
app headspace explains the app's usage
with an interesting and creative
animated video
now let's go ahead with number nine at
the number nine we have the webinar a
webinar thanks to its nature provides
your brand with loads of opportunities
to interact with your audience they are
usually very accessible and easy to make
they are also very cost effective and
can be reused as video content after the
session is complete here's an example of
Simply learns webinar where we talk to
the industry experts regarding wide
variety of topics while involving the
Audience by having the guest answer the
audience questions whenever possible
next at number 10 we have the live
streams live streams for an event will
help build excitement and hype for the
event it can be advertised on other
social media platforms to generate some
hype as well these videos can also help
you bring up your product to a larger
audience and at a reduced cost
here's an example of a live stream that
constantly keeps a track of subscribers
increasing for some of the most popular
YouTube channels next at number 11 we
have Ama or ask me anything sessions
the AMA or ask me anything sessions are
usually live streams or pre-recorded
sessions that feature questions
collected from the audience although it
originated from Reddit these videos are
finding a success on YouTube thanks to
the interactivity that it offers these
sessions can also give your audience the
opportunity to interact with you provide
suggestions feedback and much more
here's an example of AMA session with
the actor Matt Damon where questions
covering a wide variety of topics
collected from Reddit were answered by
him
next at number 12 we have interviews
interviewing someone interesting or of
an authority within your Niche can go a
long way to grow your audience these
sessions are doubly advantageous too
firstly you and by extension your
audience get to interact with an
industry style word and since this video
can be shared on your channel as well as
theirs you can expose your channel to a
brand new audience here's an example of
an interview between Marcus Brownlee a
popular Tech YouTuber with Bill Gates
the interview covers a wide variety of
topics and maintains a pleasant theme
throughout let's now go to number 13
testimonials a testimonial video help
highlight the positive feedback from a
client or a customer they provide social
proof and provide a unique perspective
on your products and services these
videos can greatly help improve people's
trust on your brand shareability and
credibility here's an example of Simply
learns testimonial video that covers a
learner's Journey as he grew in his
career video thanks to Simply learn
certification a video like this can be
greatly relatable to the audience and
even encourage some of them to take up a
certification let's go to our next video
idea that is the number 14 whiteboard
videos a whiteboard video offers your
visually attractive way of explaining
complex Concepts usually this involves
the trained experts breaking through a
complex topic on a whiteboard nowadays
there has also been the trend of digital
whiteboard videos that work thanks to
the visual style and Charisma of the
narrator here is an example of the
Whiteboard video Simply learn created
covering various concepts of social
media marketing with the help of an
engaging narrative and interesting
visuals next up we have number 15
competitions competitions or contest
videos give your audience the
opportunity to get involved with your
channel these videos enable you to
generate fresh and original content with
little from your end
in an interesting example for foldable
flight Channel users submitted their
ideas for paper airplanes that would go
to the farthest distance the channel
received a significant amount of
submissions and saw considerable growth
next we have 16 the lists list videos
are some of the most commonly found
content on YouTube most users enjoy this
type of content thanks to it being small
easily digestible and bite-sized
these videos can cover a wide range of
topics like options to choose from the
best products techniques and much more
the main advantage of these videos are
they provide users with value while
further involving them with your channel
here is an example of a list that we
have created on the top 10 skills you
need to become a data analyst in the
year 2021 if you are interested don't
forget to check it out at number 17 we
have case studies case studies talk
about how your product or service have
benefited clients and users
videos like this can greatly improve
relatability and making your brand seem
more likeable
here's a video that analyzes Coca-Cola's
marketing campaign and what it made one
of the most popular brands in the world
now let's talk about content that may
not be necessarily for a brand but for
individual creators at number 18 we have
Tech unboxing these videos usually
involve packages being open for the
first time while these are fairly common
for technology these videos have also
found success in fashion apparel these
videos enable the users to experience
the products for the first time
sometimes even helping them decide
between rival products here's an example
of PS5 being inboxed by Marcus Brownlee
who goes into detail regarding each of
its console components controllers and
other specifications at number 19 we
have tech reviews where tech reviews you
can talk about the various features of a
particular product what you liked about
it what you didn't its price and other
practical information and much more
here we have an example of OnePlus 8 Pro
being reviewed in detail covering its
many features advantages disadvantages
and much more and finally we have number
20 reaction videos reaction videos are
exactly what the name says you giving an
emotional reaction to something like a
movie trailer music video or TV episode
these videos encourage a large amount of
Engagement from the audience and make
your brand seem more relatable here's an
example of a reaction video involving
teenagers reacting to the latest tech
talk videos these videos usually enable
a large amount of likes comments and
shares today we're going to talk about
how to increase YouTube subscribers so
with YouTube It's All About subscribers
the number of subscribers you have on
YouTube it's just one of the key metrics
to measure success so gaining more
subscribers can help you achieve more
view counts on your YouTube videos so
it's all all about how to get
subscribers and today we're going to
talk about how to get more subscribers
and before we begin let's just show you
what we did at simply learn so if we
look at the past 365 days on our YouTube
channel you can see we started here back
in uh if we look back at March 9 2018 we
had 208 and you can see just over the
course of the year it kept creeping up
creeping up creeping up and creeping up
we've gained you know a significant
number of subscribers over the last year
and what's our secret well it's posting
videos so you can see we've posted a
number of videos over the course of the
year and then our subscribers have gone
basically 165 percent over the last year
so you can see it's part of it is about
posting videos because when you post
videos you have people who can watch
those videos we have people watch those
videos you can have engagement and then
when you have engagement you have shares
and people who like it and then other
people will see it so it's kind of a
halo effect so to speak so getting
subscribers it takes a lot more than
just posting videos and today we're
going to talk about some tips to help
you increase the subscriptions so let's
start out with some of those tips we're
going to start with creating engagement
informative content so engaging in
informative content that's where we're
going to start talking today about how
to increase subscriptions then we're
going to talk about publishing videos
frequently so if it's simply learn you
could see the past 365 days we were
consistent in publishing videos
consistently throughout the month and
the weeks so another tip we're going to
talk about is how to optimize your
YouTube videos so there's a lot that
goes into optimization but this is a key
key tip to pay attention to because when
it comes to posting publishing videos on
YouTube you need to align certain things
like keywords and content and metadata
so optimize on our videos we're going to
talk a lot about that then we're going
to talk about optimizing the the YouTube
channel so there's some tips and tricks
here you want to do to optimize your
YouTube channel producing high quality
videos we're going to talk about that
adding a subscriber Watermark to your
videos okay that's another tip we're
going to mention today engage with our
audience okay that's what we want to do
we want to engage with our audience
that's a really key tip we're saving the
best for last promote your videos and
different platforms so all of these tips
we're going to talk about today so let's
get started and talk about create
engaging informative content so that's
the first place we want to start okay so
create engaging and informative content
so if we want to gain more subscribers
on our Channel we have to create highly
engage in and informative content why
because not our audience is not going to
pay attention and they're not going to
watch the video and then the
engagement's not going to be high and
they're not going to share the video and
they're not going to tell their friends
or like it and so this is where it all
starts you have to be able to plan your
content and not only planning your
content but you gotta create it so it's
engaging and informative so how do you
do that well let's talk about that so
the first thing is you have to know your
audience okay so when you create a video
who you're creating the video for I mean
that's where it all starts so when
you're creating your content you're
creating your content for your audience
you're not creating it for the entire
world now we know on YouTube there's a
lot of cute videos about kittens and
jokes and you know people playing games
and you know everybody likes positive
things on YouTube but you know when
we're talking about a specific topic you
know we really have to hone in on a
target audience and so if you know who
your audience is then you can really
hone in on your content okay so that's
the first thing ask yourself who is your
audience and then build your content
around that specific audience don't
build it just for the Mass general
population because it's not going to be
engaging and informative so that's the
first place to start then you want to
engage that that audience with relevant
content so if you know your audience and
depending on the topic you want to make
sure that whatever the topic is the
content matches the topic don't there
off course if you Veer off course you're
not going to engage your viewers your
viewers are coming to watch the video
for specific reason the reason is the
topic okay so if they're your target
audience and they want to watch the
video that's a specific topic then the
content has to align so plan your video
script so if you know who your audience
is and you know you want to engage them
with relevant content go ahead and plan
the script out so what I normally do is
you know have an outline and then once I
have the outline then I go ahead and
create my slides if I will or my topics
points I want to talk about and then I
write out those points I want to make
sure I get all my points in and that's
what you should be doing you want to
plan it ahead of time so that you can
get all your relevant points across
that's what makes a video informative
okay you want to ensure to give maximum
information to your audience so the key
here is maximum information so you don't
want to overload the audience but then
again you want to cut out information so
you want to make sure that when you're
planning your script and you're writing
the outline that you're making sure you
include all your points that you want to
get across once you include those points
then go ahead and you know write your
script and make sure all the information
for all those points are in the script
that's how you're going to ensure you
give maximum information but you don't
want to overdo it so if you feel like
it's too much information it probably is
too much information back off a little
use the information to create another
video so it's all about knowing your
audience so all of these points play
against one another so be clear and use
more examples in your content just like
we're doing here okay just like at the
beginning of the session I showed you an
example of Simply learn subscribers over
the past 365 days and so that's what we
want to do we want to be clear but use
examples to to punctuate the content or
the point we're trying to get across so
we want to include sources from high
quality sites so if you're going to use
examples make sure they're from relevant
high quality sites when I make high
quality meaning does your audience know
who that source is or that site if it's
really specific and your audience may
not know then it's probably not high
quality so just keep that in mind always
play to your audience so you want to
start your video with an interesting
hook so again I get back to this example
if you're still watching this then the
hook worked we showed you our
subscriptions we showed you how we grew
over the course of a year you could see
our growth and part of it was posting a
lot of videos with relevant and
informative content and so you see how
we did it so you're paying attention you
want to know how to do it and so part of
what we did is exactly what I'm telling
you now we know who our audience is we
plan out our scripts we use good
examples and we start our videos with
interesting hooks now one when we do our
videos we also create original content
so that goes back to planning your
script okay you always want to you know
come across as original and informative
when you do that you're going to be
engaging but if you're leveraging
somebody else's content then the
engaging part may not resonate because
it's not your content to begin with so
always always always use original
content okay so keep the content flow
organized so again that goes back to an
outline you know feel free to change up
the outline so the flow makes sense add
visuals to your content and make it
appealing always include images to me if
you can use images in your videos and
play off the video or the images then
it's just gonna flow and make it a
little bit more engaging and appealing
meaning the content so visuals help
guide and Aid in the points you're
trying to make so don't make it so text
Heavy you know accentuate it balance it
with some images use Simple language and
crisp sentences meaning mean don't
choose jargon don't come across and talk
above your audience you always want to
talk to your audience and talk in a
language that they're going to
understand so it goes back to point one
if you know who your audience is you're
talking to them as if they're right in
front of you and not you're above them
or they're below you you want to talk at
them so add cards and screens and
pattern interrupts to engage your
audience and so YouTube cards or just
interactive panels that slide in and out
when a video is playing so it encourages
interaction by the viewer okay so you
can add up to five cards which include
images text or clickable links so feel
free to play around with some of these
features that YouTube has to offer to
make your content more engaging so tip
two publish videos frequently so
creating and uploading videos
consistently will help you increase your
YouTube subscribers so suppose you
haven't published videos from more than
say a month or two months it's likely
that that audience not going to
subscribe to your channel so think about
YouTube videos as a popular TV program
that comes on once a week when a new
episode comes on based on the regular
schedule it's consistency and that
consistency is what helps your users
stay engaged so for example if I go back
to our YouTube channel you know what
helped us gain subscribers was our
consistency in publishing videos you
could see we were consistent in
publishing a couple of videos a week
every couple of weeks and so this helps
users stay engaged they know when the
video is coming out they know that
simply learn is good for two three four
videos a month and the great thing about
publishing videos is that when somebody
does subscribe to your channel they're
gonna get a notification or YouTube has
an option where they can get a
notification via email so I subscribe to
Simply learns Channel I subscribe to
other channels like Google analytics for
example so anytime Google analytics
publishes a video I get an email that
says Hey Google analytics YouTube
channel just published a video and the
great thing is I'm checking my email and
I'm getting this notification in Gmail
so guess what I can watch the video
right then and there just by clicking on
the link in the email I don't even have
to go to the channel but knowing that if
you publish consistently and somebody
does get the email once a week then it's
more likely they're going to engage
especially if the content is original
engaging and informative so frequent
video publishing equals more
subscriptions so according to Social
Media examiner YouTube channels that
publish videos more than once a week are
performing much better so if you can
afford to publish more videos more than
once a week the chances of you gaining
subscribers quicker are going to be
greater so keeping a fixed frequency can
help you quickly gain more subscribers
posting videos is like almost like
blogging I always say start small if you
could do one blog post a month and then
once you get in a routine then you can
ramp up the frequency so from one blog
post you could do two a month then four
times a month and once a week or twice a
week same with the YouTube videos you
want to get into a rhythm you know start
with once a month and ramp it up okay
you'll find that the more you ramp it up
the more subscribers you're gonna get so
tip three optimize your YouTube videos
so optimizing your videos will help your
content rank higher on YouTube so this
is a give must it's not a given it's a
must you must optimize your videos if
you want people to see them of course if
you don't optimize people aren't going
to see them then people aren't going to
engage and and then not subscribe so
it's just kind of a snowball effect so
this is an important tip so I mentioned
at the beginning when we were going over
all the items we're going to discuss
this is the one item that is a must and
a given to some degree because if you
don't optimize your videos are just not
going to be found so you need that
audience to watch your video so
audiences who tend to interact more with
your content have more chance to
subscribe to your channel but they're
not going to subscribe if they don't
even watch your video so there is a
snowball effect in play here if we don't
optimize your videos so okay Rob what
are some of the tips to optimize your
YouTube video well let's go through some
of those tips so to ensure your videos
reaches the relevant audience on YouTube
you need to optimize the title
description in the video tag okay Rob
what do you mean by title description
and video tag so let's take a look at
that so when you actually create your
YouTube video you're going to have an
opportunity to put in a title you're
going to have an opportunity to put in
the description and you're going to have
an opportunity to add text so those are
the three key areas okay so once you put
in that what it looks like on the front
end is this so if I go back to YouTube
and here you can see another video that
we did about a month ago you could see
what is SEO so if that's our topic
that's our title uh or of the content of
the video then the title of the video is
going to be what is SEO and you can see
we also added in some other content for
the title so what is SEO and how does it
work SEO tutorial for beginners and then
our brand name so we have some content
to work with for the title okay and then
the description we have a lot of
characters to work with descriptions so
use as much as you can here to describe
what the video is about here you can see
we did that and so it's always good to
include this information okay and then
you can see we have tags up here seo seo
tutorial for beginners digital marketing
so we put in the necessary information
here on this video to help us rank
because if we don't optimize it we're
not going to rank and so you can see we
just put a lot of relevant content
around the description around the title
and around those tags by doing so we're
able to optimize this video you and get
found so that's just an example three of
the things you can do to help optimize
your YouTube video so if you want to
watch more on how to optimize meta tags
then I suggest maybe watching the other
video we did on the subject how to rank
YouTube videos so this goes into more
detail about how to optimize the title
The Meta description and The Meta tags
but there's a three quick fields or
areas that you can use to optimize your
video so just something to keep in mind
write a long description with keywords
timestamps and links so what I mean by
timestamps for timestamp and audience
can choose the section of the video that
they want to look for and then links
prefer to include relevant Links of your
other videos so those are just some
additional tips to help keep your
content engaging so remember when your
content is engaging then people are
going to like it people are going to
share it and watch it later so upload a
captivating thumbnail okay so you want
to include thumbnail that's going to
grab people's attention you want to
upload a transcript of the video so that
goes back to when you're creating your
content when you write your original
content you want to keep a transcript of
the content of the video so that you can
upload that as well and then add a start
screen and end screen to your YouTube
videos so that way you know it's
somebody plays the video they're going
to see it what it looks like up front
and then the way you finish it they're
going to see an end screen at the end
and so you just don't want to keep it
dark and black and non-descriptive so
according to backlinko using an exact
keyword in your video title can help you
with rankings so high ranking more views
more views more subscribers so that's
what I've been saying all along you need
to get these videos optimized so again
use an exact keyword in your video title
so let's go back again to that video I
just showed you a couple minutes ago
what is SEO so here we started out with
a question what is SEO that's the name
of the title that's one exact title all
of the video that's our exact keyword
okay so what is SEO and how does it work
and then SEO tutorial for beginners so
what is SEO is our exact keyword and
that's part of the video that's the
content of the video that's in the title
and we use it throughout the description
as well so using that exact keyword in
your video title can help with the
ranking so whatever your topic is your
title of the video or the topic of the
video included in the title so backlinko
also mentions that there is a moderate
correlation between a Channel's total
subscribers and rankings and so for some
of you this may be common sense it's
just like organic search if you're not
ranking you're not going to get traffic
on YouTube if you're not ranking you're
not going to get eyeballs on your videos
and you're not going to get subscribers
so higher rankings can help you to get
more subscribers but you can't get those
rankings unless you optimize and so
again just for the sake of Simplicity
going back focus in on your title make
sure your title match is the title of
the video itself when you're publishing
your description use all the amount of
content available to you so you can see
this entire description has a lot of
content maximize the content and then
use tags using those three Fields those
three areas can help you optimize your
video and gain the necessary ranking you
need to get viewers which will turn into
subscribers so tip four optimize your
YouTube channel so we just talked about
optimizing our videos now we're going to
turn our attention to our YouTube
channel so one of the easiest ways to
ask your viewers to subscribe to your
channel is really by creating a good not
even a good a great YouTube channel
trailer you also want to add Channel
keywords a description and some good
artwork and then having sections and
playlists to keep your videos organized
these are all good tips to creating a
good YouTube channel so let's talk about
some some of these these tips here so we
want to give your audience a preview
what your channel is offering so this is
by hooking your audience with the
trailer so you can create a trailer to
you know just give your audience an idea
of who you are as a brand what kind of
videos you're going to be posting and
give them a kind of a taste of what the
future videos are going to be like okay
you can even tell them your release
schedule and the trailer so you can
start off by saying hey hey guys we're
new to this we're going to be posting
one video a month but as we get rolling
maybe two per month and you know one per
week you know just being honest and open
and talking to your audience and get
them excited about future videos that's
what the trailer is all about so you
also want to keep it that the channel
description's short and interesting so
in your channel you want to have a
description of what the channel is all
about what kind of videos you're going
to be posting so in addition to the
trailer you want to write something
short and interesting then we want to
use keywords in our Channel descriptions
just like in the videos with what is SEO
we included what is SEO in the title we
included you know what is SEO in the
description and so we want to be true to
what our channel is so pick keywords not
only include those keywords in the
videos but include them in the channel
description pay attention to the first
100 to 150 characters I have your
channel description because that's
what's shown next your channel on the
search results so for example here you
can see we have a description here
simply learn is one of the world's
leading certification training providers
we partner with companies and
individuals to address and so you can
see those characters 100 to 150 or what
shows up in the channel description when
somebody's trying to understand hey
simply learn just uploaded this video
who is simply learning so you want to
write short interesting Channel
description so that when somebody's
first introduced to your video they
could see what your Brand's all about so
in your description with an appropriate
call to action so short interesting good
call to action at the end of the video a
good call to action would be hey check
out our next video or check out our
latest video something that's going to
gauge somebody and get them to watch one
of your videos so you want to pick
interesting channel art so let's turn
our attention to the simply learn
Channel page and here you can see we
recently had reached a milestone so
recently reached the 200 000 K
subscribers so 200 000 subscribers is a
big achievement for simply learn we went
ahead and updated our channel art and
I'm sure we will reach 500k we'll update
the artwork then too but the point is
you want to keep your channel art kind
of interesting hip and cool and feel
free to change it out every once in a
while so you have that option in YouTube
to do I mean it's very simple so here
you can see simply learns Channel if we
go home we get all our videos listed
here we got the about us you know
something very short and interesting
about us here's our call to action for
more information visit simply learn so
you want to make sure when you create
your channel get some good artwork in
there put your description in play and
create your first videos and get them
posted up there and optimize them
accordingly okay so this is the other
tips to go with that channel art and
description is a profile picture
relevant to your brand so you always
want to maybe put the the company logo
up there okay so here you can see we
have the company logo at Accurate
relevant Channel keywords so if we go
back to who we are who are we we're the
world's leading certification training
provider okay that's who we are okay we
partner with companies and individuals
so we're all about training and training
is one of our keywords so you can see
let's simply learn we provide online
training and machine learning AWS Amazon
web services devops Big Data digital
marketing project management a lot of
different topics so make sure or that's
included in the channel description
feature the playlist on your home page
so if we go back to the home page we can
see here we have our channels so you can
see we have ai machine learning trending
Technologies cloud computing tutorials
devops tutorials popular videos big data
we have a lot of different channels so
you want to organize your videos into
different playlists so those playlists
are going to feature on the home page of
your channel so how you organize the
playlist is totally up to you but I
would certainly create a playlist for
different sections so depending on your
product your services think about how
you want to organize don't just stick
all your videos in one playlist then
optimize the playlist titles and
descriptions for search rankings so just
like the videos themselves just like the
channel description you have an
opportunity to optimize the playlist
titles and descriptions so be very keen
on aligning the right keyword with the
playlist title so here you can see
programming language tutorials project
management tutorials digital marketing
tutorials so we're very clear on how we
go about choosing our titles because we
want to optimize those playlist titles
okay we can rearrange our videos in a
playlist so we want to rearrange the
videos in a way that we're maybe putting
the freshest the most newest the video
that's been published last first so
almost in descending order if you will
so we want our users to see what video
has the latest in that particular
playlist so they're seeing the most
recent first but you can rearrange your
videos any way you want feel free to
play around with it of course you can
also take the video that's the most
popular and put that up front so people
could see that first vice versa you can
take a video that maybe hasn't gotten a
lot of views or is it ranked
particularly High maybe put that video
up so it can get some views and some
shares and likes so know how you
rearrange your videos is totally up to
you just have some rationale behind that
so choose a playlist thumbnail from a
top performing video so for example if I
go back to our YouTube page you can see
the top performing videos here you know
for example this one we got a nice
thumbnail here what is machine learning
so if I click on that think wisely most
popular videos so 3 000 likes on this
video a lot of views 250 000 plus views
so have a thumbnail to go along with
that particular video so according to
backlinko YouTube SEO ranking Factor
study discovered that channel keywords
have a small yet significant correlation
with Higher YouTube search rankings so
Channel key words so when you're
optimizing your channel and you want to
include keywords start with your
description so if I go back to our
Channel okay if I go back about us make
sure your description has those relevant
keywords in it that's where it all
starts so in case you have any doubts if
you're not sure about everything we
talked about on optimizing the channel
go ahead and drop a comment below
because we do respond to every comment
that gets posted on our videos so if
you're not sure how to go about
optimizing your channel when you say
align keywords with the channel what
does that really mean so if you want
some clarity on that go ahead and drop
us a channel if you're not sure about
the trailer video drop us a comment
we're more than happy to expand upon the
explanation of how to best optimize your
channel okay tip number five produce
high quality videos so we need to get in
the habit of producing high quality
videos because viewers don't prefer to
watch videos that have poor audio and
video quality it's just that simple you
need to know what it takes to produce
high quality videos if you don't you're
just going to discredit you're not going
to come across as relevant you know I'm
going to come across is qualified
professional there's a lot of things
attached to poor quality videos so we
need to create high quality videos for
the end users so let's talk about some
ways in which you can create high
quality videos and so the first is to
avoid any noise in the background so you
want to have a nice quiet atmosphere no
distractions so people can hear you
clearly and only you clearly you want to
use good audio recording equipment
there's plenty of options available on
the internet usually I would recommend
going with something paid not overly
expensive because you get what you pay
for so if you use something free it
might not be of good quality and you
might not have all the features and
bells and whistles with a free option so
you know use good audio recording
equipment again it can be online or it
could be some software just make sure
that you're able to produce good high
quality video and audio so when you do
purchase that audio recording equipment
you want to have something similar to an
input volume meter that way you can see
whether your audio is coming across or
not so if you're not seeing green lights
then your audio is not coming across if
it's red it might be distorted and so
you want something that's going to
signify that you're really pushing out
good quality audio you want to create
your videos in 1080 pixel size okay
that's HD and so you want to have at
least minimum 1080. so anything less
than that's probably going to come
across as not so good maybe staticky
blurry not professional not high def so
you want to create a high def video and
1080 is about the minimum you want to go
and then you want to plan your video
script before filming so it goes back to
some of the other points I made earlier
you always want to have a video script
available so you know what you're saying
when you're recording your audio that
way you're not doing something on the
Fly then you want to use good lighting
for video recording so you don't want to
be in a dark place you want some nice
lighting so your video comes across well
lit people could see you they're not
struggling to strain their eyes on what
it is you're trying to show and appear
because of poor lighting again it just
comes across as professionals so if you
can you know shoot a high def video with
good audio speaking clearly having a
professional script with some good
lighting then people are going to take
you serious and they're going to start
to listen and engage and see the video
as good quality and very relevant and
informative and share it so use slow
motion and jump Cuts wisely so there's
some features you could do with your
video I mean using slow motion and jump
cuts are some of the features you can
use to accentuate your points and then
set up a green background for recording
again this is for you know making sure
that the video part of it comes across
in good quality and stabilize your video
recordings with a tripod that way you're
not moving your video cam camera all
around and again it's coming across the
shaky and poor quality shoot horizontal
videos you don't want to go vertical it
tends to cut the screen so you want to
stay horizontal so that people can see
everything that should be included in
the video okay you want to capture a
wider shot using a clip-on lens again a
good feature good tip to use use that
wider shot okay so you could do that
using a clip-on lens and then choose
good video editing software I can't
State this enough because you're putting
all this time and effort into a video
you need to be able to edit it to cut
out you know some of the things you
didn't want to say or maybe some poor
quality or or you know you just want to
have a smooth professional output for
your video and so you gotta have good
video editing software there's plenty of
options available on the internet again
I would go with something low cost but
paid usually free isn't exactly the way
you want to go if you're trying to
create a high def good quality video and
the very least review your work before
publishing I just said it a minute ago
I'll say it again you want to be able to
have a really professional video and
high def when you have a good
professional video in high def with good
audio horizontal shots you know nice
green background image nice well lit
it's going to come across as
professional and if you have a
professional video then people are going
to take you seriously they're going to
see you as a professional and then share
or subscribe and like and then they're
going to watch more videos and and
that's how you start to build up a
reputation as being a very professional
organization so just following these
simple tips on producing high quality
videos so you want to review your work
because if you don't you put all that
effort into it and then you're going to
realize hey your video is low quality
and then you're gonna have to do it all
over again so follow these tips get a
high quality video and you should be on
your way to ranking in fact according to
backlinko you two preferably a ranks HD
videos so you gotta have that 1080 pixel
size that way you know your video is
going to come across crisp and clear and
YouTube prefers that tip six add a
subscriber Watermark to your videos so
this is a great feature in YouTube so
it's a feature that allows you to add a
watermark that can be shown on all your
videos the reason why you want that
Watermark because you want to keep
reminding your audience to subscribe to
your Channel The Watermark can be
whatever you want but normally it's
going to be some type of logo or brand
and a call to action and so how do you
add a watermark to your video well you
log into your YouTube account it's it's
pretty simple at the top right corner
you're going to select your creator
Studio icon and then you're going to go
to channel select branding and then add
a watermark to your video so if we look
at that in YouTube so here Creator
Studio on the left side navigation I'm
just going to click Channel then I'm
going to click branding and then once
you click brand name you have the
ability to add your watermark and then
you can add it to the entire video at
the end of the video at a specific start
time and then just click update and
that's pretty much it so you want to be
able to add this so that you can brand
your videos with an image and then add
that CTA so this is a good good feature
for YouTube it allows you to be
consistent with all your videos by
branding and adding that call to action
tip 7 engage with your audience so you
want to be able to interact with your
audience as much as possible just
because of the video and you can't see
people doesn't mean you can't engage
with them so when you interact with your
viewers especially when you interact
with them immediately there's
gratification you know everybody likes
to be responded to nobody likes to be
ignored and so when somebody is
responded to there's a higher chance
that your viewers are likely to gonna
become customers it's just customer
service is how you really want to look
at this okay so when you engage you're
creating a service for your customers so
here are some tips on how to engage with
your audience so first is at the end of
every video convey a thank you message
to your viewers you know thank you for
spending the time out of every busy day
to watch this video you know some of our
videos go an hour plus long and so when
somebody's taking an hour to watch a
video it's only the least you can do is
thank them now you can thank them and
give them some information about where
to go for more information because if
they watch the whole video they're
already engaged and they're probably
going to want to learn more so you
always want to follow up to thank you
with where to go for more information
just like our videos always convey at
the end okay you always want to ask your
audience for their feedback or ideas on
the video so with YouTube there's a
comment section and you always want to
encourage comments so comments can be in
the form of feedback so as you're
watching this video feel free to leave
feedback on on other ways to engage with
your audience or some other tips to
increase your subscribers on YouTube so
we're always looking for those ideas we
want to keep it engaging so somebody may
have some other ideas that we didn't
think about and so we always appreciate
that from our audience so we very much
appreciate the feedback that our
audience gives us so not all the
feedback there's always going to be
positive some of the feedback could be
less than positive or even negative
there could be mistakes so the idea
behind getting feedback is you want to
look at it you want to read it and you
want to react to it you want to react to
it positively in the form of you know
what thank you for the feedback and
looking at the feedback weighing it and
incorporating the feedback so you don't
always want to make the same mistake
twice in a video so if there's something
definitely wrong with the video that
we're doing for example and somebody
looked at it and gave us feedback on it
we'd certainly definitely take a deep
look into that and try not to do the
same mistake twice because likely that
you is going to watch the video again so
you always want to learn from your
mistakes and you want to turn those
mistakes or turn those comments into
future videos